JUNE SECOND ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
HEARING- MY NAME IS THERE AND
IT INVOLVES I AM SORRY I'M
TAKING OFF MY MASK BECAUSE I
CANNOT KEEP MY GLASSES FROM
FOGGING UP. SO BUT I APPRECIATE
EVERYBODY WHO IS. WEARING MASK
AND SOCIAL DISTANCING. I'M WE
ARE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND START
BY ESTABLISHING A QUORUM
BECAUSE THAT'S MOST IMPORTANT
PIECE OF. ORDER BUSINESS THAT
WE NEED TO START WITH IF MADAM
SECRETARY IF YOU CALL THE ROLL.
GONZALEZ PRESENT BIGELOW
PRESENT. FARRAKHAN BLOOM BONTA
CALDERON CARRILLO GEL. DOLLY
DEEP EGGMAN PHONE GABRIEL. YOU
GARCIA. PETRIE-NORRIS MCCARTY
FOR QUIRK. ROBERT RIVAS VOEPEL
REPUBLICAN VACANCY THANK CORPS.
ALL RIGHT. BEFORE WE START I'M
GOING TO JUST FOR I KNOW THAT.
FOR HOME A LOT MORE PEOPLE ARE
WATCHING THE NORMAL IN THIS
COMMITTEE CAN BE A LITTLE BIT
CONFUSING IN- IT'S NOT LIKE
EVERY OTHER COMMITTEE- IN THE
CAPITAL SO WE'RE GONNA EXPLAIN
JUST BRIEFLY WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN TODAY AND WHAT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN TOMORROW. WE HAVE
THREE HUNDRED AND SEVEN BILLS
IN FRONT OF US TO CONSIDER
TODAY. THERE ARE NUMBER OF
THINGS THAT WILL HAPPEN WITH
THOSE BILLS AT A GOOD CHUNK OF
THOSE BILLS- THAT COST OVER A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS WILL BE SENT TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE. THAT FILE WILL
BE DISPENSED OF TOMORROW MOST
OF THOSE BILLS MOST OF THOSE
AUTHORS OF WAVES AS AN TATIAN
ON THOSE BILLS SO IF YOU HAVE A
BILL THAT SAYS ON THE SUSPENSE
OUT IN THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION THAT MEANS THERE
WILL BE NO DISCUSSION ABOUT
THAT BILL. NOW IF YOU'RE
LISTENING AT HOME AND YOU WANT
TO COMMENT ABOUT YOUR POSITION
AT THE VERY END WILL ALLOW YOU
AN OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH IN ON
THE BILL BUT THE AUTHOR DOES DO
A PRESENTATION THERE IS NO-
OPPOSITION PRESENTATION AS WELL.
AS IF IT A THE A NUMBER OF
BILLS WE WILL CONSIDER TODAY
THOSE WILL BE HEARD TODAY IT
LIKE A NORMAL BILL IN THOSE
VOTES WILL BE TAKEN TODAY WE
WILL ALLOW. TWO MINUTES OF-
SUPPORTIVE COMMENTS AND TWO
MINUTES OF COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION. AND THEN WE WILL GO
TO- SUPPORT OR OPPOSE. AND THE
ONLY. SPEAK TO IN SUPPORT
PROPOSITION IS THE FISCAL
ANALYSIS YOU CAN'T. I SPEAK TO
THE POLICY MATTER AT HAND SO
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT IF
YOU'RE ONE THE PEOPLE SPEAKING
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. TO A
BILL THAT ACTUALLY BEING
PRESENTED WE HAVE TO KEEP THE
COMMENTS TO FISCAL. WINDOWS
BILLS ARE HEARD- WE DON'T TAKE
A VOTE IN THE NORMAL A ROLL
CALL FASHION. THEY WILL EITHER
PASS ON IN A ROLL CALL- WHICH
MEANS WELL THE DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS VOTED FOR THE BILL-
OR ON A B. ROLL CALL WHICH IS
JUST THE DEMOCRATS VOTED ON A
BILL- IF IT'S A SEA ROLL CALL.
ME JUST THE REPUBLICANS VOTED
AND THAT WILL NOT PASS- OR JUST
DOESN'T PASS SO THOSE ARE THE
OPTIONS. THERE'S NO BILLS THAT
WILL GO ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
THAT MEANS THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION TO BILLS- IN THIS
CHAMBER A ON WILL VOTE ON THOSE
AS A GROUP TOGETHER. SO I HOPE
THAT HELPS EXPLAIN FOR A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHAT WILL BE SAID IT I'M
SURE IT WILL STILL BE SOME
CONFUSING. THOSE BE SEEN
CREATION BEFORE THAT I THINK
CAN GO VERY LONG AND SO TO
AVOID. THE STRIP IN THE POLLS
IT. WILL A LOT TRY TO BEYOND
THE RULES EITHER. A ANALYSIS IF
YOU'RE OF THE WITNESS AND
TESTIMONY OR SIMPLY SAYING YOUR
NAME IN YOUR POSSESSION. SO
THAT'S WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN
TODAY I WANT TO- WELCOME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAUER CAME TO
THE COMMITTEE IT'S HER FIRST
COMMITTEE HEARING. I AND I WANT
TO THANK MR MCCARTY MISTER
VOEPEL FOR SUBBING AND TODAY. I
WANT TO NOTE THAT THE FOLLOWING
BILLS HAVE BEEN PULLED BY THE
AUTHORS FROM THE AGENDA TODAY
SO THESE BILLS WILL NOT BE
HURT- WE OFTEN SAY THEY THEY'RE
HELD IN COMMITTEE THAT DOES NOT
MEAN. THAT THEY'RE HERE WAITING
TO BE HEARD THEY ARE DEAD AFTER
TWO DAYS OF THE FOLLOWING BILLS
HAVE BEEN PULLED BY THE AUTHOR.
AB THREE ZERO ZERO SEVEN BY MR
CHOW. AB TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY
FOUR BY MISTER LOW. AB TWENTY
TWO NINETEEN BY MISTER
O'DONNELL. AB THIRTY TWO
THIRTEEN BY THREE OF US IN AB
TWENTY NINE NINETY ONE BY
MISTER SANTIAGO SO THOSE BILLS
WILL NOT BE. ABLE NOT BE HEARD
TOMORROW- THEY ARE NO LONGER IN.
REALLY EXISTENCE. WE HAVE A
QUORUM- WE'RE GOING TO BE USING
PHONES TODAY WE HAD A PLAN TO
THAT SO I'M GOING TO APOLOGIZE
IN ADVANCE WE WERE HOPING FOR
TEST MONEY THROUGH THE PARK
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS AN UNUSUAL
APPROPRIATIONS HEARING BECAUSE
IT'S JUST ONE WE USUALLY HAVE
MULTIPLE ONES AND- WERE NOT
ONLY THE MIDDLE THE PANDEMIC
BUT ALSO- JUST FIGHT CIVIL
UNREST. SO IT'LL BE DIFFERENT
WE'RE GONNA YOU GUYS ARE GONNA
BE PATIENT. WITH US. WITHOUT
WE'RE GONNA GO AN AUTHOR ORDER
TODAY AS AUTHORS NO. YOU KNOW.
YOU CAN PRESENT ON A SUSPENSE
WELL- MOST AUTHORS DO NOT
RIGHTFULLY I AND- YOU CAN MAKE
A FOR ABBREVIATED HOPEFULLY
PRESENTATION ON THE BILLS IN
FRONT OF US WITHOUT MISTER
BERMAN YOUR FIRST UP AB TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR I ASSUME
YOU'RE YOU'RE NOT SPEAKING ON
YOUR SUSPENDS CANDIDATE CORRECT
THANK YOU MISTER BERMAN AB
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR ENJOYS
A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES
AB TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR
WOULD WITHOUT CREATING A
MANDATE ALLOW COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS TO USE RESTRICTED
LOTTERY FUNDS TO PROVIDE
HOUSING ASSISTANCE AND FOOD
ASSISTANCE TO STUDENTS OVER 60%
OF COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
HAVE A SURPLUS OF THESE
RESTRICTED WATER I HAVE A
MOTION BY- MISTER CALDERON IN A
SECOND BY MISTER A MAN I'M
SORRY TO HEAR THOSE EARLIER.
YEAH IS OF THIS NO THIS BILL
RESULT IN NO COST I RESPECT.
YOU MISTER BERMAN DO YOU HAVE
WHAT. I DO THINK WONDERFUL ARE
THERE- OF. DO I GO TO THE
PHONES TO ASK THE IF THERE IS
ANYBODY SPEAKING ON AB TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR. ANYBODY
REGISTERING SUPPORT OUR
OPPOSITION. LIKE TALKING TO THE
VOICE OF GOD WHO IS NOT
RESPONDING IS THERE AN OPERATOR
ON THE LINE. AND YOU WANT TO
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AT THIS
TIME. IF IT PERTAINS TO AB.
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR WE'RE
NOT ANTICIPATING ANY BUT IF
THERE IS WE WILL ACCEPT IT. DO
YOU WANT TO BREAK THAT UP INTO
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION OR TAKE
THEM ALL TOGETHER I WOULD LIKE
TO TAKE THE SUPPORTERS FIRST.
THANK YOU IF YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE
A COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WATER FROM
THE. NO ONE IN Q. AT THIS TIME
WOULD YOU LIKE TO MOVED
OPPOSITION I WOULD. THANK YOU
YOU LIKE TO QUEUE UP AND MAKE A
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
USING YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
MORNINGQUEUE FOR DISPOSITION
EITHER PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK
YOU SIR WHAT IS YOUR NAME. IT
MAY OR EIGHTEEN T. WILL BE FINE
BUT NICK. YEAH NICK THANK YOU
NICK. IT'S A LITTLE SURREAL TO
HEAR YOUR VOICE AND NOT BE ABLE
TO. ALL RIGHT. WITH THAT THEIR-
IS- NOBODY IN SUPPORT NOBODY IN
OPPOSITION IS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE PERSON WHO. YEAH
RIGHT. NO FOR NOTHING. OKAY
WE'RE NOT GONNA GO TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- WITH
THAT- NO QUESTIONS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CONCLUDE RESPECT THAT
ZERO THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
BERMAN THAT GETS OUT- WITH TE
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING AND
MISTER DO YOU HAVE AN MISTER
FONG VOTING HI. THANK YOU.
EXACTLY LOOK. ALL RIGHT I'VE
BEEN TOLD THE FINANCE WILL
ACTUALLY BE ON THE PHONE
SOMETIMES WE'RE GOING TO GO IN
ALPHABETICAL ORDER MISTER BLOOM
WOULD YOU LIKE TO GO TO HELL
THANK YOU YOU CAN SEE AT IF
YOU'RE IN THIS COMMITTEE YOU
CAN SPEAK FROM YOUR DESK IF YOU
SO CHOOSE BUT THANK YOU MISTER
BLOOM- MISTER BLOOM IS GONNA
PRESENT ON AB TWENTY TO SEVENTY
THREE IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION- AS AMENDED TO
CLARIFY ACADEMIC MEDICAL
CENTERS QUALIFY BY DEFINITION
AND DO NOT HAVE TO BE APPROVED
BY THE MEDICAL BOARD MR LIMITS
YOUR BILL. THANK YOU I ACCEPT
TWENTY TO SEVENTY THREE WOULD
ALLOW AN ACADEMIC MEDICAL
CENTER SPECIFICALLY CEDARS
SINAI WELL CENTER TO WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MS CARILLO AND A
SECOND BY MISTER CALDERON TO
SUBMIT CANDIDATES FOR SPECIAL
FACULTY PERMITS DIRECTLY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL BOARD. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ARRIVAL.
THANK YOU MISTER BROWN. NICK
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO THE PHONES
NOW ON AB TWENTY TO SEVENTY
THREE DO WE HAVE ANYBODY IN
SUPPORT. ANYONE LIKE TO SHARE
THE POSITION AND SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR NO
ONE IN Q. AT THIS TIME WE CAN
GET OPPOSITION PLEASE. IF YOUR
POSITION IS IN OPPOSITION YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
ALL IGHT LINE THEN. THANK YOU
SIR- I HAVE HERE THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE IS NOT ON THIS BILL
SO WITH THAT- SEEN NO SPEED NO
MEMBERS QUESTIONS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE MISTER BLOOM I
RESPECTFULLY AFTER A VOTE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU TAKE IT OUT ON A
ROLL CALL MISS BURKE. I DO NOT
SEE MISS BURKE HERE. THAT
REMINDS ME AS LONG AS. MADAM
SECRETARY ACTUALLY LET'S GO
AHEAD IN- READ OUT THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. THAT'S ALRIGHT ARE
YOU READY FOR THAT IF NOT WE
CAN MOVE ON. THANK YOU. THESE
ARE THE BILLS THAT ARE GOING ON
CONSENT WERE IN TAKE ONE VOTE
ON ALL THESE BILLS WITHOUT
COMMENT. REGULAR KERRY TWENTY
TWO TEN FARRAKHAN. TWENTY FIVE
FIFTY NINE BIGELOW. TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY SIX TWENTY FOUR
FIFTY NINE BOERNER HORVATH
NINETEEN FORTY NINE WITH THE
MINUTES BRO THIRTY EIGHTY SEVEN.
CHAO. TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY NINE JAN
THIRTY ONE SIXTY ONE. JUNE
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY CHOI TWENTY
FOUR FIFTY FOUR JUNE NINETEEN
SIXTY THREE TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT COOLEY TWENTY FORTY NINE
EGGMAN NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX. IN
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY SEVEN FLORA
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SIX FONG
TWENTY OH SIX FRAZIER THIRTY
NINETY SEVEN GALLAGHER TWENTY
NINETY SEVEN TWENTY ONE FIFTY
ONE ACR SEVENTY THREE. CRISTINA
GARCIA. TWENTY ONE OH FOUR
TWENTY TO SEVENTY NINE GIPSON
TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY NINE.
GLORIA TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY ONE
THIRTY TWO THIRTY FOUR. GREAT
THIRTY ONE THIRTY NINE GRAYSON
TWENTY TWO THIRTY TWO IRWIN
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY EIGHT
THIRTY TO FORTY TWO. JONES
SAWYER 232-130-4320 THIRTY TWO
SEVENTY SEVEN. KALRA. TWENTY
FIVE FORTY TWO TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY EIGHT LEVINE THIRTY ONE
SEVENTY FIVE. LOW TWENTY TWO
EIGHTY EIGHT TWENTY THREE
ELEVEN MAIENSCHEIN NINETEEN
EIGHTY FOUR MATHIS TWENTY ONE
FORTY ONE MEDINA. TWENTY FIVE
FORTY ONE TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY
THREE MULLIN TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
OBERNOLTE. TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY
NINE TWENTY EIGHT FORTY FOUR
TWENTY NINE TWENTY THIRTY SIXTY
TWO  TWENTY NINE SIXTY
SEVEN PETRIE-NORRIS TWENTY
SIXTY EIGHT. TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
TWO QUIRK TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED
WITH THE MOMENT TWENTY FIVE
SIXTY. QUIRK SILVA TWENTY TWO
FIFTY FIVE RAMOS NINETEEN FIFTY
EIGHT ROBERT RIVAS. TWENTY ONE
SIXTY FIVE RODRIGUEZ TWENTY
THREE SIXTY FIVE. DOCTOR RUBIO
NINETEEN TWENTY NINE SMITH
THIRTY TO SIXTY SEVEN MARK
STONE TWENTY NINE FORTY FOUR.
EL TWENTY FORTY SIX THIRTY ONE
THIRTY SEVEN. WEEKS THIRTY
SEVENTY THREE. WOOD TWENTY ONE
THIRTY SEVEN COMMITTEE BUILT ON
CONSENT CALENDAR CAMINO
TRANSPORTATION TWENTY THIRTY
EIGHT. COMMITTEE TWENTY ONE OH
ONE VETERANS AFFAIRS TWENTY ONE
NINETY TWO THIS IS AN FOR
PROFESSIONS TWENTY FIFTY FOUR.
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS THIRTY TWO SIXTY ONE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
336-233-6330 THREE SIXTY FOUR
THIRTY THREE FIFTY FIVE ARTS
COMMITTEE THIRTY THREE SIXTY
NINE VETERANS AFFAIRS THIRTY
THREE SEVENTY ONE RED AND TAX.
THIRTY THREE SEVENTY TWO AND
HIGHER EDUCATION THIRTY THREE
SEVENTY FOUR. THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY THOSE ARE NON
CONTROVERSIAL BILLS WHERE THERE
HAS NOT BEEN- OPPOSITION AND-
AS WITH THAT WILL TAKE THE
MOTION BY MISTER BIGELOW AND A
SECOND. BYE BYE MISTER
CALDERON- MAN SECOND CHERRY
BACK IT'S OUT ON IN A ROLL CALL.
IF YOU AN NOW NOW WHAT WE'RE
GONNA DO AND I AM IF YOU CAN
REMOVE YOUR MASK TO READ THESE
I'M A LITTLE WORRIED BECAUSE
THERE'S SO MANY BILLS HERE NOW
WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO IS READ THE
BILLS THAT WILL BE MOVED- TO
THE- SUSPENSE. FILE. MAYBE WE
SHOULD WAIT BECAUSE MISS BURKE
IS HERE. TO PRESENT HER BILL.
LET'S WAIT UNTIL WE GET TO THE
AUTHORS ON READING THE REST OF
BILLS SINCE IT'LL BE CONFUSING
IF WE MOVE IT TO THE SUSPENSE
AND THEY CHOOSE TO TESTIFY
THEY'LL BE AT LACK MISS BURKE
AB TWENTY TWO FORTY SEVEN
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
IT WAS MOVED BY MISS CARILLO.
AND SECONDED BY MISTER CALDERON.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT THE
NAME OF. ALL RIGHT NECK WE'RE
GOING TO AB TWENTY TWO FORTY
SEVEN SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU YOUR POSITION IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO USING YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. WE DO HAVE SOMEONE IN
QB JUST A MOMENT PLEASE THANK
YOU.
I DO APOLOGIZE JUST AMOUNT
NOT A MOMENT THAT'S OKAY.
BOB.
AND ONE THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES I ACTUALLY I WAS
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF. THE
DIFFERENT ITEMS THE FIRST ONE
WAS DOCTOR REGULAR STILL I
DON'T THAT'S NOT UP RIGHT NOW
NO SIR I'M SORRY. OKAY I'M
SORRY. IT'S ON SUSPENSE AND-
WILL NOT BE HEARD TODAY YOU CAN
REGISTER YOUR SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION AT THE END IF YOU
FEEL LIKE STATE NOT LONG. DID
YOU WANT TO SPEAK ON AB TWENTY
TWO FIVE COMING UP WITH. NO
THAT IS NOT IS THERE ANYBODY ON
THE LINE TO IS IN SUPPORT OF AB.
TWENTY TWO FORTY SEVEN. GAME OF
TWENTY TO FORTY SEVEN CORRECT
MANAGER. RIGHT THANK YOU CAN
YOU MAY PRESS ONE NINE ZERO YOU
LIKE TO SHARE YOUR POSITION IN
SUPPORT. NO ONE IN Q. AT THIS
TIME IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY TWO
FORTY SEVEN. IF YOUR POSITION
AS OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE.
AND WE DO HAVE A LINE IN Q. BE
JUST A MOMENT PLEASE. AND FORTY
MA'AM OUTLINED DROPPED
THEREFORE NO ONE'S IN Q. YOU
MAY CONTINUE THANK YOU IS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON THE
LINE. MORNING MADAM CHAIR OF
THE DOLE AND AGAIN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- I HAVE
NO FILE ON THAT MEASURE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SCENE- NO
QUESTIONS MISS BURKE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE EAH AB TWENTY
TWO FORTY SEVEN IS SPONSORED BY
THE F. D. B. AND SIMPLY WOULD
GIVE THE TAXPAYERS THE OPTION
OF WRITING ALTERNATE
IDENTIFYING INFORMATION FOR THE
PURPOSES OF CLAIMING THE
DEPENDENT EXEMPTION ON THE
TAXES WITHOUT A QUESTION I.
THANK YOU THAT GETS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL WITH MR GAP NOT
VOTING. AT I THINK YOU WOULD
LIKE TO PRESENT ON A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE TWENTY FOUR OH FIVE
IF YOU CAN. BRIEFLY. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB
TWENTY FIVE FOUR OH FIVE
ESTABLISHES A RIGHT TO HOUSING
FOR ALL CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
IN CALIFORNIA AND MAKE THAT THE
POLICY OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT NO CHILD GO
WITHOUT A HOME. I'D LIKE TO
THINK THE CHAIR FOR HER SUPPORT
AND FOR BEING A JOINT AUTHORED.
IN AN EFFORT TO REDUCE COSTS
THIS BILL DELAYS IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE RIGHT HOUSING TO TWENTY
TWENTY SIX. AT THE EMPHASIS IS
PREVENTING HOMELESSNESS AND
IT'S ON TO THE VANCE AGAIN.
TURN TIME PREVENTING HOMELESS
IN THE FIRST PAID WRITING
EMERGENCY HOUSING WAS
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES WHEN NEED
AND TRANSITIONING FAMILIES AND
CHILDREN TO PERMANENT HOUSING.
AS WE'VE SEEN IN THE LAST FEW
MONTHS THAT WE HAVE REALLY
BECOME AWARE THAT SO MANY
FAMILIES ARE ONE PAYCHECK AWAY
FROM BEING HOMELESS AND AT THIS
TIME THIS BILL IS IMPERATIVE
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN IBM. THANK YOU YOU HAVE
SPEAKERS AND SUPPORT- NECK ARE
THERE SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY FOUR OH FIVE. IF YOUR IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL TELLING ME
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE DO
HAVE A LINING QB JUST A MOMENT
PLEASE THANK YOU. LINE THIRTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FOR
CALLING ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
CAN AMIR KHAN ADOLESCENT
PSYCHIATRY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. IF THERE IS ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT YOU MAY ALSO
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. NO ONE
ELSE TO KEEP PLEASE CONTINUE.
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
TO AB TWENTY FOUR OH FIVE. YOU
YOUR POSITION AS AN OPPOSITION
IN THE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE SHOULD NO ONE
HERE AT THIS TIME MANAGER
PLEASE CONTINUE THANK YOU
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE GIVE A
FILE. THANK YOU I WELL WE DON'T
HAVE A POSITION ON THE BILL THE
MOMENT. I WOULD NOTE THAT THIS
BILL WILL RESULT IN UNKNOWN-
BUT OCCASIONALLY SIGNIFICANT
FUTURE GENERAL FUND CAUGHT. A
POTENTIALLY IN THE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. SELECT COMMITTEE. THE
BILL AND IF THEY ARE
INTERPRETED TO REQUIRE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO PROVIDE
HOMELESSNESS PREVENTION
SERVICES AND HOUSING FOR
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES. THE BILL
COULD RESULT IN A STATE
MANDATED REIMBURSABLE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I'M THAT BILL IS
GOING TO SUSPEND SMITH BURKE
THANK YOU UNLESS THERE'S
ANYTHING YOU NEED TO ADD. THANK
YOU. MISTER CALDERON YOU HAVE
TO BILLS TO BE PRESENTING AB
TWENTY. TWO ZERO ZERO FOUR
ENJOY THE DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE A MOTION
BY MS CARILLO. AND A SECOND BY
MISTAKE MEN. THE I HAD A
PROJECT THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
MEMBERS FOR ANYONE AND HAS COME
TO THE TOUGH DECISION A PLACE
YOU SEE LOVE ONE AN ASSISTED
LIVING FACILITY KNOWS HOW
DIFFICULT IT CAN BE FUNNY RIGHT
PLACE THE MOVE GOOGLE SEARCH OF
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES FOR
THE ELDERLY CAN REVEAL A DOZEN
FACILITIES WITHIN A TWENTY MILE
RADIUS RADIUS. THIS IS WHERE
REFERRAL SOURCES BECOME SO
VITAL SO THEY PLAY IN MY
PRESENT A TWO ZERO FOUR TWENTY
TWENTY SIX TWENTY A TWENTY SIX.
WE DO WE DISPENSED TWENTY TWO
TWO THOUSAND ZERO FOUR RIGHT.
TWO ZERO ZERO FOUR IS WHAT YOU
SHOULD BE PRESENTING ON. ALL
RIGHT I WAS A LITTLE CONFUSED
ON. YOU OKAY GOT A LETTER TO
THE PROCESS OKAY GREAT- YEAH
THIS BILL WOULD AUTHORIZE USE
VERIFIABLE HEALTH CREDENTIALS
FOR THE PURPOSE OF VERIFYING
THE RESULT OF A- PROVEN
NINETEEN TESTED PROVIDES A
FLEXIBLE PATH. TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS EMERGING
TECHNOLOGY RESPECT LAST ANOTHER.
ALL RIGHT THAT WAS AB. TWO ZERO
ZERO FOUR NICK IF YOU CAN OPEN
THE LINES OF SUPPORT. Q. IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT IN A PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. YOU DO HAVE
A FEW LINES IN Q. JUST A MOMENT
FOR OUR FIRST COMMENT. NINE
ELEVEN IS YOUR POSITION ON THIS
BILL. IT IS ON TWENTY NINE
TWENTY. 90% ON I APOLOGIZE. THE
NEXT NOW WE'LL HAVE TO WAIT TO
THE NEXT WHERE BY WILL. WELCOME
WELCOME THAT I. YEAH I THINK
YOU I APOLOGIZE TO THE CHAIR. A
LINE ONE TWELVE ONE ONE TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY MIND.
TWENTY NINE TWENTY SIX ARE WE
ON THAT YET NO WE ARE NOT ON
TWENTY NINE TWENTY SIX PEOPLE
AT HOME CAN PAY ATTENTION- I'M
SORRY IT IT'S GONNA BE
CONFUSING SO IT'S GOING TO TAKE
SOME TIME TO GET THIS RIGHT BUT
ONE AB. TWO ZERO ZERO FOUR.
WHERE TAKE AB TWO ZERO ZERO
FOUR WE'RE TAKING COLORS IN
SUPPORT. THAT IS YOUR POSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
THEY'RE ALL. WE'LL GO BACK TO
LINE NE ONE TWO ONE TWELVE
OPEN. IT IS THE BILL YOU WANT
TO SPEAK TO. NO THE. I KNOW
WARNING HERE AT THIS TIME AND
CHAIR. THANK YOU ARE THERE
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWO ZERO ZERO FOUR. THAT IS
YOUR POSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
DO HAVE A LINE IN Q. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE.
LINE ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
THREE ONE FIVE THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YES I'D LIKE TO URGE
THE COMMITTEE NOT TO APPROVE AN
ASSEMBLY CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT NUMBER FIVE WE ARE
NOT ON AND WE ARE NOT ON THAT
BILL RIGHT NOW WE ARE ONLY ON
AB. TWO ZERO ZERO FOUR. NO
OTHER SECURE AT THIS TIME AND
CHECK. THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE YOU HAVE A PILE. FIND
THANK YOU I SEE NO QUESTIONS
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CONCLUDE
MISTER CALDERON THE CLASS WHEN
I WROTE HE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE ON THAT GETS OUT ON
AN EIGHT ROLL CALL WITH- MISTER
DEAR MR BIGELOW IN MR GABRIEL
NOT VOTING. NOW WE WILL GO TO
AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY SIX.
AGAIN THIS IS AB TWENTY NINE
TWENTY SIX MISTER CALDERON YOUR
MOTION BY MISS CARILLO AND YOU
HAVE A SECOND BY DOCTOR EGGMAN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AGAIN FOR
ANYONE THAT HAS HAD KIND OF
TOUGH DECISION- PLACE YOU SEE
YOUR LOVED ONE LIVING ASSISTED
LIVING FACILITY- THEY KNOW HOW
DIFFICULT IT CAN BE- REFERRAL
SOURCES BECOME SO VITAL AS THE
UTILIZED KEY INFORMATION ABOUT
SENIORS HEALTH NEEDS TO PROVIDE
REFERRAL TO THE MOST OF.
APPROPRIATE FACILITY IN THE
AREA- SO. RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN
I BUILT. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
NICK IF THERE ARE SUPPORTERS OF
AB. THANK YOU THERE ARE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WELL THE FIRST ON LINE
ONE TWELVE ONE ONE TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU CLIP
BURGUNDY HAVE A PLACE FOR MOM
IN SUPPORT A CO SPONSOR. THANK
YOU. WE'LL GO TO LINE UP ELEVEN
ONE ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
ELEVEN I GET THERE YOU MAY BE
NEEDED ON YOUR SIDE. YEAH THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MONICA MILLER REPLICATING
CONSUMER ADVOCATE RCMP BUT
FARMING WORK AND ALSO. BUT THE
OF OUR THE COMPANY TO THE ALBUM
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THERE ARE NO
OTHERS IN Q. AT THIS TIME. ALL
RIGHT IS THERE ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY NINE
TWENTY SIX. IF THAT IS AND IF
THAT IS YOUR POSITION ME PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND WE DO
HAVE A LINE IN Q. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE.
ARE WE STILL WAITING ON
A SPEAKER IN OPPOSITION. WE ARE.
THAT IS LINE ONE FORTY EIGHT
ONE FOUR EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN YES THIS IS AN FHA OF
ANNAPOLIS IN SAN FRANCISCO-
FEARING DISABILITY ACTION AND
AT LEAST SUPPORT THE BILL. A
NINE TWENTY SIX THANK YOU THANK
YOU. ANOTHER SUPPORTER THAT'S
OKAY. AND WHAT WE DO HAVE A
ANOTHER LINE IN Q. GREAT LINE
THIRTY ONE THREE ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. NINE THIRTY ONE
CHARLIE YOUR GO HEAD. MY
APOLOGY I'M PROMOTING WERE
DIFFERENT OUR OUR SAY AGAINST
BECAUSE THINKING THIRTY. NO ONE
IN Q. AT THIS TIME AND CHAIR
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE TO HAVE A FILE.
WHILE THE FIFTH. THANK YOU
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CONCLUDE
MISTER CALDERON THE QUESTION OF
THE TICKETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
MISS CARILLO AB TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FIVE- YOU CAN PRESENT
FROM YOUR DESK THERE THAT'S
FINE IF YOU TO IT ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE A
MOTION BY. MISTER CALDERON AND
A SECOND BY DOCTOR EGGMAN.
THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU-
NECK ARE THOSE ANYBODY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FIVE. THAT IS YOUR
POSITION MAY PRESS ONE AT THIS
TIME. WE DO HAVE AN ONLINE
GREETING ME JUST A MOMENT
PLEASE. WELL THE FIRST TIMELINE
OF ONE THIRTY ONE ONE THREE ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YET MORE LOW.
LINE ONE THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO WE CAN HEAR YOU.
YEAH CAN YOU HEAR ME YES YES
SIR. YEAH IS THIS BILL IS THIS
THE BILL RELATED TO-
INVOLUNTARY FORCE BUT TO
VOLUNTARY FOR STERILIZATION NO
IT'S NOT THAT BILL IS ON
SUSPENSE. OKAY THANK YOU. THIS
IS AB. TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FIVE. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
VICTOR RAY I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE CHILD SUPPORT
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION WE
REPRESENT THE DIRECTOR OF THE
COUNTY CHILD SUPPORT AGENCY. AB
FIFTY EIGHT SUPPORT AT TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FIVE ADDRESS WITH
SITUATIONS WHERE CHILD SUPPORT
ORDERS ACCUMULATOR REARS
QUALITY PETERING CARBURETED AND
ARE NOT LEARNING AND ARE NOT
ABLE TO MAKE THEIR CHILD
SUPPORT PAYMENTS. SENATE OUT
SINCE HE PAYS TO SUCCESSFUL
WHEN THEY AGREE IN OUR SOCIETY
AND RE ENGAGE WITH THEIR
FAMILIES- ONE IMPORTANT. THING
TO NOTE ABOUT THE BILL. IS IT
IS C. P. WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
GET ORDERS. IF THEY EITHER HAVE
TO BE PAID FOR THEIR
INCARCERATED BECAUSE OF EITHER
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. FOR NON
PAYMENT OF CHILD SUPPORT. WHEN
THE LANGUAGE SUNSET IT AT THE
BEGINNING OF THIS YEAR- LOCAL
CHILD SUPPORT AGENCIES- ARE
TREATED THE- PENSION OF THE
ORDER GOING TO PERSUADE
CONSIGNMENT AND THEY HAD ARE
VERY LANGUAGE AUTOMATICALLY
INCLUDED IN YOUR CHILD SUPPORT
ORDERS. WHICH WOULD KICK IN IF
A- HE WAS INCARCERATED IN OTHER
CASES- THEIR DECISION EITHER
THROUGH THE LCS STATE AND LOCAL
COURT AT ALL THESE ISSUES
SHOULD GO THROUGH THE COURT
MODIFICATION PROCESS. SO THERE
ARE DIFFERENT TREATMENT BASED
ON THE COUNTY YOUR CASE WITH
AND WITHOUT FOR THAT WAS THAT-
YOUR- CASE AND HELP IS MANAGED
ATTENDED A WHAT COUNTY YOU'RE
LOCATED IN. YOUR CASE WITHIN
SPENDING ORDERS WILL HELP US TO
AVOID THE SCENARIO THAT IS TWO
MINUTES. REPORTER SIR THAT.
THAT IS TWO MINUTES THANK YOU
FOR TESTIMONY. WE'RE NOW JUST
TAKING P. NAY IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR COULD YOU
REPEAT THE NUMBER THE BILL
PLEASE IT IS AB. TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FIVE. IN A DEALS WITH
YOUR REGISTRATION AND CHILD
SUPPORT. THANK YOU WE'LL GO TO
LINE ONE TWENTY SIX IS YOUR
POSITION ON THIS BILL. BUT THE
ONLY ENTER FRANKLIN OPPORTUNITY
A CONSTANT THE MEASURE AND-
WHAT. THANK YOU BOOK ONLINE
THIRTY THREE THREE THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THIRTY THREE DID
YOU WANT TO SHARE YOUR POSITION
FOR THIS BILL. MOVEON NO ON A
SECURE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
IS THERE ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION
TO AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY FIVE.
HERE YOUR POSITION AS AN
OPPOSITION FOR THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN THEY'RE ALL. AND
THERE ARE NO LINES IN Q. THANK
YOU DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE GIVE
A FILE. NO FILE THANK YOU MISS
CARILLO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. YES THAT GETS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL WITH MR FONG VOTING I
MISS DOLLY MISSED OUR QUE HAN
MISS PETRIE-NORRIS IN THE CHAIR
NOT VOTING THANK YOU AB THREE
THREE THREE SIX ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION I SEE A
MOTION BY MISTER CALDERON A
SECOND BY A- DOCTOR EGGMAN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I'D LIKE
TO JUST- INSURE THAT EVERYBODY
KNOWS THAT WE ARE TAKING THEM
AMENDMENTS NECESSARY THIS IS
NOT A BILL THAT- WILL- AVOID
PEOPLE NOT BEING ABLE TO WORK
OR PUT RESTRICTIONS ABOUT WORK
THIS IS ABOUT ENSURING THAT
FOOD. IS SIMPLY SAFELY
DELIVERED AND NOT CONTAMINATED
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AND I BOUGHT. THIS IS
A. B. THREE THREE THREE SIX IT
IS A BILL ABOUT FOOD DELIVERY
ARE THERE SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
NECK. THANK YOU IF YOU'D LIKE
TO SHARE YOUR POSITION IN
SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I DO
APOLOGIZE IT SOUNDS LIKE WE
MIGHT HAVE A PLAN SPEAKER.
CALDERON WOULD LEARN MORE. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR JUST ALONG
FOR THE LOCAL ENVIRONMENT
HEALTH DIRECTORS WE ALL THE
SPONSOR OF THE BILL AND AS THE
OLD THE CORRECTLY STATED THIS
IS INTENDED TO CLARIFY WHICH
PUBLIC HEALTH SAFETY PROVISIONS
THE FOOD DELIVERY COMPANIES
SHOULD BE A HEARING TO
DETERMINE LEFT WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE THE COST
OF ANY COST OF THIS BILL AND-
WE BELIEVE THAT IT SHOULD
ADDRESS CONCERNS IN OPPOSITION
I PREVIOUSLY STATED- WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION AND
HOPE THIS WILL HELP- AT.
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS OF C<c.cyan></c>
SPRAYED AS WELL AS A FOOD BORNE
ILLNESS THANK YOU THANK YOU. IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SHARE YOUR
POSITION IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL IN PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. WE HAVE A LINE IN CUBA
COMES FROM ONE FIVE SIX ONE
FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING HER WOMAN MEMBERS
OPERATE IN THE YOU KNOW WITH
THE NOT ON BEHALF OF LA COUNTY
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AT THE TIME THERE NO FOR
THE LINES IN Q. ARE THERE ANY
OTHERS I'M SORRY ARE THERE
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL AB THREE THREE THREE SIX.
WE'D LIKE TO SHARE YOUR
POSITION IN OPPOSITION TO THAT
BILLION THE PRESS ONE THAN
ZERO. WE DO HAVE A FEW LINES
AND Q. JUST ANOTHER MOMENT FOR
THAT FIRST COMMENT. LINE ONE
SIXTY FIVE ONE SIX FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE COURT
IN JENSEN WITH TAX THAT IN
OPPOSITION AB THREE THREE THREE
SIX WE APPRECIATE WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR AND PROPONENT FROM
THE OF THE BILL- AND AGREED
THAT FOOD SAFETY AND DEMOCRATS
THE TOP PRIORITY FOR TECH THAT
MEMBER COMPANIES- WE DO
MAINTAIN SOME CONCERNS AROUND
ME A CORE CHOIR MEN'S AND THE
BILL. I'M AND WANT TO MAKE SURE
A BAD DRIVER CAN CONTINUE TO
UTILIZE THEIR PERSONAL VEHICLES
FOR DELIVERY- WHEN DELIVERING
BAND- ON BEHALF OF THIRD PARTY-
DELIVERY COMPANY AS- AND MAKE
SURE THAT THEY CAN CONTINUE TO
UTILIZE THEIR PERSONAL VEHICLES
TO- MAKE MONEY THROUGH THE FORM
OF WORK. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
LINE FIFTY SIX FIVE SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS WITH
THE SERVER THE- WITH THE
CALIFORNIA GROCERS ASSOCIATION
WE ARE IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL IN PRINT AND WE WOULD LIKE
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING
WITH THEIR OFFICE- LOOKING
FORWARD TO SEEING THE
AMENDMENT- HOPEFULLY. WILL
REMOVE IT TO A NEUTRAL POSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LINE ONE
SEVENTY NINE ONE SEVEN NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS THAT TELL US ROUND I'M A
MEDICAL STUDENT AT UCT AT SAN
DIEGO SCHOOL OF MEDICINE AND
I'M JUST CALLING IN HER STRONG
SUPPORTER ECA FIVE. I'M SORRY
I'M COMING I'M SORRY WE'RE NOT
ON A CA FIVE AGAIN THIS IS THIS
IS AB THREE THREE THREE SIX AND
WE'RE JUST LOOKING FOR SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION. WHO WILL STATE
THEIR NAME AND THE ORGANIZATION
THEY REPRESENT IF ANY AND THEIR
POSITION. RIGHT. NO FURTHER
LINES IN Q. MADAM CHAIR PLEASE
CONTINUE. THANK YOU DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE YOU HAVE A FILE.
JOURNAL FILE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I'M I WANT TO THANK YOU
MISS CREE OF FOR BRINGING THIS
VERY IMPORTANT BILL- IT WOULD
BE GREAT IF WITH THE COMPANIES-
THAT WOULD BE AB DOWN BY THIS
BILL WOULD ACTUALLY ABIDE BY
CALIFORNIA LAW WITH OTHER BILLS
AND PERHAPS WE WOULDN'T HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO US CREATE NEW LAWS
A LITTLE DISTURBING THE THEIR
OPPOSITION GIVEN THAT IT
DOESN'T MATTER WHAT WE WILL
PASS THEY WILL LIKELY. CONTINUE
TO VIOLATE CALIFORNIA LAW AS
THEY HAVE DONE OVER THE LAST
YEAR WITH THAT. WOULD YOU LIKE
AN AYE VOTE. YES THANK YOU
CHECK IT OUT AND BE ROLL CALL
WITH MISS PETRIE-NORRIS MISS
BARKING IN VOTING NOW. THANK
YOU MISS CARILLO THAT. IS YOUR
BILLS MISTER COOPER I SAW YOU
COME IN AB NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT
AGAIN THIS IS AB NINETEEN FIFTY
EIGHT IS AND JOYS I DO PASS AS
AMENDED RECOMMENDATION TO
DELETE THE MISDEMEANOR CRIME
DELETE THE PROVISION THAT
AUTHORIZES A PEACE OFFICER TO
ENFORCE THE PROJECT VISIONS OF
THIS BILL IN ANY PLACE IN THE
STATE TO WHICH THE PEACE
OFFICER'S AUTHORITY EXTENDS.
REVISED THE LANGUAGE SO MEMBER
THE FLOORBOARD OR LOCAL AGENCY
MAY MOVE RATHER THAN REMOVE
SPECIFIED OBSTRUCTIONS AND ADD
IT THE INTENT LANGUAGE. WITH
THAT WE HAVE A MOTION BY DOCTOR
EGGMAN AND THE SECOND BY MISS
CARILLO MISTER COOPER. THIS IS
A BILL ABOUT HOMELESSNESS
PROPERTY. CORRECT AND WE HAVE
FIXING HER MILES OF DELTA
ELEVEN THE DELTA APPEAR WHEN
LEVEES BREAKS HERE WITH FLOOD
THE ENTIRE DOWNTOWN SACRAMENTO.
THE MANAGER MEMBERS AB NINETEEN
FIFTY EIGHT IS AN IMPORTANT
MEASURE TO INCREASE PROTECTION
AND INVESTMENTS TO OUR LEVEE
SYSTEM. OVER SIXTY MILES LEVY
SERVE TO PROTECT THE LIVES AND
PROPERTY OF THOUSANDS OF
RESIDENTS. COMBINED FEDERAL
STATE AND LOCAL INVESTMENTS IN
THE FLOOD PROTECTION SYSTEM
HAVE EXCEEDED THREE BILLION
DOLLARS IN JUST THE URBAN AREAS
OVER THE PAST TEN YEARS. DOES
NOT IN THE ANALYSIS THIS BILL
RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT COST
SAVINGS BY SHOWING THE STATE
POTENTIAL LIABILITY IN THE
EVENT OF A LEVEE BREACH. THE
NAME IS MAKE THE BILL BETTER.
ARE STRICTLY SB RIVALS. THANK
YOU MISTER COOPER AND THIS A
NINETEEN. EIGHT AS AMENDED- NAY
DO WE HAVE ANY SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT. YOUR SUPPORT OF AB
NINETEEN FIFTY ONE AND THEN
ZERO. TO ONE Q. AT THIS TIME
PLEASE CONTINUE. CAN WE GET THE
OPPONENTS OF AB NINETEEN FIFTY
EIGHT IF ANY. DO YOU. IF YOU
HOLD THAT POSITION ME PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. YOU KNOW NINE THANK YOU
AT THIS TIME MANAGER THANK YOU
I SEE WE HAVE ACTUALLY SOMEBODY
IN PERSON OPPOSED IN AB
NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT. POLITICS
AROUND CHAIR- DURRANCE
INCENTIVIZE PROTECTION BOARD.
IN SUPPORT. OF AB NINETEEN
FIFTY EIGHT OKAY THANK YOU I'M
SORRY I MISSED YOU THANK YOU-
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE HAVE A
POSITION. BUT I'M SURE NO FILE
MEASURE. THANK YOU SEE NO
QUESTIONS BY THE MEMBERS WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE RECESS WE
HAVE THREE RIVAL THANK YOU THAT
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL MISTER
COOPER THANK YOU YOUR NEXT BILL
AB TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY THREE IS
A DO PASS AS AMENDED TO REDUCE
THE SCOPE OF THE PR EIGHT
EXEMPTION. WHERE MOTION BY
DOCTOR I EGGMAN IN A SECOND BY
MISTER RIVAS. MR COOPER WITH
MEDICARE MEMBERS WITH ALL THE
UNCERTAINTY IN THE FINANCIAL
MARKETS ARE PENSION SYSTEMS
WORKING DO THEIR PART. TO
PROTECT THE PENSIONS OF ALL OF
OUR PUBLIC EMPLOYEES. AB TWENTY
FOUR SEVENTY THREE PROVIDES
CALPERS WITH THE ABILITY TO
ACCESS EVERY TOOL POSSIBLE TO
INVEST MANAGE AND GROW
CALIFORNIA'S PENSION FUNDS. AB
TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY THREE I'M
NOT CREATE ADDITIONAL STATE
COST NOT ACCEPTED THE
AMENDMENTS SUBMITTED TO THIS
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU NECK IF WE
CAN GET SUPPORTERS OF AB TWENTY
FOUR SEVENTY THREE IT'S A BILL
ABOUT PENSIONS. Q. IF YOUR
POSITION AS AND SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WE DO HAVE
A FEW LINE THANK YOU BE JUST A
MOMENT WHEN. LOCAL FIRST THE
LINE SEVENTY ONE SEVEN ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD MORNING-
THE BEDROCK OF ALL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SCHOOL BUSINESS OFFICIALS
BEFORE. THANK YOU WILL DRAW THE
LINE ONE TEN ONE ONE ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS IS.
WITH THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT SYSTEM.
THE SPONSOR AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU DOES ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO FOUR SEVEN HE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS. NO FOR THE LINE IN Q.
PLEASE CONTINUE. YOU IS THERE
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION TO AB.
TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY THREE. IN A
BETTER POSITION IN A HOLD ON
YOU LIKE TO COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU WELL WE DO HAVE
A LINE IN Q. I APOLOGIZE WE
JUST A MOMENT. MOBILE TO LINE
TWENTY ONE TWO ZERO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI THIS IS JJ TO ONE
SIX SPEAKING ON MY BEHALF AND
ON BEHALF OF PARK PA IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME ALL
INCORPORATE. AND NOT RE PEOPLE
WITH CERTAIN OUR POSITION PAPER
BUT THIS AREA IS FRAUGHT WITH
BROAD FAVORITISM AND WHAT PRO
QUO. IT PUTS THE ASSET. AND THE
REPUTATION OF RETIREMENT SYSTEM
WITH RICH. THE SPONSOR IS
TELLING YOU THEY CANNOT FULLY
PARTICIPATE. IF THERE IS SOME
LIGHT THE AMENDMENTS ACTUALLY
DEEP IN THE SHADOW. BETTER
FISHERIES AND PUBLIC DESERVE TO
KNOW WHAT'S BEING DONE WITH
THEIR MONEY PLEASE REJECT THE
BILL OR AT LEAST REQUIRED THAT
THE LOAN AGREEMENTS THE TERM
CONDITIONS ALONG BE BROUGHT
INTO THE SUNLIGHT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR. AT THIS TIME
THERE ARE NO FOR THE LINES AND
Q. PLEASE CONTINUE THANK YOU
I'M GONNA FINANCES ARE FILE. NO
BY. THANK YOU MISTER COOPER
RESPECTFULLY ASKYOUR RIVAL
THANK YOU THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL THANK YOU. I JUST-
WANT PEOPLE TO KNOW I KNOW
THERE'S A NUMBER OF MEMBERS ON
THE COMMITTEE WHO WILL BE
PRESENTING FOR OTHER MEMBERS
WERE NOT HERE- IF IT'S OKAY
WITH EVERYBODY WE WILL TAKE
THOSE PRESENTATIONS WE WILL
SKIP THEM- IF THE AUTHOR IS NOT
HEARING TO THEM AT THE AND-
JUST I KNOW THERE ARE SOME
AUTHORS WHO ARE GOING TO TRY TO
MAKE IT HERE AND- WE'LL JUST
SEE IF WE- HOW THAT WORKS OUT-
SEVEN FORTY FIVE IT ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION. IT'S A
MOTION BY MISS CARILLO IN A
SECOND BY MISTER BIGELOW.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. SHE LEARNS QUICK- AB
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY FIVE NICK DO
WE HAVE ANYBODY IN SUPPORT. IF
YOU'D LIKE TO COMMENT ON YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SEVEN
FORTY FIVE IN THE PRESS ONE OF
THEM ZERO. THANK YOU. WE DO
HAVE A LINE AND GIVE ME JUST A
MOMENT PLEASE.
THAT COMMENT
COMES ON LINE TWO HUNDRED TWO
ZERO ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CALLER ON LINE TWO HUNDRED ARE
YOU THERE. YES. PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION. ALL MY NAME GIPSON
YELLING WILL. I'M LEAVING AT
TEN AM FROM THE LOS ANGELES.
THANK YOU IS THIS FOR AB TWO
SEVEN FOUR I. A FOR AC EIGHTY
FIVE. I WANT TO REMIND THE
CALLERS WE ARE NOT ON A CA FIVE
AND IN FACT JUST AS A- HEADS UP
THERE WILL BE NO PRESENTATION
ON A CA FIVE THAT WILL BE MOVED
TO THE SUSPENSE FILE WITHOUT
PRESENTATION SO YOUR PUBLIC
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION WILL BE AT THE VERY
END. SO IF YOU COMBINE AND-
SPEAK ON IT THE TIMING IS NOT
CORRECT YOU CAN WAIT UNTIL THE
END OR SUBMIT YOUR NAME AND
WRITING THAT WORKS AS WELL THIS
IS AB. TWENTY SEVEN FORTY FIVE
IN ITS SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
THAT IS YOUR POSITION WE PRESS
ONE AND THEN THEY'RE ALL.
THERE'S NO ONE IN Q. AT THIS
TIME MADAM CHAIR. ALL RIGHT IS
THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY FIVE. IN A
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO TO COMMENT
OPPOSITION TO AB TWO SEVEN FOUR
FIVE. NO ONE IN Q. AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. WE ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR FIRST
APPROPRIATIONS MOMENTS DOLLY.
MR DEEP AB TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
EIGHT IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION AS AMENDED TO
CLARIFY THE TYPES OF WRITTEN
REQUEST WOULD YOU LIKE TO.
PROCEED THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL WE
HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER BIGELOW
IN A SECOND BY MISS CARILLO-
NECK THIS IS AB. TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY EIGHT IS THERE ANYBODY
IN SUPPORT. NECK. REMEMBER HE
WAS ON IF YOU'D LIKE TO SHARE
YOUR SUPPORT OF AB TWO FIVE TWO
EIGHT MAYBE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. YOU
MADAM CHAIR NO ONE IN SUPPORT
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU IS THERE
ANY OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY
FIVE TO EIGHT. COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. THERE ARE NO
LINES IN Q. PLEASE CONTINUE
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
TO HAVE A FILE. NO FIVE NINE
CHAIR. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
MISTER DF REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
THAT GETS OUT ON THE- A ROLL
CALL. JUST GAS AND NOW. MISTAKE
MEN MISSED A MAN- ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION IN AN AYE
AYE RECOMMENDATION. A IT HAS A
MOTION BY MS CARILLO A SECOND
BY MISTER BIGELOW I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY FIFTEEN I ASK
FOR YOUR EITHER. GREAT AS NICK
IS THERE ANYBODY IN THE QUEUE
FOR AB TWENTY FIFTEEN. IF YOU
WANT TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
TWENTY FIFTEEN IN A PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
DO HAVE A LINE IN QB JUST A
MOMENT. DAVE THEY REMOVE
THEMSELVES SO NO ONE IN Q. AT
THIS TIME MAKE CAN DANIEL HEY I
APOLOGIZE MANAGER LINE ONE
NINETY. CAN YOU STATE YOUR
POSITION ON THE ON THE BILL.
ONE NINE THERE ARE ALL THE.
BIGELOW LINE ONE NINE ZERO ONE
NINETY YOUR MIND IS OPEN. YES
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TO SEE GRANT OKAY
YOU'RE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PSYCHIATRIC ASSOCIATION WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT CHRISTMAS BUT WE
ARE THE SPONSORS. THANK YOU. NO
FOR THE LINE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU DEPARTMENT FINANCE. THE
FILE THANK YOU MISS EGGMAN
WITHOUT THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL. MISS FRIEDMAN- IT LOOKS
LIKE AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY
THREE ENJOYS A DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO REMAIN. REMOVE THE
CORTES THE LIST PROVISIONS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR A I JUST
WANT TO SAY UP FRONT THAT I
KNOW THAT THERE HAVE BEEN A LOT
OF CONCERNS ABOUT THE SECTION
OF THIS BILL THAT DEALS WITH
TOXIC SITES AND I WANT EVERYONE
TO UNDERSTAND I WANT TO BE VERY
CLEAR THAT WE'RE ACCEPTING AN
AMENDMENT THAT WAS- VERY KINDLY
AUTHORED BY- THE CHAIR TO
REMOVE THAT SECTION WE ARE
MOVING THAT REMOVING THAT
SECTION. COMPLETELY SO THAT'S
NO LONGER IN THE BILL THAT'S
THE ONLY OBJECTION TO THIS BILL
THAT WE HAVE HEARD FROM ANY
STAKEHOLDER AND I APOLOGIZE IF
ANYBODY HAS A DIFFERENT
OBJECTION BUT I HAVE NOT HEARD
ANY OTHER OBJECTION TO THIS
BILL THAT SECTION OF THIS BILL
IS NOW REMOVED I HOPE THAT THAT
ADDRESSES ANY CONCERNS ANYBODY
MIGHT HAVE. THIS BLL IS BEEN A
LONG TIME IN DEVELOPING- IT IS
CO AUTHORED BY MYSELF AND DAVID
CHIU THE CARE OF HOUSING AND IT
IS ATTEMPTING TO TAKE THE VERY
A SEQUEL EXCEPTIONS THAT
ALREADY EXIST UNDER THE LAW AND
TO CONSOLIDATE THEM TO MAKE
THEM MORE USER OF DEVELOPERS
ARE WHO HAVE TO DO WITH A PATCH.
OF CONFUSING AND SOMETIMES
CONTRADICTORY A DIFFERENT
EXEMPTIONS WE ALL KNOW WE HAVE
A HOUSING CRISIS I BELIEVE THAT
THIS IS A VERY MODEST BUT
IMPORTANT STEP IN MAKING IT
EASY BILL HAPPENING IN
CALIFORNIA. WITHOUT I WOULD.
RELIEF YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
FRIEDMAN AGAIN THAT WAS AB
TWENTY THREE TWENTY THREE IT
ENJOYS AID DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION MADE A MOTION BY
MISS CREE ON A SECOND BY MISTER
CALDERON AND- THE AUTHOR HAS
ACCEPTED THE AMENDMENTS THAT
TAKE OUT THE PROVISION DEALING
WITH TOXIC SITES- WITH THAT I
THINK WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT ARE THERE
ANY SPEAKERS AND SUPPORT. YEAH
ON THE LINE NICK AB TWENTY
THREE TWENTY THREE. SHARE YOUR
POSITION UP SUPPORT FOR AB
TWENTY THREE TWENTY THREE ME
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO WE DO
HAVE A FEW WHEN YOU ALREADY
WORK ON THE LINE SIXTY SEVEN
SIX SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS STILL GO FOR OUR IN
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA BUILDING
DISTRICTS OF PATIENT OR- THANK
YOU. LINE NINETY EIGHT NINE
EIGHT LINE IS OPEN. NOT A
TERRIBLE CONTENT BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIAN BEING SUPPORT THANK
YOU. HELLO LINE TWO SIXTEEN TWO
ONE SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY SHANTI HALF OF THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI- AND WE BELIEVE THIS
BILL WILL HELP FAVORITE CITY
FINDING IN TERMS OF ELIMINATING
FACT REVIEW HOPPED ON REDUNDANT
PLANNED AND SAVING SOME
POTENTIAL LITTLE GATE LATE
LITIGATION. WE ARE TRANSPORT
THANK YOU. KIM LINE NINE ONE
TWENTY NINE ONE TWO NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
COREY SMITH ON BEHALF OF THE
BAY AREA HELPING ADVOCACY
COALITION IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY THREE TWENTY THREE THANK
YOU. LINE FORTY NINE FOUR NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS WARRANTED OLYMPIA
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
LINE ONE SIXTEEN ONE ONE SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE CHAIR
NUMBER OF DOLLARS TOWARDS ON
BEHALF OF UP FOR GROWTH ACTION
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NINE TO SEVENTEEN TO ONE SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIRPERSON MADAM THAT
LIKE HAVE PUBLIC AFFAIRS
CALLING ON BEHALF OF HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA AND
CALIFORNIA ME INTO. THANK YOU.
NEXT TO ORDER TO NINETEEN TWO
ONE NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING BACK POCKET BEING
ON THE ACT THAT THE ASSOCIATION
OF ENVIRONMENTAL PROFESSIONAL
SPORTS WELL THANK YOU. LINE ONE
EIGHTY THREE ONE EIGHT THREE
AIRLINE US OPEN. MADAM CHAIR
THIS IS ROBERT NAYLOR-
REPRESENTING FIELD SEVEN
COMPANY AN ORANGE COUNTY
BUSINESS STRONGLY SUPPORTING
THE M B. AND THIS BILL AB
TWENTY THREE TWENTY THREE.
LYING TO TWO ONE TWO TWENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR AND MEMBERS RICHARD MARX
AND FOR THE WESTERN ELECTRICAL
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
THREE TWENTY THREE THANK. IN
OUR FINAL COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
THIS TIME IS LYING TO TWO ZERO
TWO TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO THIS IS ABBY TUNING
CALLING FROM THE BAY AREA
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
NO THE LINES IN THE QUEUE
MANAGER PLEASE CONTINUE THERE
IS SOMEBODY LIVE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION JEREMY. WILL TAKE
THAT BEFORE WE GO TO THE PHONES
IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY
THREE TWENTY THREE THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH HERE
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
WE WERE OPPOSED TO THE BILL I
HAVE NOT SEEN HIM IN A LANGUAGE
THAT ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN
SPEAKS ABOUT WE- BUT DOES AS
YOU DESCRIBE IT THOSE ARE EXACT
CONCERNS. SO I LOOKED FORCING
THE THAT LANGUAGE AND WILL HELP
YOU HOPEFULLY REMOVE OPPOSITION
WHEN THE TIME IS CORRECT THANK
YOU THANK YOU I HOPE SO I TOOK
YOUR LETTER IN STRIDE. IS THERE
ADDITIONAL- OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONES AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY
THREE. IF YOU WANT TO COMMENT
IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY
THREE TWENTY THREE IN A PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. WE DO HAVE A
FEW LINES AND Q. ALTHOUGH FIRST
TO LINE NINETEEN ONE NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS IS
RICHARD DRURY ON BEHALF OF THE
LABORERS INTERNATIONAL UNION OF
NORTH AMERICA PACIFIC SOUTHWEST
REGION- WE HAD FORCED
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY TWENTY
THREE TWENTY THREE BECAUSE OF
THE COURT TV LIST PROVISIONS
WHICH WE THINK ARE IMPORTANT TO
SAFEGUARD WORKER HEALTH AND
SAFETY- WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE
AUTHOR HAS AGREED TO REMOVE
THOSE AND WE THINK THE OPERA
FOR THAT. OF COURSE WE NEED TO
SEE THE LANGUAGE- SO WHILE WILL
RESERVE FURTHER COMMENT WE'RE
ABLE TO USE THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION TO IT AB
TWENTY THREE TWENTY THREE IT
WOULD JUST BE YOUR NAME AND
POSITION AT THIS POINT. THE
NAME OF POSITION FROM THE BOND
WITH A LINE TO FOURTEEN TWO ONE
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WILL LINE TWO TO
THREE TWO TWENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YEAH YEAH ON. THE
EIGHTEENTH ALL I'M I'M I'M
PROBLEM FRESNO CALIFORNIA I
PROBABLY. I'D SAY A FIVE THAT
WE ARE NOT ON- THAT BILL WE ARE
ONLINE AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY
THREE IF THERE ARE PEOPLE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY THREE
TWENTY THREE I REALLY ASK THIS
THIS MEETING WILL GO ON ALL
NIGHT IF PEOPLE DON'T PAY
ATTENTION TO WHAT BILL WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT- SO THOSE OF YOU
WHO WANT TO SPEAK ON A
DIFFERENT BILL PLEASE WAIT YOUR
TURN THIS IS AB TWENTY THREE
TWENTY THREE IN OPPOSITION YOUR
NAME IN THE POSITION ONLY. TO
FOURTEEN. FIFTY ONE ASSURE YOUR
POSITION. YEAH MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MIKE WELL REPRESENTING
THE INTERNATIONAL UNION OF
PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES WERE
LINED WITH THE BUILDING TRADES
IN THE FOUR TO REMOVE IN OUR
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NINE ONE TWO ZERO ONE TWENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THAT BACKGROUND AND
THE AFTER THE TEAMSTERS WHICH
IS- ECHO THE SENTIMENT IN THE
BUILDING TRADES IN QUITE A FEW
WERE MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. THANK YOU. NO
FURTHER LINE CAN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME PLEASE CONTINUE MADAM
CHAIR THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCES ARE FILE. BY LETTERS
YOU'RE THINKING. CASH THE ECHO
I'M THANK YOU ARE THERE
QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
IF NOT- I'D LIKE TO TELL YOU
MISS FRIEDMAN THANK YOU FOR
WORKING WITH ME IN OUR
COMMITTEE ON THESE AMENDMENTS-
AS YOU KNOW IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT WE GET THESE HOUSING
BILLS RIGHT- WE WORK WITH ALL
OF OUR PARTNERS IN TRYING TO
ACHIEVE A WIN WIN SOLUTION AND
I HOPE WE I THINK WE HAVE ONE
HERE AND I HOPE- THAT PROVES TO
BE TRUE. SO WITH THAT I ASSUME
YOU RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THAT'S RIGHT. THANK YOU
THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL
WITH MISS BARRETT TIENDA MR
GABRIEL NOT VOTING. THANK YOU
MISS FRIEDMAN MISS GARCIA. I
THINK YOU ARE ONLY GOING TO
PRESENT ON ONE BILL TODAY THANK
YOU FOR BEING PATIENT WAITING-
AB EIGHT NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE
AND ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE A MOTION
BY MISS CARILLO A SECOND BY-
BUT MISTER CALDERON. YOU MAY
PROCEED. AT MEMBERS AB NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE WILL PROTECT PEOPLE
OF HEALTH REFRAIN THE
DISCLOSURE OF ALL ON
INGREDIENTS MISTER PRODUCTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK BRENT I'VE A.
THANK YOU- NECK CAN WE GO TO
THE PHONES ON AB NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE THIS IS NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE THAT IS THE ONLY
BILL WERE TAKING SUPPORT ON AT
THIS POINT. IF YOU'D LIKE TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. DO WE DO HAVE ONE LINE
AND GIVE ME JUST A MOMENT. ALL
RIGHT CAN WE GET ANY SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION. TO AB NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE. IF YOUR POSITIONS
IN OPPOSITION OF NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE YOU MAY ALSO PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONE IS IN Q. AT THIS TIME AND
CHAIR. OKAY.
NICK ARE WE STILL
WAITING ON ONE IN OPPOSITION.
NO I'M SORRY NO LINES IN Q. AND
EITHER POSITION I'M SORRY I
MISUNDERSTOOD THAT THEN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. WHY
THANK YOU- MISTER C. READ QUEST
A I VOTE THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL WITH MR BIGELOW
MISTER FONG NOT VOTING THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. IS
EDUARDO GARCIA I DO SEE OR HEAR
I DON'T KNOW. YOU ARE GOING TO
PRESENT ON A SUSPENSE BILL AB.
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY SIX. THANK
YOU THANK YOU ALL DIRTY FROM MY
DESK APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
PRESENT THIS. BILL AB TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY SIX IN JOSHUA
TREE PROTECTION ACT- I'D LIKE
TO JUST ADDRESS THE FISCAL
ANALYSIS THAT WAS A PRESENTED
TO THE COMMITTEE. RESPONSE TO
SOME OF THE CONCERNS WE'VE-
WANTED TO MAKE IT VERY CLEAR
THAT WE'VE AMENDED THE BILL TO
CREATE MEDICATION FUN WITH
SPECIFIC PURPOSE. OF PROTECTING
THE PARK. MY INTENT IS AN ONLY
IS THAT THE MONIES COLLECTED
FROM THE PENALTIES OF THIS BILL
WOULD BE USED TO MITIGATE ANY
ENVIRONMENTAL. DAMAGE TO THE
PARK. WELL THE ANALYSIS STATED-
POTENTIAL COST PRESSURES AND
LOW MILLIONS- THE FISCAL BURDEN
WOULD NOT BE PUT ON THE STATE.
BUT ON ANY POTENTIAL PROJECT
THE VIOLATES THE TERMS OF THE
BILL. BY CREATING THIS FUN WE
WOULD GENERATE RESOURCESTHAT
COULD BE USED TO PROTECT JOSHUA
TREE WHICH IS ROUGHLY FIVE
MILES FROM WHERE. A POSSIBLE
RENEWABLE ENERGY PROJECT IS
BEING PROPOSED. JUST A TREE
NATIONAL PARK AND ITS
ENVIRONMENTAL TREASURES ARE
VALUED BY MY CONSTITUENTS. THE
ONLY FOR ITS ENVIRONMENTAL. A
BEAUTIES OF BUT ALSO FOR
ECONOMIC TOURISM AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE REGION-
IT IS A VITAL- PLACE FOR OUR
REGION FOR THE STING FOR THIS
NATION WHICH IS WHY WE ARE.
ATTEMPTING TO PUT THIS BILL
FORWARD TO PROTECT- JOSHUA TREE
ON JUST TO HIGHLIGHT A- COUPLE
THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED IN
THE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THIS
BILL- AND NOT TO GET. TOO INTO
THE POLICY SIDE OF IT BUT IT'S
TIED TO THE FISCAL HOUSES- WILL
BE CLEAR THIS THIS BILL IS NOT
ABOUT A PROCUREMENT OF ANY.
PARTICULAR PROJECT- IN THE
REGION. AND THAT THAT'S BEEN
PART OF THE COMMENTS THAT WE'VE
HEARD BY OPPOSITION- THE BILL
ALSO CONTAINED NO LANGUAGE-
THAT WOULD- THAT PUT A COST AND
INCREASED OF. ENERGY COSTS TO
RATEPAYERS THIS AGAIN IS
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT. PROTECTION
JOSHUA TREE AND THE THIRD AND
FINAL POINT I'D LIKE TO MAKE
ABOUT THE BILL THE BILL
ABSOLUTELY DRESSES.
ENVIRONMENTAL CONCERNS BY
IMPOSING MEANINGFUL STATE LEVEL
SANCTIONS FOR ANY FAILURE TO
COMPLY. WITH GROUND WATER AT
USES- USES THAT WOULD BE- A
REQUIRED BY ANY POTENTIAL
PROJECT IN THIS AREA AND SO. WE
ARE FOCUSED ON TRYING TO AGAIN
PROTECT JOSHUA TREE- FOR MANY
ADVERSE AFFECTS OF ANY
POTENTIAL RENEWABLE ENERGY
PROJECTS WITHIN PROXIMITY TO
THE PARK- RESPECTFULLY NAM. ASK
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION AS YOU.
ENTERTAIN YOU KNOW THE SUSPENSE
CANDIDATES ARE WE DO HAVE. TO
INDIVIDUALS THAT WOULD LIKE TO
BRIEFLY- PROVIDE SOME TESTIMONY
TO THE BILL. I JUST WANT TO
REMIND ON THE WITNESSES YOU
WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES TOTAL-
AND SO. HAD ADDED MISTER WET
CHECKING FOR STARTING WITH YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS GOT WHICH
WILL BE HAVE TO CALIFORNIA
STATE PATRIOTS COUNCIL THE
STATE'S CESSATION OF LIKE
WORKERS TO CALIFORNIA COALITION
OF UTILITY EMPLOYEES. THE
ELEVATOR CONSTRUCTORS UNION IN
THE WESTERN STATES COUNCIL
SHEET METAL WORKERS- THIS A
BILLS REGARDING PROBABLY ONE OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT TO RENEWAL
ENERGY PROJECTS IN CALIFORNIA-
ON THE REASON FOR THE BILL IS
THAT THE BILL THE PROJECT HAS
BEEN MALIGNED. BY CHARGES THAT
THE FEDERAL ENERGY REGULATORY
COMMISSION WOULD NOT AND FORCES
OWN PERMIT. SO TO THE FISCAL
ISSUES HERE- THIS PROJECT WOULD
CREATE FIFTEEN THOUSAND JOBS IN
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN TAX REVENUE
PER YEAR THE TWO ISSUES RAISED
IN THE ANALYSIS REGARDING THE
COST IMPLICATIONS. IS THAT
THERE'S POTENTIAL LEGAL COSTS
FOR THE STATE WATER BOARD-
PETITIONING FOR UNDER THE
AUTHORITY OF THIS BILL. THE
FACT THAT FOR ACCEPTED ALL
THIRTY OF THE PERMIT CONDITIONS
REQUESTED BY THE WATER BOARD
AND BY. A FISH AND WILDLIFE
WITH THE COULD BE A VERY RARE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT THEY
WOULDN'T ENFORCE THEIR OWN
PERMIT. AND THEN SECONDLY THE
IT DENOUNCES POINTS OUT THAT
THERE MAY BE COST PRESSURE.
RESULTING FROM THE CREATION OF
THE JOSHUA TREE NATIONAL PARK
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION FUND-
MEMBERS I WOULD I WOULD SUBMIT
THAT THERE'S NO MORE RIGHTEOUS
BECAUSE THE CREATING OF FUNDS
TO PROTECT JOSHUA TREE AND THAT
WE CAN WERE STATE WE CAN
WITHSTAND THOSE PRESSURES
SHOULD THEY COME TO BEAR. WE
URGE AND I VOTE ON THIS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT BILL THANK.
WE GOT ABOUT THIRTY SECONDS
LEFT. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR-
GEOFF HARVEY- WORKED ON THE
EAGLE CREST ENERGY PROJECT FOR
THE LAST TEN YEARS
ENVIRONMENTAL PERMITTING WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL THE
ESTIMATE ACOSTA HUNDRED
THOUSAND PER YEAR. OR LOW
MILLIONS OVER TIME SEE VERY
HIGH THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YEAR
MAYBE A MAXIMUM FOR THE FIRST
TWO YEARSTHEREAFTER ANNUAL DAY
REVIEW SHOULD BE COREY SHOULD
BE A VERY SMALL COST MUCH LESS
THAN A THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE THANK YOU I WAS
RIGHT ON TIME WITHOUT WILL GO
TO THE PHONES THE IS ARE MORE
PEOPLE IN SUPPORT HERE. JUST
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION A
POSITION THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE
JEREMY SMITH HERE AGAIN ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
ALSO IN SUPPORT. IF THERE'S
NOBODY ELSE IN THE CHAMBERS OF
IN SUPPORT WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
THE PHONES IN SUPPORT AGAIN.
THIS IS MISTER EDUARDO GARCIA
IS BILL. TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY
SIX. NECK YOUR POSITION OF
SUPPORT ME PRESS ONE THEN
THEY'RE ALL WILL GO FIRST TO
LINE UP TO- FIVE TWO HUNDRED
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CALLER
ONTO A FIVE DO YOU WANT TO
COMMENT OR TO TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY SIX. Q. WILL MOVE ON THE
LINE IT WOULD BE SEVENTY THIRTY
SEVEN AIRLINERS OPEN. I LET THE
LEGAL ORDER WITH ERIC- CALLING
ON BEHALF OF A BUT HELLO DOLLY
NEARBY COMMUNITY FOR AB TWENTY
SEVEN THIRTY SIX- WERE THE
FOLLOWING NIGHT ENDORSEMENT- IF
SUPPORTERS AT RECOUNTED I'M
SORRY YOUR I'M SORRY. I'M SORRY
WE'RE JUST DOING A NAME-
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION. IT.
KNOW WHATI WANT TO GET THIS
TIME MANAGER THANK YOU AT I
THINK THERE NOW IT THE
OPPOSITION IS IN THE CHAMBERS
IS THAT CORRECT THEIR TWO
SPEAKERS YOU GET A COMBINED
TOTAL OF. TWO MINUTES. YOU MAY
BEGIN. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE NEIL
THE SIDE WITH THE NATIONAL
PARKS CONSERVATION ASSOCIATION
WE HAVE ADVOCATED FOR THE
PROTECTION OF OUR NATIONAL
PARKS FOR THE PAST ONE HUNDRED
AND ONE YEARS WE HAVE TWO
OFFICES IN THE CALIFORNIA
DESERT WHERE WE'VE HAD A
PRESENCE FOR OVER TWO DECADES
WE ARE PROUD DEFENDERS OF THIS
NATIONAL PARK AND LIKE EVERYONE
IN THIS ROOM ARE EQUAL OWNERS
OF THIS PUBLIC ASSET. AS WE
STATED BEFORE WE'VE WORKED WITH
THE AUTHOR IN ON UNRELATED-
ENVIRONMENTAL MEASURES AND KNOW
THAT HE IS A SUPPORTER OF
JOSHUA TREE NATIONAL PARK
HERE'S THE PROBLEM THE POLICY
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS CONFIRMS
THAT THIS IS NOT AN
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION BILL
HE CANNOT BE DUE TO FEDERAL WE
DON'T SPEAK TO THE POLICY
COMMITTEE HERE THIS IS AN AND
BE IN THE FISCAL. IMPACT OF
THAT NOTED CORRECT WITHIN THE
OUR COMMITTEE ANALYSIS- THIS
BILL IS NOT ADDRESSING AN
ISSUE- URGENCY THE WAY THAT- WE
SEE AND FEEL CRISIS- BEEN
PROPOSED FOR THE PAST TWO
DECADES AND HAS COME TO THE
STATE ASKING FOR IT THREE
BILLION DOLLAR- BAILOUT AND THE
LEGISLATURE HAS CONTINUED TO
SAY NO- AND SO WITH THAT WE
RESPECTFULLY- OPPOSED TO
PASSIVELY SET ASIDE. GOT ONE
MORE MINUTE IN OPPOSITION TO
THE RISK THAT CONVERTS THANK
YOU MANAGER JAZZ MONEY JONES
WITH THE INDEPENDENT ENERGY
PRODUCERS WILL REPRESENT YOU TO
GO OVER THE DOUBLE COMPANIES
OUT WE TOO ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL AS IT ANALYSIS CORRECTLY
POINTS OUT IS A LITIGATION
MAGNET OR TWENTY SEVEN
DIFFERENT GROUPS OPPOSED. TO
THIS. CLUB IN CALIFORNIA AND
NEVADA THOSE ASIAN THERE'S NO
NEED THIS BILL IS THE FOR TIME
I IF IT WE DO AVE AN EXISTING
OF THE PROCESS THAT THE P. YOU
SEE THAT THE WHETHER PROJECT.
OR NOT I HAVE A TREMENDOUS
ABOVE MY RESPECT FOR MR GARCIA-
BUT WE WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO
VOTE NO ON THIS- BILL BECAUSE
IT'S GONNA JUST INVOLVE THE
STATE AND UNNECESSARY
LITIGATION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. WITHOUT NECK WILL GO
TO THE PHONES IN OPPOSITION OF
AB. TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY SIX.
JUST SO YOU MAKE YOU UP BY THE
PRESS IN ONE AND THEN ZERO.
WE'LL GO TO LINE NINETY SIX
NINE SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
CAN MORNING CALL MORE HERE
CALIFORNIA WE'RE IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL. I'VE ALSO BEEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR THE
NAME ORGANIZATION ORGANIZATION
FOR MORE. WELL WE'RE THOUGHT IT
WOULD BE SAVINGS NOW WITH ALL
I'M SORRY. WE PLEASE THAT WE
ARE TAKING ONLY YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NO FURTHER
LINES AND GIVE IT TO HIM THANK
YOU DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NO
VIOLENCE HERE THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR PRESENTING ON THIS BILL
MISTER GARCIA IS SOMEBODY WHO
DOES MANY BILLS THAT ARE
LITIGATION MAGNET SAY- DO NOT
HOLD THAT AGAINST YOU EVEN
THOUGH IT IS IN OUR ANALYSIS SO.
I'M SORRY. FOR THAT I'M WITH
THAT IT IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATES AND WE WILL- MOVE
THAT SOON TO THE SUSPENSE
CALENDAR. MR. CHAO ARE YOU
GOING TO. I'M SORRY MISTER GORE
I SAW THAT YOU WALKED IN I'M
GONNA TAKE MR CHOW BECAUSE HE
HAS THE LAST PRESENT HE WANTS
TO PRESENT ON A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE SEE WHAT YOU STARTED
MISTER GARCIA PEOPLE ON THIS
SHOULD KNOW BETTER BUT MR CHOW
IS GONNA NOW PRESENT ON AB
TWENTY TWO SIXTY ONE WHICH IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE- AND THEN
WE'RE GOING TO DISPENSE OF THE
SUSPENSE CALENDAR. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE LAST TIME
CALIFORNIA TENTATIVE
COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTION ON
FACIAL RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY
WAS ABOUT TWENTY YEARS AGO
SINCE THEN THE INCLUSION OF
FACIAL RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY
IN OUR DAILY EVERYDAY LIVES HAS
PERSISTED AND THERE'S CONCERN
ITS APPLICATION WILL EXPAND AS
GOVERNMENTS AND PRIVATE
ENTITIES TURN TO THE
TECHNOLOGY. IN DEALING WITH A
COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC IN
CRIME FIGHTING SITUATIONS WERE
TIME OF IS OF THE ESSENCE SUCH
AS LOCATING MISSING CHILDREN
ARE VICTIMS OF SEX TRAFFICKING
THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT FACIAL
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY IS AND
HAS BEEN INCREDIBLY USEFUL. ITS
USE HOWEVER ALSO COMES WITH
SERIOUS CHALLENGES IN CONCERNS
SUCH AS THE ACCURACY OF THESE
SYSTEMS ON SOME RACIAL OR
ETHNIC GROUPS AND BIASES IN
FACIAL RECOGNITION ALGORITHMS
THERE ARE ALSO CLAIMS ON THE
USE OF FACIAL RECOGNITION
SYSTEMS BY STATE AND PRIVATE
ENTITIES TO TARGET IMMIGRANTS
AND PEOPLE OF COLOR. AND TO A
PRIVATE RELIGIOUS MINORITIES
AND DISCOURAGE FREE EXPRESSION
UNFORTUNATELY CURRENT LAW WE
HAVE A- IF ANY WE DISCOVER OR
LIMIT ITS USE SOMEONE IS
POLICIES HAVE BANNED THE USE OF
FACIAL RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY I
PUBLIC ENTITIES BUT PRIVATE
ENTITIES REMAIN LARGELY
UNREGULATED WE CANNOT LEAVE IT
TO A HANDFUL OF CITIES TO
REGULATE INTO SPACE BECAUSE IT
DOES NOT PROVIDE THE ADEQUATE
OVERSIGHT TO ADDRESS PRIVACY.
BYPASS AND OTHER WELL ISSUES
WOMEN'S HOPE PUBLIC PRIVATE
ENTITIES EQUALLY. AND EVERYONE
A THIS SHOULD BE FUNDAMENTAL
TEXANS AGAIN THE BASE USE
TECHNOLOGY AB TWENTY PENINSULA
WITH TO REGULATE THE USE OF A
CORRECT TO. BY COMMERCIAL STATE
AND LOCAL PUBLIC ENTITIES FIRST
WE WANT TO SEE ONE SURE. BY
REQUIRING MEANINGFUL THIS AND
SETTING HAD DEPLOYED. FACIAL
TECH. IT TO. OF FACIAL
RECOGNITION. FOR BIASES ACROSS
SUBPOPULATIONS IT REQUIRES
DEVELOPING TRANSPARENT POLICIES
AND PROCEDURES. WHEN USING THE
TECHNOLOGY IT REQUIRES PUBLIC
REPORTING TO ENSURE THE
RESPONSIBLE USE OF THE
TECHNOLOGY. TO IMPROVISE CHOICE
TO CONSUMERS REQUIRES EXPRESS
CONSENT WHEN COLLECTING
ENSURING AN INDIVIDUAL'S IMAGE.
IT ALSO GIVES THE MITCHELL THE
INDIVIDUALS THE RIGHT TO.
WITHDRAW CONSENT AT ANY IME
ACCESS THE LEAD CORRECT AND
CHALLENGE ANY ENROLLMENT OF THE
FACIAL IMAGES. AND FINALLY IT
THE PROVIDES PROTECTION BY
PROHIBITING ENTITIES FROM THE
NINE SERVICES FOR WITHHOLDING
CONSENT IT ALSO REQUIRES HUMAN
REVIEW OF FACIAL RECOGNITION
RESULTS TO PREVENT CIVIL RIGHTS
VIOLATION. IT WILL HIT IT
PROHIBITS- USING FACIAL
RECOGNITION FOR ONGOING
SURVEILLANCE WITHOUT A WARRANT.
IT ALSO PROHIBITS DEPLOYING
FACIAL RECOGNITION TO
DISCRIMINATE OR TO FILE A CIVIL
RIGHTS WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR IBM. THANK YOU MR
CHOW- DO WE HAVE. NICK THIS IS.
SOARING GOING BACKWARDS AB
TWENTY TWO SIXTY ONE- DO WE
HAVE SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE MR NECK IN THE COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO TWO SIX ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THAN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. TO CLARIFY IF YOUR
COMMENT IS NOT IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO TWO SIX ONE YOU MAY ALSO
PRESS ONE ZERO TO REMOVE
YOURSELF. WE DO HAVE A LINE IN
Q. AND BE JUST A MOMENT PLEASE.
WE'LL GO FIRST IN LINE TO ALL
FIVE TWO OH FIVE IS FOUR TWO
TWO SIX ONE. CALLER LINE TO A
FIVE ARE YOU THERE. WHAT WILL
BOND WITH ONLINE TO FIFTY FIVE
TWO FIVE FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS
THIS IS KIM STONE ON BEHALF OF
THE ACLU IN STRONG OPPOSITION
WE HAVE A LARGE COLLECTION OF
OVER SIXTY CIVIL RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION. PUBLIC HEALTH
ORGANIZATIONS LABOR
ORGANIZATIONS- IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
I THOUGHT WE ARE STILL IN
SUPPORT BUT THAT'S OKAY THAT
WAS IN OPPOSITION. DO WE HAVE
ANY WIND ONE FIVE ONE ONE FIFTY.
WHAT WE DO BOB PARMENTER LINE
ONE FIVE ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
YES MY NAME IS CAT CARRILLO ON
BEHALF OF THE SECRETARY OF THE
FEEL YOUR NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND I SPEAK UP STRONGLY IN
OPPOSITION. AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY
ONE. THANK YOU. IT WILL TAKE
ANY ONE THIRTY FOUR. THANK YOU
WILL WIND FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS TIFFANY AND I AM
COULD SUPPORT AT THIS STUFF.
THANK YOU. LINE ONE FORTY EIGHT
ONE FOUR EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. CALDERON YEAH ON ONE
THIRTY EIGHT DO YOU HAVE A
POSITION FOR A BI TO DEATH SIX
OR MY POSITION AS OPPOSE I'M A
MEMBER OF THE BAND FRANCISCO
TENANTS UNION AND- ALSO SUPPORT
THE ACLU'S POSITION- AS AS- IT.
THANK YOU AS IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
TWENTY ONE TWO ZERO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MADAM CHAIR THE MEMBER
MAP RIGHT HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
ENGINEERS AND SCIENTISTS THE
CALIFORNIA I HE LOCAL TWENTY IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AT THIS TIME THERE ARE NO FOR
THE LINES IN Q. YOU MAY
CONTINUE THANK YOU I'M A WILL
ASSUME EVERYBODY SINCE WE HAD
OPPOSITION DURING SUPPORT AND
SUPPORT AS WELL WE WILL SUGGEST
EVERYBODY'S BEEN SPEAKING ON
TWENTY TO SIXTY ONE. I'M
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. WHILE
THANK YOU- MR CHOW. I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR FOR YOUR
INDULGENCE SELL ABOUT TWENTY
YEARS AGO WHEN SB ONE SIXTY
NINE WAS UNDER CONSIDERATION BY
THE LEGISLATURE- IT'S OUGHT TO
RESTRICT THE USE OF FACIAL
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY IN ORDER
TO PROTECT BOTH PERSONAL
PRIVACY AND ALSO THE SECURITY
OF COLLECTED DATA IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL WERE GROUPS LIKE THE
ACLU WHO IS NOW IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL. LAST YEAR WHEN I
AUTHOR A SMALL A BILL AB TWELVE
EIGHTY ONE REQUIRING BUSINESS
TO DISCLOSE WHEN THEY ARE USING
FACIAL RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY
IT WAS OPPOSED BY THE ACLU AND
THE OPPONENTS ARE SAYING THAT
IT WAS AUTHORIZING THE USE OF
THE TECHNOLOGY WITHOUT
APPROPRIATE DISCLOSURE OF
CONSENT THERE WAS ALSO CONCERN
OF PROVIDING INFORMATION TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WITHOUT A
WARRANT OR PROBABLE CAUSE. IN
TWO THOUSAND ONE THE NARRATIVE
OF BY THE ACLU IN SUPPORT OF SB
ONE SIXTY NINE WAS THAT WE WERE
ENTERING AN ERROR. OR
TECHNOLOGIES OUTPACING A BASIC
PRIVACY RIGHT. AND I'LL
GOVERNMENT MISS EXERCISE SOME
CONTROL OVER THE RAPIDLY
DEVELOPING USE OF SOPHISTICATED
FACE IDENTIFICATION SYSTEMS.
BEFORE WE'VE BECOME A SOCIETY
UNDER CONSTANT SURVEILLANCE.
THIS BILL BEFORE YOU TODAY
EXERCISE THAT CONTROL HOWEVER
THE NARRATIVE OF THE OPPOSITION
TODAY. IS TO PUSH FOR A
MORATORIUMOF THE TECHNOLOGY.
AND THAT THIS BILL EXPLICITLY
GREEN LIKE THAT TECHNOLOGY.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THAT LIKE
HAS BEEN GREEN FOR TWENTY YEARS-WITH ALL DUE RESPECT. WORKERS
ALSO INDIVIDUALS OUTSIDE OF
THEIR EMPLOYMENT WHO NEED
PROTECTION FROM THIS TECHNOLOGY.
LET ME CLEAR- DOES NOT EXPAND
THE USE OF THE USE OF
TECHNOLOGY TO EMPLOYMENT
SETTINGS. AND WE ALL KNOW THAT
FACIAL RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY
HAS BEEN INTEGRATED INTO OUR
DAILY LIVES. OF. TWENTY THE
CASE THAT WE TAKE CONTROL OF
THE TECHNOLOGY RATHER THAN
LETTING IT CONTROL US. FAILURE
TO TAKE IMMEDIATE ACTION TO
REGULATE THIS TECHNOLOGY WILL
MAKE IT EVEN MORE DIFFICULT TO
REGULATE IN THE FUTURE BECAUSE
MORE AND MORE ENTITIES ARE
DEPLOYING FACIAL RECOGNITION.
SERVICES EVERY SINGLE DAY. DO
WE WANT TO WAIT ANOTHER TWO
DECADES ONLY TO LOOK BACK TO
THE STATE. AND REALIZE WE
FAILED ONCE AGAIN TO PROTECT
OUR INDIVIDUAL PRIVACY
PERSONALLY I REFUSED TO DO SO
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE THANK YOU. YOU MISTER
CHAO SINCE THAT WAS THE LAST
PRESENTATION ON BILLS THAT ARE
HEADED TO SUSPENSE FOR THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE ON THE LINE AND
I HOPE THIS MAKES IT MORE CLEAR
IT MAY NOT BUT I'M GOING TO
READ ALL OF THE BILLS AS WE
NORMALLY DO YOU NORMALLY
SECRETARY DOES THAT ARE BEING
MOVED TO SUSPENSE IT IS A VERY
LONG LIST THESE ARE BILLS THAT
ARE NOT GOING TO HAVE A
PRESENTATION TODAY SO YOU WILL
NOT HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT- ON THAT PRESENTATION.
IF AT THE END OF TODAY'S
HEARING YOU WANT TO. RECORD A
POSITION OF SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
YOU MAY DO SO DURING THE PUBLIC
COMMENT PORTION THAT'S ALL YOU
WILL BE ABLE TO DO ON THESE
BILLS. AND IT WILL BE AT THE
VERY END OF THE HEARING SO IF
YOU HEAR A BILL ON THIS LIST.
DO NOT- DO NOT AS- HERE IN INTO
THE VERY AND WHEN THE WHEN- THE
OPERATOR NICK ASKS YOU TO DO SO
THESE ARE ALL THE BILLS THAT
ARE BEING MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE
CALENDAR WHICH WE WILL DISPENSE
OF TOMORROW. AND WE'RE GONNA DO
IT ALPHABETICALLY BY AUTHOR.
AGUIAR-CURRY AB TWENTY TWENTY
EIGHT AB TWENTY FORTY SEVEN AB
TWENTY OH SIX AB TWENTY FOUR
SIXTY FOUR. ARAMBULA AB TWENTY
ONE EIGHTY NINE AB TWENTY NINE
EIGHTY NINE AB THIRTY EIGHTY
THREE. BAUER-KAHAN AB TWENTY
FOUR EIGHTY THREE AB TWENTY SIX
TWENTY SIX BERMAN. AB TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY EIGHT BIGELOW AB
TWENTY FORTY AB TWENTY SEVENTY
SIX BLOOM. AB TWENTY SIX NINETY
THREE AB THIRTY ONE OH SEVEN IN
AB THIRTY ONE EIGHT. BONTA AB
THIRTY TWO TWENTY EIGHT. BURKE
AB TWENTY FOUR OH FIVE AB
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY SEVEN AB
TWENTY SIX FIFTY EIGHT AB
TWENTY SIX SIXTY. CALDERON AB
TWENTY ONE FIFTY AB TWENTY
THAT'S IT SORRY I'M- JUST
TWENTY ONE FIFTY. THIRTY ALL AB
TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT AB
THIRTY FIFTY TWO. CERVANTES AB
TWENTY SIX SIX AB TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY CHAO AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY
ONE AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY EIGHT.
THAT IS AT MISTER CHAN AB
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. MISTER DAVID
CHIU AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY
NINE AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY
SEVEN AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY
SEVEN AB THIRTY FORTY AB THIRTY
NINETY SIX A. B. THIRTY TWO
SIXTY NINE. MISTER KANSEN CHU
AB TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY TWO.
MISTER CUNNINGHAM A. B.
NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO MISS DOLLY
AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY ONE A. B.
THIRTY SIX TEAM MR DAILY AB.
TWENTY SIX TO TWENTY ONE SIXTY
SEVEN AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY A.
B. THIRTY FIFTY THREE. DOCTOR
EGGMAN AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
MISS FRIEDMAN A. B. NINETEEN
SEVENTY NINE AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY ONE AB THIRTY SEVENTY
FOUR A. B. THIRTY ONE SIXTY
FOUR AB THIRTY TWO SEVENTY NINE
AB THIRTY THREE FIFTY TWO.
GABRIEL AB TWENTY FIFTY EIGHT
AB TWENTY TO THIRTY SIX A. B.
TWENTY TO SEVENTY ONE AB TWENTY
FOUR SIXTEEN AB TWENTY SIX
SEVENTEEN A. B. TWENTY SEVEN
FORTY SIX. CRISTINA GARCIA AB
TWENTY FIVE NINETY TWO AB
TWENTY NINE NINETY EIGHT. MR
EDUARDO GARCIA AB TWENTY SIX
SIXTY THREE AB TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY SIX AB THIRTY SEVENTY
NINE AB THIRTY TO FIFTY SIX AB
THIRTY THREE ZERO SEVEN. GIPSON
AB TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AB TWO
FIVE FIVE FOUR AB TWENTY SIX
FIFTY FIVE AB TWENTY NINE SIXTY
AB THIRTY ONE SIXTY NINE GLORIA
AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY TWO.
GONZALEZ AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY AB
TWENTY TWO FIFTY SEVEN A. B.
TWENTY THREE FORTY FIVE A. B.
THIRTY FIFTY SIX A. B. THIRTY
SEVENTY FIVE. I'M SORRY. GRAY
AB NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR AB
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY THREE A. B.
THIRTY FORTY FIVE GRAYSON AB
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY MR HOLDEN AB
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR AB TWENTY
NINETEEN AB TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
AB. TWENTY TWENTY SIX. MISS
IRWIN AB TWENTY THIRTEEN AB.
TWENTY TWO OH EIGHT TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY TWO AB THREE ONE ONE SIX
MISTER JONES SAWYER AB TWENTY
EIGHT NINETY ONE MISTER KALRA
A. B. NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN. AB.
TWENTY ONE EIGHTEEN AB TWENTY
THREE THIRTY TWO AB TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY FIVE AB THIRTY THIRTY AB
THIRTY TWO SIXTEEN. COM LAGER
AB NINETY IN NINETY THREE AB
TWENTY FIFTY FOUR AB TWENTY
FIFTY NINE MR LACKEY AB TWENTY
FOUR EIGHTY ONE. AB TWENTY
EIGHT THIRTY THREE A. B. THIRTY
SIXTY NINE MR LEVINE AB TWENTY
ONE SEVENTY EIGHT. MISS LOW
MOAN AB TWENTY SIXTY ONE AB
TWENTY TWO THIRTEEN AB TWENTY
FIVE OH ONE AB THIRTY TWO
FOURTEEN MISTER LOW AB TWENTY
ONE THIRTEEN AB TWENTY EIGHT
FIFTY AB TWO NINE NINE NINE. MR
MAIENSCHEIN AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTY MR MAYES AB TWENTY TWO
NINETY THREE MR MCCARTY AB
TWENTY TWENTY TWO A. B. ME TO
EIGHTY TWO AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY ONE A. B. TWENTY THREE
FORTY TWO. AB THIRTY TO THIRTY
I'M SORRY THIRTY TWO TWENTY SIX
MR MEDINA AB NINETEEN THIRTY MR
MULLIN AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY ONE
AB TWENTY EIGHT OH NINE MISTER
MURATSUCHI AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTY TWO AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY
TWO. MISTER NAZARIAN AB
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN AB TWENTY
TWO OH THREE AB TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY ONE MISTER OBERNOLTE AB
TWENTY ONE OH EIGHT A. B.
THIRTY TWENTY TWO. MISTER
O'DONNELL AB TWENTY FIFTY TWO
A. B. TWENTY ONE TWENTY SIX AB
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY FIVE AB
THIRTY THREE THIRTY. MISTER
PATTERSON AB TWENTY SIXTY FOUR
AB THIRTY TWO SEVENTY EIGHT.
AFTER QUIRK AB TWENTY TWO
NINETY SIX AB TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY ONE AB TWENTY EIGHT
HUNDRED MISS QUIRK SILVA AB
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY THREE.
MISTER RAMOS AB TWENTY ONE
TWELVE AB THIRTY NINETY NINE
MISS RADIUS AB TWENTY FIFTY ONE
AB TWENTY ONE FORTY SEVEN AB.
TWENTY TWO SEVENTY SIX. AB
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY ONE. AB
THIRTY ONE THIRTY FOUR. MISS
THREE OF US AB EIGHTEEN FORTY
FIVE MR ROBERT RIVAS AB TWENTY
FORTY THREE AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY
FOUR AB THIRTY ONE FIFTY FIVE
MISTER RODRIGUEZ AB TWENTY ONE
FOURTEEN AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN AB TWENTY NINE SIXTY
EIGHT A. B. THIRTY TWO TWENTY
FOUR. MISS BLANCA RUBIO AB
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE AB TWENTY
THIRTY AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
AB. THIRTY ONE ZERO ONE. MR
SALAS AB TWO NINETEEN OH SIX AB
NINETEEN TWENTY THREE AB TWENTY
TWO SEVENTY SEVEN AB TWENTY
FIVE FORTY NINE AB TWENTY SIX
FORTY TWO A. B. THIRTY TWO OH
FIVE A. B. THIRTY THREE OH TWO.
MR SANTIAGO AB TWENTY TWO
EIGHTEEN A. B. TWENTY NINE
SEVENTY THREE A. B. THIRTY
THREE HUNDRED A MISS SMITH. AB
THIRTEEN I'M SORRY EIGHTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN. AB THIRTY TO
THIRTY EIGHT MISTER MARK STONE
AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE AB
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY AB TWENTY
SIX NINETEEN AB TWENTY SEVEN
FORTY NINE. MR TEAM AB TWENTY
ONE NINETY EIGHT AB TWENTY FOUR
ONE THREE AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY
THREE MR VOEPEL AB NINETEEN
THIRTY FIVE MISS WALDRON AB
TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY SIX.
DOCTOR WEBER AB EIGHTEEN THIRTY
FIVE AB TWENTY NINE NINETY TWO
AB THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE A CA
FIVE. MISS WICKS AB TWENTY FOUR
OH SIX AB TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
FOUR AB TWENTY NINE THIRTY SIX
AB THIRTY NINETY TWO AB TWENTY
ONE HUNDRED AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY SEVEN. I'M SORRY THAT WAS
MISTER WHAT WE'RE ON NOW AB
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED AB TWENTY
THREE FORTY SEVEN AB TWENTY
FIVE NINETEEN. AB TWENTY SIX
FORTY FOUR IN AB TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTY. THE COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION AB TWENTY TWO
EIGHTY FIVE THE COMMITTEE ON
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS AB THIRTY TWO. TWENTY
AND THE COMMITTEE ON JOBS
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IN THE
ECONOMY AB THIRTY THREE THREE
SIXTY EIGHT. SO FOR THOSE ON
THE PHONE I WANT TO REITERATE
ALL OF THESE BILLS- THE AUTHORS
ARE WAVING PRESENTATION WHICH
MEANS THERE WILL NT BE A
CHANCE TO FORMALLY TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OUR OPPOSITION IF YOU
STILL WANT TO REGISTER ON YOUR
VOCAL SUPPORTER OPPOSITION FOR
ONE OF THESE BILLS THAT TIME
WILL COME AT THE VERY END OF
THIS HEARING WE HAVE A NUMBER
OF IT. IS TO GET THROUGH BEFORE
WE GOT THAT SO YOU SHOULD NOT A
TIME BE I'M PUNCHING IN FOR
ANOTHER BILL IT'LL COME AT THE
VERY AND- AND I DON'T
ANTICIPATE WILL GET ANYMORE I'M
POSITIONS ON A CA FIVE THEN
UNTIL THE VERY END YOU CAN ALSO
CHOOSE JUST NOT TO DO IT
VERBALLY AND I'M READY TO
YOURS. OUR OPPOSITION ONLINE WE
WILL READ THOSE AND INTERNALIZE
THOSE AS WELL I HIGHLY
RECOMMEND THAT- IF YOU DON'T
FEEL LIKE SITTING ON THE PHONE
FOR A FEW MORE HOURS SO. THOSE
ARE OPTIONS BUT THE BILLS ARE
MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE CALENDAR
TOMORROW THIS GROUP OF FOLK
FINE FOLKS WILL GET THERE ONE
MORE TIME TO DO. SINCE OF THIS
SPENT CALENDAR. THAT MISTER
GORE HAVE BEEN INCREDIBLY
PATIENT I'M SORRY ABOUT THAT.
WE HAVE A MOTION. AB TWENTY
FIVE SEVENTEEN FROM MISTER
CALDERON A SECOND FROM MISS
CARILLO. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
RIGHT AND STAY WITH A MOTION
AND A SECOND I WOULD JUST NOTE
THIS BILL HAS TO DEAL WITH
HELPING SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE WITHIN A HAS MINOR
OBSERVABLE COSTS TO THE STATE'S
COURTS- WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS KRISTIN
THEM SICK I WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP TO IN DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. I MADE BACK TO ASK
FOR HER TESTIMONY AND THEN
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR OF. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- TO THE FOLKS ON
THE FLOOR IS THERE ANYONE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
STE SEEING NONE GO TO THE
PHONES NECK DO YOU HAVE ANYONE
CUED UP. IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. THIS IS EIGHT OR NINE ONE
FIVE SEVENTEEN OR PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO. WE DO HAVE ONE
MIND GIVING UP. SPEAKER YOU CAN
SPEAK. SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT BUT
I CERTAINLY. SPEAKER CHECK YOUR
PHONE INSURANCE ON A SECTOR
LINE. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
KRISTEN I'M SICK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP TO
MYSTIC VIOLENCE PRONE TO
SPONSORED THE BILL AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I HOPE.
THANK YOU THE NEXT SPEAKER. NO
ONE ELSE CAN KILL. I'LL GO TO
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE. CAN YOU SEE IF YOU HAVE
ANY IN THE QUEUE. CONNECTED
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
WE HAVE NO KILLING UP AT THIS
TIME. WE HAVE WHEN. IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE FLOOR IN THE
AUDIENCE WISHING TO ADDRESS US
IN OPPOSITION SCENE NINE WE
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND ON A
FINANCE DEPARTMENT FIND. NO
FILE THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
MISTER GLORIA RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE THOSE. THAT BILL GUESS
OUT ON A ROLL CALL. THANK YOU.
SORRY ABOUT THAT. AB TWENTY
FIVE SEVENTY SIX THAT ENJOYS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION I HAVE A
MOTION BY MISTER BIGELOW TO
SECOND BY MISS CARILLO. IT
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
DISRESPECTFULLY ASK FOR THE
COMMITTEES I VOTE ON THIS BILL
WITH MINIMAL COST TO THE STATE.
IS THERE- ANYONE ON THE PHONES
IN SUPPORT OF TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY SIX. PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME IF
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT. HOLD. BY TWO
OH FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS JESSICA AND I
SUPPORT THE BILL. WE HAVE NO NO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU IS THERE
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION. TO
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY SIX. PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ENTER WENT THIS
TIME IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION.
NO THANK YOU. THANK YOU-
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. NO VIOLENCE
HERE THANK YOU THANK YOU. YOU
ASKED FOR AND I WROTE I DO NOT
INSURE WITH CREATION UNIT
COMMITTEE THANK YOU ON THAT
GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING MISTER YEP VOTING NO
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND YOU ARE
DONE MISTER GLORIA. I'M GONNA
SKIP MYSELF UNTIL THE END-
BECAUSE WE HAVE. HIS ANY FOR
EVERYBODY THAT DOESN'T SHOW UP.
SO WE'LL GO TO. MR HOLDEN. WHO
MISTER BLOOM YOU'RE GONNA
PRESENT FOR MR HOLDEN. THAT'LL
WORK AB TWENTY NINE EIGHTY
THREE THIS IS BY MR HOLDEN IT
ENJOYSA DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISS
CARILLO- A SECOND BY MISTER
REEVE US. TO BLOOM THANK YOU
AUTOMATED PHARMACY SYSTEMS CAN
BE HELPFUL FOR PEOPLE WITH
CHRONIC CONDITIONS TO TAKE GOD
DALY MEDIC CATIONS BY REDUCING
LAG TIME BETWEEN REFILLS BUT-
SOME LARGE PHARMACIES TAKE THIS
PROCESS A STEP TOO FAR BY
REQUESTING RECALLS BEYOND WHAT
WAS ORIGINALLY PRESCRIBED AND-
THIS BILL WOULD RESTORE BACK.
BY GIVING DOCTORS AND PATIENTS
MORE CONTROL OVER HOW MANY
PRESCRIPTIONS ARE AUTOMATICALLY
REFILLED AND ENSURE THE NUMBER
OF REFILLS PATIENT RECEIVED AS
RECOMMENDED BY THE DOCTOR NOT A
PHARMACY. I ASK FOR YOUR AYE.
THANK YOU ARE THERE- CALLERS ON
THE LINE IN SUPPORT OF TWENTY
NINE EIGHTY THREE. PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
IF YOUR IN SUPPORT. BEN AND
JERRY OF NOTING Q. THANK YOU
ARE THERE IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY NINE
EIGHTY THREE. AT THIS TIME
PRESS ONE AND ZERO IF YOU WERE
IN OPPOSITION. MADAM CHAIR WE
HAVE KNOWN IN Q. YOUR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAVE A
FILE. FILE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER BLOOM ON BEHALF OF MR
HOLDEN RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE THAT GETS OUT ON A. B.
ROLL CALL WITH MISS FARAH CAN
VOTING NO I MISS EGGMAN NOT
VOTING. THINK. IT IS NOW MISTER
KALRA IS CHANCE AND I KNOW MISS
CARILLO IS PRESENTING FOR
MISTER KALRA. IT'S AB TWENTY TO
THIRTY ONE IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE A MOTION
BY A MR REEVE US. AND A SECOND
BY A- MR GABRIEL. WHO THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. IF WE CAN GO TO THE
PHONES IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
TO THIRTY ONE THE COLORS IN
SUPPORT I'M SORRY BEFORE WE GO
TO THE FUNDS WE HAVE A LIVE
I'M- SUPPORTER AB TWENTY TO
THIRTY ONE JEREMY. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JR SMITH YOUR BEHALF
OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL OF
THE SPONSOR AND SUPPORTED
BETWEEN TWO THIRTY ONE. WE
AGREE WITH THE ANALYSIS THAT
FINALLY DEFINING AND STATURE
THE TERM TO MINIMUS WILL RESULT
IN MINOR COSTS AND WILL
ACTUALLY SAVE THE STATE MONEY
BECAUSE THE QUERY IT WILL
PROVIDE. WILL THE I. R. NO
INTERVENTION IN CASES WHERE
DEVELOPER DISAGREED PAYING
WORKERS THE PREVAILING WAGE. WE
ALSO BELIEVE THIS WILL SAVE
DEVELOPERS MONEY WHEN THEY'RE
PROJECTS GET DONE ON TIME AND
UNDER BUDGET BECAUSE OF THE USE
OF A SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE. FOR THOSE REASONS WE
ARE. TODAY THANK YOU KNOW HOW
TO THE LIONS I'M SORRY ABOUT
THAT AB TWENTY TO THIRTY ONE AS
THEIR SUPPORT. PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME WE
GO FIRST TO THE LINE OF TWO
EIGHT FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MEDICARE MEMBERS MIKE MONEY
GOING TO BE HALF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION LEXICAL
WORKERS THE CALIFORNIA STATE I
CREATE COUNCIL. THE WESTERN
STATES COUNCIL OF SHEET METAL
WORKERS. IN INTERNATIONAL UNION
THE ELEVATOR CONSTRUCTORS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL
GO TO THE LINE OF ONE SIX. AND
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MATT CRIME
AND HERE BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
THAT A CONFERENCE OF OPERATING
ENGINEERS HAPPY TO BE HERE
TODAY AND SUPPORT THANK. THANKS
TO THE TO THE LINE OF TWO EIGHT
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MADAM
CHAIR NUMBER EIGHT ON YOU
DROWNED THE CALIFORNIA CITY
COUNCIL PAPERS COSPONSORED
QUIRK. NEXT LINE ONE TWENTY ONE
TWO ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MAP BROUGHT
IN THE AFTER THE TEAMSTERS IN
COURT THANK YOU. AN EXTRA LINE
TWO EIGHT EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MIKE
WEST REPRESENTING INTERNATIONAL
UNION OF PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IN AT THIS TIME AND
I'M SURE THERE IS NO ONE
FURTHER IN Q. THANK YOU ARE
THERE ANY PEOPLE IN OPPOSITION
TO AB TWENTY TO THIRTY ONE. I
DON'T SEE ANY IN THE CHAMBERS
OR IS THERE ANY- ON THE PHONES
IN OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY TWO
THIRTY ONE. AT THIS TIME PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO IF YOU
ARE COMMENTING IN OPPOSITION.
WE DO HAVE AT LEAST ONE LINE
QUEUING UP. ONE MOMENT. IN TWO
THREE SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
AGREE WITH HIGH TECH ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION. CAN AT THIS TIME
MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE KNOWN FOR
THEIR IN Q. THANK YOU
DEPARTMENT FINANCED EVER FILE.
BY LETTING CHAIR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- MISS CAREER ON
BEHALF OF MISTER KALRA ASPIRIN
I VOTE THAT GETS OUT ON A. B.
ROLL CALL WITH MR TO GET VOTING
HI. MS COM LONGER. I DO NOT SEE
HER HERE OR NOR DO I SEE A NOTE
THAT SOMEBODY'S PRESENT- I AM
PRESENTING FOR HER. I WILL DO
THAT AT THE END. THAT IS A NOTE
TO MY STAFF THAT I DO NOT HAVE
TALKING POINTS BUT I DID SAID
PRESENT FOR HER MISLIM MON.
MISTER RIVAS FROM A SLIVER MON
THANK YOU AB TWENTY NINE
SEVENTY TWO MISTER REVERSE IS.
IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION MISS CARILLO
MAKES THE MOTION- MR GABRIEL IS
SECOND IN THE MOTION AND-
MYSTERY OF US THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR SO THIS BILL AB TWO NINE
SEVEN TO PROVIDE FOR ON LINE
TRAINING FOR CALIFORNIA
ADMINISTRATOR TO HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS RELATED
TO. A DOCUMENT STUDENTS. IN
THIS. ARE MINIMAL THAT THE
PRODUCTION OF THE ONLINE
TRAINING WILL COST BETWEEN
SEVENTY FIVE AND A HUNDRED
THOUSAND WITH MINOR MEANS COSTS
THERE AFTER RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR RIVAL FIGURE THIS ON
BEHALF OF MISS LOW MOAN AB
TWENTY NINE SEVENTY TWO ARE
THERE ANY SPEAKERS AND SUPPORT
ON THE PHONES. PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT. WE DO HAVE ONE
LINE QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT. AND
ONE ONE ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI FI CHANNEL AND THEN ON THE
HAVE TO CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY IN SUPPORT. EIGHTY
NINE AT THAT MAKE. THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN Q. THANK YOU IS
THERE ANYBODY WHO WANTS TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY NINE SEVENTY TWO. ON THE
PHONES. BEGIN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. MANAGER WE HAVE KNOWN
QUEUING UP THANK YOU DEPARTMENT
FINANCE GIVE A FILE. THANK YOU
ON BEHALF OF MISS LIMóN
MYSTERY OF US ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE TECH IS HOW TO BE ROLL
CALL WITH MR FONG NOT VOTING.
MR LOW. THEN YOU REPRESENTING
FOR MISTER LOW WE WILL SKIP
HAMMER MISTER NAZARIAN IS
ANYONE PRESENTING FOR MISTER
NAZARIAN WE WILL SKIP HIM. IS.
A STIR BLOOM YOU WILL PRESENT
FOR MISTER NAZARIAN. THANK YOU
THAT'S AB TWENTY ONE NINETY
NINE IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION I HAVE A MOTION
BY MISTER BIGELOW IN A SECOND
BY MISS CARILLO. REVENUE. MADAM
CHAIR AB TWENTY ONE NINETY NINE
EXTENDS AN EXISTING PILOT
PROGRAM THAT IS ALL BUT ALREADY
RESULTED IN OVER THREE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY THOUSAND SUCCESSFUL
PLASMA COLLECTIONS IN
CALIFORNIA. PLASMA COLLECTION
IS VITAL NOT ONLY FOR EXISTING
PATIENTS WHO RELY ON PLASMA
THERAPY FOR THEIR HEALTH. BUT
IT'S ALSO PLAYING A ROLE IN
HELPING ADDRESS THE COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC IN FACT LAST
NIGHT ON SIXTY MINUTES I
WATCHED A PIECE ABOUT THIS VERY
SUBJECT- SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR I'VE A- THANK YOU MISTER
FLOW. YET I BEST FOR OUR CAN WE
HAVE WE- CAN WE GO TO THE
PHONES TO SEE OF THEIR SUPPORT
FOR AB TWENTY ONE NINETY NINE.
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE DO
HAVE SEVERAL AND KILLING UP ONE
MOMENT. AND ONE ZERO SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MORE THAN THAT I'M SURE NUMBER
COMING DELGADO ON BEHALF OF
GRATEFUL THAT THE COURT. THANK
YOU APPLE. GIVE ME THE LINE
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR GIVING
DOLLARS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES USED
IN SUPPORT IN ADVANCE ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. IF WE GO
TO LINE SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BILL SPEAR WITH THE PTA
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. CAN WE
DOUBLE LATELINE QUEUING UP ONE
MOMENT. ONE TWO SEVEN NINE YOUR
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NOT OUR
INTERNAL REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA CHRONIC CARE
COALITION SUPPORT. CAN AT THIS
TIME AND I'M SURE WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE THANK YOU IS THERE
ANYBODY ON THE LINE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY ONE
NINETY NINE. AT THIS TIME FOR
AN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. SURE WE'VE KNOWN
TO KILL THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE TO HAVE A FILE. NO FILE
THANK YOU THANK YOU- ON BEHALF
OF MR NESS AREA MISTER BLOOM
SUGGEST WE GO WATCH SIXTY
MINUTES AND VOTE I ON A SNOW.
ALL RIGHT WITH THAT IT GETS
OUT. ON A ROLL CALL THANK YOU.
MS BARRICADES AND YOU'RE GONNA
PRESENT FOR MISTER DOCTOR
QUIRK- HAS TWO BILLS A. B.
WE'LL START WITH AB TWO THREE
THREE THREE EIGHT ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION. WE HAVE A
MOTOR AND AYE AYE I'M SORRY I
SCHOOL I DID STEP SKIP MISTER
PORTANTINO BECAUSE I'M TO DO
THEM ALL AT THE END THE ONES I
HAVE. THAT OKAY I'M SORRY. AB
TWO THREE THREE THREE- BY.
DOCTOR QUIRK AND ENJOY THE DO
PASSED WAY TO A MOTION BY MISS
CARILLO WE HAVE. A SECOND BY A
MISTER GARCIA THANK YOU SIR
GARCIA. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I'M PRESENTING AB
TWENTY THREE THIRTY THREE ON
BEHALF OF DOCTOR QUIRK AB
TWENTY THREE THIRTY THREE
ADDRESSES THE VOLUNTARY CLEANUP
PROGRAM WHICH LOCAL HEALTH
OFFICERS OVERSEE THE
REMEDIATION OF HAZARDOUS WASTE
SITES. THE BILL WILL HAVE NO
ADDITIONAL COSTS FOR THE STATE
WATER BOARD INDY TSC THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU WILL GO TO THE
PHONES ARE THERE SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT OF AB. TWO THREE THREE
THREE. CURRENT SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I'M SURE WE HAVE KNOWN
QUEUING UP. ALL RIGHT IS THERE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO AB TWO
THREE THREE THREE. HE WAS OPEN
TO HEAR AN OPPOSITIONAL PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND
I'M SURE WE HAVE KNOWN QUEUING
UP THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCES ARE FILE. THE FILE.
THANK YOU ON BEHALF OF DOCTOR
QUIRK I MISSED OUR QUE HAN
ASPIRIN AYE VOTES THAT GETS TO
BE ROLL CALL WITH MR DEEP IN
MISTER VOTING I AM SIR FONG NOT
VOTING MOVING ON TO AB THIRTY
THIRTY NINE FOR DOCTOR QUIRK
MISS I OKAY HEN WILL PRESENT IT
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
WE'VE A MOTION BY MISTER
BIGELOW IN A SECOND BY MISS
CARILLO THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
UNDER EXISTING LAW OTHER THING
REMOVING BREEDING THEM PROVIDE
LOANS AND GRANTS TO ASSIST
SMALL BUSINESSES WITH
COMPLIANCE. FEDERAL TORCHING
THE GRANT PROGRAM EXPIRE IN
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TO AB THIRTY THIRTY NINE EXTEND
THE PROGRAM UNTIL JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY SIX THERE'S NO
WOULD IT COST PRESSURES ANY
STATE AGENCY FOR THE SUNSET
EXTENSION EXTENSION THE BILL
HAS NO OP. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU-
THE DOCTOR COURTS BILL AB
THIRTY THIRTY NINE- NICK ARE
THEIR COLORS IN SUPPORT. IF
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I'M SURE WE HAVE KNOWN IN Q.
THANK YOU ARE THE COLORS IN
OPPOSITION. THE SENATOR
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I'M
SURE WE HAVE KNOWN IN Q. I'M
HERE TO OF FINANCE DO YOU HAVE
A- THE FILE. ALL RIGHT I
MISSPELLED CAN'T ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON BEHALF MINISTER QUIRK
AND I GETS OUT ON ON A ROLL
CALL WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO MR
ROBERT RIVAS BEFORE HE GOES I
JUST A NOTE I UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE ARE INDIVIDUAL LOBBYIST
CALLING IN ON BEHALF OF
MULTIPLE ORGANIZATIONS I
SUGGEST WHEN YOU START SPEAKING
YOU SAY. I AM. JOE LOBBYIST
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF ALL IN
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF ALL OF
THESE ORGANIZATIONS AND THEN I
WILL NOT CUT YOU OFF WHILE YOU
LIST THEM OTHERWISE IT'S HARD
TO HEAR IN HERE AND IT JUST
SOUNDS LIKE. YOU'RE TRYING TO.
SO AS- WE AND TALKING SOMETIMES
AT APPROPRIATIONS HEARINGS WE
DO- SO MISTER RIVAS WE WILL GO
TO YOUR A. B. WELL I AM SORRY
MISS CALM UNDER IS HERE. WE'RE
GONNA GO BACKWARDS THEN I DID
NOT SEE YOU BACK THERE. MS COM
LAGER- IS GOING TO PRESENT ON
AB NINETEEN FIFTY IT ENJOYS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION. AB
NINETEEN FIFTY HAS A MOTION BY
A MIS KERR RIO AND A SECOND BY
MYSTERY BOSS MISS COM LONGER
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE YOU GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB NINETEEN FIFTY.
WHAT'S THAT THE MAXIMUM
PROBATION PERIOD OF FOR
MISDEMEANOR OFFENSES IN TWO
YEARS FOR FELONY OFFENSES. AB
NINETEEN FIFTY CREATES
REASONABLE AND EVIDENCE BUT
IT'S ON PROBATION TERMS WHILE
LOWERING COSTS TO TAXPAYERS
INVESTING SAVINGS AND EFFECTIVE
MEASURES PROVEN TO REDUCE
RECIDIVISM AND INCREASING
PUBLIC SAFETY FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. YOU KNOW OUR
ADULT SUPERVISED PROBATION
POPULATION IS ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SIX THOUSAND
IT IS ONE OF THE LARGEST OF ANY
STATE IN THE NATION WHICH MEANS
THAT PROBATION OFFICERS
FREQUENTLY ARE MANAGING. HELLO
CASE LOW SUPERVISING PEOPLE DID
OF MINOR OFFENSES BUT NONE THE
LESS SENTENCED TO YEARS ON END
OF SUPERVISION THE LONG SOMEONE
STAYS ON PROBATION. CONSIDERED
BECOME. IF BECOME. TAX DOLLARS
DOWN THE DRAIN. MEANWHILE THE
DAILY COST OF TO PROVIDE AND
SOMEONE ON PROBATION IS ABOUT
TO A DAY. PROBATIONERS COVER
THE COST OF. EVERYTHING A LAB
TEST EVERY SINGLE FEE EVERY
SINGLE PROGRAM EVERY SINGLE
TIME THEY STEP INTO COURT THE
AVERAGE DEBT BURDEN. OF THE
THREE MOST CMMON FEES FOR
SOMEONE INFORMATION IS MORE
THAN THIRTY SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS
FAILURE TO PAY THE FEES AND
FINES WHILE ON PROBATION. OFTEN
RESULTS IN A VIOLATION I HAVE
TO SAY THAT- PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS ARE WORKING ON A
FAILED BUSINESS MODEL. AND AS A
RESULT THE OUTCOMES ARE FAILING
IT'S TIME TO MOVE TOWARDS
SUCCESSFUL OUTCOME. I ALSO WANT
TO NOTE THAT WE HAVE BEEN AND
VIGOROUS CONVERSATION- WITH.
OPPOSITION AND HAVE TAKEN MANY
AMENDMENTS- ALTHOUGH I KNOW
THIS IS A FISCAL POLICY AND NOT.
EIGHT OF FISCAL COMMITTEE I'M
SORRY NOT A POLICY COMMITTEE
BUT I KNOW THAT THERE BEEN SOME
CONCERNS- AND WE ARE CONTINUING
TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN
ESPECIALLY IN THIS DAY AND AGE.
IT'S A LAW THAT MAKES SENSE FOR
EVERYONE. AB NINETEEN FIFTY
WILL FREE UP STATE FUNDS THAT
COULD BE USED FOR ANTI
RECIDIVISM PROGRAMS. A LINE FOR
THE REINVESTMENT OF FUNDING
INTO SUPPORTIVE SERVICES FOR
PEOPLE ON MISDEMEANOR AND
FELONY PROBATION. RATHER THAN
KEEPING THEM ON SUPERVISION FOR
EXTENDED PERIODS. AB NINETEEN
FIFTY MAKE FINANCIAL SENSE. FOR
PROBATIONERS AND FOR PROBATION
DEPARTMENT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. I THINK WE
MAY HAVE A COUPLE OF WITNESSES
ON THE PHONE. OKAY SO I AM
THANK YOU FOR THE PRESENTATION
ON THE VERY UNICORN BILL THAT
SAVES US MONEY. WITH THAT I'LL
GO TO THE PHONES IN SUPPORT A.
B. NINETEEN FIFTY DO WE HAVE
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT. IF YOU'RE
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME WELL
FIRST GO TO THE LINE OF ONE ONE
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
GREGORY KRAMER ON BEHALF OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANKS TO GO TO LINE
ONE FIFTY ONE FIVE ZERO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MARCO GEORGE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. THANKS
TO GO TO THE LINE OF THREE TWO
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. DENNIS BUT
UP FOR MY WHAT THEY FEEL YOU OF
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT. THANKS
FOR YOUR TOTAL MIND ONE EIGHT
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. ERIN
HANGING WITH REFORM ALLIANCE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. MANAGER AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE NO IN FURTHER IN
Q. THANK YOU AM WILL GO NOW TO
OPPOSITION AB NINETEEN FIFTY-
AN OPPOSITION SEE NOBODY IN THE
CHAMBERS WILL TAKE THAT TO THE
PHONES. AT THIS TIME IF YOU'RE
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
DO HAVE IT LOOKS ONE MIND
KILLING UP ONE MOMENT. FOR THE
FIRST TO LINE THREE HUNDRED
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON- DANIEL PENSIONS ON
THE OPPOSITE YOU PROBATION
OFFICERS CURRENTLY OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED I JUST VERY
BRIEFLY WE CERTAINLY RECOGNIZE
AND SUPPORT THE INTENT AND
RESEARCH BEHIND THEM ALL-
HOWEVER FROM A FISCAL
PERSPECTIVE- THE CHANGE TO
SHORTEN. WOULD HAVE A DIRECT
AND NEGATIVE IMPACT ON SB SIX
SEVENTY EIGHT. WHICH REALLY
HAVE BEEN. THANKS WILL GO TO
LINE TWO THREE ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IF ANY MATTHEWS ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION AND ARE
IN OPPOSITION BUT HAVE BEEN IN
TALKS WITH THE AUTHOR AND HOPE
TO FIND COMMON GROUND. AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE NO ONE FURTHER IN
Q. MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU KNOW
DEPARTMENT FINANCE OF A FILE.
HOLLINGER THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
I'M WITH THAT HAS COME UNDER
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE ON AB
NINETEEN FIFTY GETS OFF ON A B.
ROLL CALL WITH MISS BARRICADE
HAND- VOTING NO MISS
PETRIE-NORRIS BUT YOU KNOW I
MISTER CHAO NOT VOTING THINGS
COME LATER. I STILL MISTER LOW
DID I NOT OKAY MISTER LOW WE
ARE GOING TO YOU. I'M YOU'RE
PRESENTING ON ONE BILL AB
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT IT HAS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION AS
AMENDED TO STRIKE THE
REQUIREMENT FOR AN IN PERSON
VISIT. IN A DEAD INSERT CLEAR
FINING CONSUMER PROTECTION
PROVISIONS RELATED TO
ORTHODONTICS YOU MAY PROCEED
AND I KNOW THIS IS A WORK IN
PROGRESS YOU'RE STILL WORKING
ON SO WE WILL- TAKE THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU FOR THE
APPOINTMENT. THE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM CHAIR IN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND YOU ON THIS BILL
THIS ENSURES THAT WE HAVE
ADDITIONAL CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
WITH RESPECT TO NEXT RAIN
ENSURING THAT. WE HOLD TO
ACCOUNT THE IMPORTANCE OF A
PRIORITIZING CONSUMER
PROTECTION OF A PROFIT OF TECH
ROSA RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE.
THANK YOU MISTER LOWE. IF WE
HAVE SPEAKERS- IN SUPPORT OF AB
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT WE'LL GO
TO THE PHONES AB. NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT. PLEASE PRESS ONE
IN AN ERA AT THIS TIME IF YOU
WERE IN SUPPORT. THE MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MERRY MCKENNA THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION
HEARING TODAY IN SUPPORT. OF
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT AS
OPPOSED TO BE AMENDED. THE MAN
HAD MINOR AN OBSERVABLE COSTS
THEY IN PERTINENT PART
CLARIFIED THE LEGISLATIVE
INTENT OF LAST YEAR'S DENTAL
BOARD SUNSET THOUGH. AND THE
INEVITABLE ESTABLISHED STANDARD
OF CARE THAT REQUIRED EXTREME
TO BE REVIEWED PRIOR TO THE
MOVING OF PATIENTS HE- FELL.
EVEN CITY A- URGENT I THANK BE
TO VOTE ON A B. LIKE B. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AT THIS TIME
MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE KNOWN IN Q.
YOU SAY THERE IS NO ONE IN THE
QUEUE. I CRACKED KNOWN
FREDERICK YOU WELL NOW THAT
OPPOSITION- THOSE OPPOSED TO AB
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT ON THE
PHONES. PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION.
WE DO HAVE A FEW LINES KILLING
UP ONE MOMENT.
WE'LL GO TO LINE
TWO EIGHT SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS CORPS
IN JENSEN ATTACK MAN IN
OPPOSITION TO AB NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT WE APPRECIATE THE
OFFER WORKING ON AMENDMENTS TO
THIS BILL BUT REMAIN CONCERNED
PARTICULARLY ABOUT THE
AMENDMENT TO SECTION SIXTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT H. WHICH WOULD
TAKE A PEN AND- A PAPER SENATE
OUT OF THE DECISION MAKING IT
AND THEY IN FACT. WITHOUT BRING
THE APPLICABILITY AT EXISTING
TECHNOLOGY IS OR THOSE THAT
MIGHT BE AVAILABLE IN THE
FUTURE- WE HAVE NOT YET SEEN
ANY CLINICAL EVIDENCE THAT
SUPPORTS REQUIRING RADIOGRAPHS
FOR EVERY PATIENT SPEAKING
ORTHODONTIC THE ITALIC
DENTISTRY. IN ADDITION NEED TO
BE ABLE TO MAKE THEIR DECISION
THAT ARE IN THE INTEREST OF
THEIR- THIS BILL THOSE
DECISIONS WAY IF I PULLED IN.
THIS AMENDMENT WOULD ALL TO GET
BEGAN THE INCREASED COPPER
CONSUMER UTILIZING TELE
DENTISTRY IN CALIFORNIA AND
IT'S- BOARD EMERGED INTO AN IN
PERSON VISIT FOR IMAGING. THAT
THERE ARE NO RADIOGRAPHS
AVAILABLE THE AVERAGE COST FOR
A DENTAL VISIT IS TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY EIGHT DOLLARS AND THE
AVERAGE COST OF ACTUARIES ABOUT
SEVEN HUNDRED DOLLARS. DENNIS
USING REMOTE TECHNOLOGY AND HOW
THEY ARE LIGHT CALIFORNIA
DENNIS ARE FOLLOWING THE SAME
BUT IT WILL BE UNDER THROUGHOUT
THE VALUATION DIAGNOSIS AND
TREATMENT. OF THOSE PRACTICING
IN A TRADITIONAL BRICK AND
MORTAR SETTING ALL LICENSE
DENNIS REGARDLESS OF WHAT TOOLS
THEY'RE USING ARE SUBJECT TO
THE SAME RULES AND ENFORCEMENT
AFTER THE DENTAL PRACTICE ACT
AND GOVERNED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DOT. ORG AGAIN WE APPRECIATE
THE MAJORITY OF THE MOMENT
HOWEVER WE DO NOT BELIEVE
PRESCRIBING A STANDARD OF CARE
IN STATUTE IN CALIFORNIA IS
APPROPRIATE. AND WILL ONLY LEAD
TO INCREASED COSTS. FOR
CONSUMERS THANK YOU. GO TO LINE
THREE ZERO FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CAROL CAROLINE BEALE HUNTER ON
BEHALF OF SMALL DIRECT WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL. MEXICO TO
LINE THREE THREE THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. OUR UPLAND CALIFORNIA
NAACP OPPOSED THE BILL. TWELVE
LINE THREE THREE FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES DOCTOR MARK ARE
COMING FROM THE AMERICAN
TALIBAN THREE TALKING SHE ALSO
A CALIFORNIA LICENSE CENTER MY
NONPROFIT HIS DONE ECONOMIC
IMPACT STUDY HELLO DENTISTRY IN
CALIFORNIA AND I'D LIKE TO
SPEAK ABOUT AB NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT HUNDRED CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY. AB NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT WE HAVE USED UP THE TIME
PERIOD FOR I'M SORRY SIR WE'VE
USED UP THE TIME PERIOD ALREADY
FOR COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION SO
NOW IT'S JUST YOUR NAME YOUR.
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR- ADDITION.
DEADLINE THREE THREE FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HI THIS IS
BECAUSE SANDRA JENNINGS
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE
GREATER SACRAMENTO URBAN THE
ALSO REPRESENTING THE IRVINE
LANES IN SAN DIEGO AND LA WE
ARE OPPOSED. TO EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT. THANK
YOUR MANAGER AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE KNOWN FOR THEIR IN Q.
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
TO SERVE FILE. NO FILE. THANK
YOU I SEE NO QUESTIONS MISTER
LOW I KNOW YOU'RE COMMITTED TO
WORKING ON THIS BILL WOULD YOU
JUST LIKE TO ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ESPECIALLY ESTARá. THANK
YOU. DID YOU HAVE A QUESTION-
I'M SORRY I'M- DO WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THIS WE HAVEN'T TAKEN
A MOTION I'M SORRY MISS KOREA
WAS. COMMITTEES RIGHT OF SHE
WOULD LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL
THAT WILL BE SECOND MY MISTER
RIVAS- THAT GETS OUT ON AND A
ROLL CALL WITH MR DEEP MISTER
BIGELOW AND MISS EGGMAN NOT
VOTING. THANK YOU MISTER LOWE.
MR SALAS- YOU'RE OUT OF ORDER
I'M SORRY WE'RE GONNA GO BACK
TO IT YOU'RE YOU'RE NOT OF MYST
MYSTERY THIS IS GOING TO LET
YOU JUMP AHEAD MR SALAS. YOUR
FIRST BILL IS AB THIRTY ONE
SIXTY THREE IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. I HAVE A MOTION.
BY MISS CARILLO A SECOND BY
MISTER CHAO. THE THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS ON
PLEASE PRESENT AB THIRTY ONE
SIXTY THREE TO THE COMMITTEE
TODAY AB THIRTY ONE SIXTY THREE
WILL HELP CALIFORNIA MEET IT'S
CLEAN ENERGY GOALS I WILL
CREATE MORE CLEAN OR NON
RENEWABLE ENERGY FOR RICH AB
THIRTY ONE SIXTY THREE WILL
EXPAND THE DEFINITION OF BIO
METHANE TO INCLUDE SO YOUR LONG
EXAMPLE FOR WASTE WHICH IS
CURRENT. EXCLUDED UNDER THE
DEFINITION. THE THIRTY ONE
SIXTY THREE WILL HELP
CALIFORNIA PRODUCE MORE CLEAN
BIOENERGY WILL. REDUCE HARMFUL
EMISSIONS FROM OPEN THEIR
BURNINGS AND LANDFILLS. OF
WOODY MATERIAL. THIS BILL DOES
NOT IMPOSE ANY NEW STATE OFFICE.
THE NUMBERS WILL JUST TELL YOU-
IF YOU'VE EVER DRIVEN UP THE
FIVE OR THE NINETY NINE YOU
MIGHT HAVE SEEN. LARGE. THEN
I'LL JUST TAKE THE MOTION AND
THE SECOND I APPRECIATE THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I BUT I
DO HAVE A WITH THIS IS A SPORT.
ALL RIGHT WE THE BILL WE
SECONDED I'M SORRY WHERE. GOT A
LOT OF STUFF GOING ON HERE. AB
THIRTY ONE SIXTY THREE WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO THE PHONES- I
DON'T KNOW THERE'S SOMEBODY
HERE IN SUPPORT LIVE YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES COMBINED SO USE
THEM WISELY GOOD MORNING JULIE
I HAVE BEEN WITH THE BIO ENERGY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA. SB
THIRTY ONE SIXTY THREE IS
CRITICAL TO REDUCE THE MOST
DAMAGING CLIMATE POLLUTANTS
KNOWN AS SHORT LIVED CLIMATE
POLLUTANTS AND TO ACHIEVE
CARBON NEGATIVE EMISSIONS
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
AND LAWRENCE LIVERMORE NATIONAL
LAB. THESE ARE HIGHLY COST
EFFECTIVE REDUCTIONS IN CARBON
EMISSIONS AND AIR POLLUTION
THERE WILL BE NO COST TO THE
STATE AND ACTUALLY THIS IS A
HEAVILY OF INTENSIVE AREA
BIOENERGY CREATES MORE JOBS PER
MEGAWATT OR PER DOLLAR THAN ANY
OTHER FORM OF ENERGY SO WE ARE
TO COMMIT TO PASS THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I LIKE
YOUR MASK. I AM CHRISTIANA
DARLINGTON WITH PLASTER
POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT. I'M
HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL TO RECOGNIZE THE FACT THAT
WHEN YOU OPEN PILE
AGRICULTURAL. WERE FORCED
WASTE. THANK YOU YOU CRAZY
CONTRIBUTE SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS
OF CRITERIA POLLUTANTS TO THE
AIR AND WITH THIS TECHNOLOGY
REDUCE IT BY NINETY EIGHT
PERCENT. BASED ON STUDIES AT
LEAST IN. WITH THE DISTRICT AND
THEIR RESOURCES HARD. CAP HELLO
WHICH IS THE ASIAN ABOUT THIRTY.
SINCE THIS. THANK YOU THANK YOU
WILL NOW GO TO THE PHONES IN
SUPPORT OF AB. THIRTY ONE SIXTY
THREE. PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME IF YOU WERE IN
SUPPORT WE GO TO LINE THREE ONE
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. MATT
YEAH ORIGINALLY. CRIED YES
JULIE NO ONE OUT THEBALL ON
THE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA BIOMASS
ENERGY ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR THIS IS TERRENCE
MAKE WITH SAN JOAQUIN
RENEWABLES AN ENVIRONMENTAL
COMPANY LOCATED IN KERN COUNTY
CALIFORNIA. RESPECTFULLY
VOICING STRONG SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. THANK I COULD
ALIGN ONE SEVEN TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING PRESS
OCULUS ON BEHALF OF THE
FOLLOWING ORGANIZATIONS SALT
LAKE THAT THE ASIAN OF NORTH
AMERICA AND WESTERN PLASTER
WASTE MANAGEMENT AUTHORITY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ACTUALLY GO
TO LINE THREE FIVE TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING ON
CHAIR OF LYING AND KENNY WITH
CLEAN ENERGY IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. AN ONLINE THREE FIVE
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS REALLY A HOLIC
IF THE VISION OF CALIFORNIA
WATER AGENCIES HERE AND QUIRK
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND ONE
THREE FOUR ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WELL IT IS THE VALLEY
VIEW TRIO WITH REIMAGINE POWER
IN WIDE WITH ENERGY AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANKS TO GO TO NINE
ONE ONE NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU TERRY MEMBERS TIONNE
INSTITUTE A ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN COALITION
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. IN ONE
THREE FIVE FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES THANK YOU SURE
MEMBERS THIS IS LORD IF HE
MANAGED ON BEHALF OF SO CAL GAS
IN STRONG SUPPORT. IN AT THIS
TIME AND I'M SURE WE HAVE KNOWN
FURTHER IN Q. THANK YOU SO MUCH
AB THIRTY ONE SIXTY THREE AND
OPPOSITION DO WE HAVE- SPEAKERS
IN. OPPOSITION. ON THE PHONES
AND PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION. AND WE DO HAVE A
LINE QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT.
APOLOGIZE FOR THE DELAY WE DO
HAVE A COUPLE LINES QUEUING UP
ONE MOMENT. WITH ALL TO THE
LINE OF THREE FOUR SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO DEAR CALL
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. THANK YOU WE HAVE TWO
MORE LINES KILLING UP. NINETY
NINE FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
KILEY GARIBAY AND IN ON BEHALF
OF THE FOLLOWING ORGANIZATIONS
AND OPPOSITION TO THE BILL-
TRAFFIC AND NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL THANK YOUNG.
NINE THREE FIVE NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING SHARON
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MICHAEL DAFT
WITH THE PAN MAKE KAYLEE ON
BEHALF OF REPUBLIC SERVICES IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY ONE SIXTY
THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
ON THAT AND CHAIR WE HAVE NO
AND FURTHER IN Q. THANK YOU TO
PART OF FINANCED YOU HAVE A-
PHONE. THE PLANT MANAGER THANK
YOU. THANK YOU- WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. OF THANK YOU MEDICARE
JUST SAVE YOU HAVE RENEWABLE
ENERGY GROUPS WASTE MANAGEMENT
GROUPS AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
DISTRICT ALL IT'S FOR
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT EITHER.
THANK YOU KNOW THAT GETS OUT ON
A ROLL CALL WITH MISSPELLED QUE
HANNAH MISS PETRIE-NORRIS
VOTING NO MR BLOOM MISTER BONTA
MR GABRIEL THE CHAIR NOT VOTING
THANK YOU MISTER CELIS. I THINK
THE REPUBLICANS AB NINETEEN
FORTY FIVE ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION THAT GETS OUT.
NO FOR THE LET'S PRESENT ON THE
BILL. CURRY SECOND BY MISTER
RIVAS- AB NINETEEN FORTY FIVE
SORRY JUMP JUST AHEAD OF MYSELF
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- KEEP
THIS BRIEF FOR THIS BILL
ACTUALLY HELPS AND RECOGNIZES
ALL OF OUR DISPATCHERS UP AND
DOWN THE ENTIRE STATE AS YOU
KNOW A LOT OF THEM ARE
MISCLASSIFIED EITHER AS
ADMINISTRATIVE OR CLERICAL THAT
CAN NUYS AS THEIR LIFESAVING
WORK I DO BELIEVE WE HAVE A
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF ALL
THAT SPEAK TO YOU. BECAUSE THEY
DO. ALL RIGHT NEXT WE GOT SOME
SUPPORT FOR A BI NINETEEN FORTY
FIVE- WE HAVE SOMEBODY LIVE
OKAY I'M SORRY IN THE CHAMBERS
A. B. NINETEEN FORTY FIVE DID
SEE A MANAGER ONE MEMBERS MARK
SMITH ON BEHALF OF CAL NINA THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
NATIONAL EMERGENCY NUMBER
ASSOCIATION. OTHERWISE KNOWN AS
NINE ONE ONE DISPATCHERS WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THIS BILL.
WHEN ALL OF US ARE HAVING THE
WORST DAYS OF OUR LIVES NINE
ONE ONE DISPATCHERS ARE ALWAYS
THERE TO ANSWER THE PHONE THEY
WILL ALWAYS BE THERE. THIS BILL
SHOWS IN THE RESPECT AND GIVES
IN THE CREDIT THAT THEY DESERVE-FOR THE HARD WORK THAT THEY DO.
WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT TO
NETWORK- BACK TO THE PHONES NOW
AB NINETEEN FORTY FIVE.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT. PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME IF
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT. WE DO HAVE
SEVERAL AND QUEUING UP IF YOU
ARE CONNECTED AS A WITNESS YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AND WE WILL GO
FIRST TO LINE THREE ONE FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MA'AM CAREFUL THOUGHT I'M OFF
NINE ONE ONE DISPATCHER ON
BEHALF OF COUNTY NOT IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN FORTY
FIVE. Q. AND ALONE NOW TO LINE
FIFTY NINE FIVE NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIRMAN MY NAME IS DOING A
YOUNG AND I AM A FORMER
PRESIDENT OF THE EL NINO NINE
ONE ONE DISPATCHER ASSOCIATION.
AND REQUESTING PRETTY WORK CELL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. OUTLINED
THREE SIX THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS SOMEONE THE ARM FROM
CHINO Q. ARE STRONGLY OPPOSE
EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE TWO. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT- FOR THE
FIFTEENTH TIME TODAY I WANT TO
REMIND FOLKS THAT WE ARE ONLY
TAKING TESTIMONY ON THE BILL
THAT WE ARE ON. WE ARE
CURRENTLY ON AB NINETEEN FORTY
FIVE I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S
A LOT OF CONFUSION. BUT ANY
CALL FOR A CA FIVE- WHICH HAS
ALREADY BEEN- WAVES FOR
PRESENTATION GETS MOVED TO THE
VERY END OF THE HEARING SO THIS
IS AB NINETEEN FORTY FIVE-
WE'RE STILL HAVING SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT WITH YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION. DO WE HAVE ANY
MORE NECK. WE DO HAVE A LATE
LINE QUEUING UP. THE NUMBERS
DON'T. THIS MATERIAL AND OPEN.
I CAN MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MY NAME'S TINA BRAZIL I
PRESIDENCY HE PUBLIC SAFETY
DEFECTORS ASSOCIATION AND
SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT AT
CALIFORNIA THEY WERE LAW
ENFORCEMENT SO HERE'S AN- WHERE
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN
FORTY FIVE WHICH FOR THE FIRST
TIME I WRECKED MY PUBLIC SAFETY
DISPATCHER THE COMMUNICATION
OPERATOR. AT FIRST RESPONDED
WITHIN THE MARK THANK YOU THANK
YOU I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE WE'RE
JUST TAKING NAME AN
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION.
THANK YOU. THIS TIME WE'VE
KNOWN FOR THEIR IN Q. IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU DO WE HAVE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION OF AB
NINETEEN FORTY FIVE. ON THE
FUNDS. PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB ONE NINE FOUR
FIVE. MANAGER AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO IN KILLING UP. THANK
YOU DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
TERRIFYING. NO PLAN THANK YOU
MISTER SALAS OF IT IF YOU WOULD
I'D LIKE TO BE A- ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR ON THIS BILL AND I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD I ASSUME YOU'RE ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE. YES CHECK IT
OUT ON A ROLL CALL THANK YOU
YOUR- MR JONAH I'M SORRY YOUR
DOWN HER READY MISTER TEEN. MR
STONE TWO BILLS. AB TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY TWO ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION- IT'S MOVE
BY MISS CARILLO A SECOND BY
MISTER CALDERON. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS
A BILL TO PRESERVE. AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AT THE LOCAL LEVEL WITH
RESPECT TO MOBILE HOME PARKS
AND THEIR CONVERSION. THE
FISCAL IMPACTS ARE NEGLIGIBLE
AND I ASK FOR YOUR ABOUT. THANK
YOU- WE WILL GO. TO SEVEN
EIGHTY TWO IT IS- TO DO WITH
MOBILE HOME PARKS ARE THERE
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT ON THE
PHONES. PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME IF YOU'RE INTO PORT.
WE GOT A LINE ONE ONE FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS GREGORY
KRAMER ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY
RIGHT CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU YOU DON'T ALIGN SIXTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS LISA AARON THE DIRECTOR OF
LITIGATION AND COMBINING THAT
PUBLIC LAWCENTER IN ORANGE
COUNTY AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY TWO.
THANK YOU IF YOU'RE CONNECTED
AS A WITNESS FOR THE SPELL YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AT THIS TIME WE HAVE KNOWN FOR
THEIR QUEUE MANAGER THANK YOU
IS THERE ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION
TO AT TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY TWO.
ON THE PHONES. AT THIS TIME
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AND AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO
ARGUING A MANAGER THANK YOU
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NO FINAL
CHAIR THANK YOU. YOU MISTER
STONE ASPER NIVEAU TECH IT'S
OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL AB THIRTY
THREE SIXTY SIX IT ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION I HAVE A
MOTION BY MS CARILLO A SECOND
BY MISTER RIVAS MR STONE THANK
YOU THIS JUST ADDRESS THE
JUDICIAL EMERGENCIES DURING
TIME LIKE TIMES LIKE THESE NO
FISCAL IMPACT. THANK YOU THIS
IS AB THIRTY THREE SIXTY SIX
ARE THERE COLORS IN SUPPORT.
THIS TIME OF YEAR AND SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. MANAGER WE HAVE
KNOWN QUEUING UP. ARE THERE ARE
SCHOLARS IN OPPOSITION AB
THIRTY THREE SIXTY SIX. AND NOW
IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND MANAGE OTHERS NO ONE
QUEUING UP. THANK YOU
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. FIVE AB
THIRTY THREE SIXTY SIX. FINANCE
NOW. NO FILE MANAGER THANK YOU
THANK YOU- THERE'S A LITTLE BIT
OF CONFUSION MISTER STONE IF
YOU HOLD ON THAT YOUR BILL IS
GETTING OUT.
I GET OUT ON A
ROLL CALL THANK YOU MISTER
STONE THANK YOU WITH THIS THE
TIME NOW WORK IN THE CHRISTMAS
FOR FREE CA FIVE. OF MR STONE
GHOSTED ON THE PHONES UNTIL THE
END OF THE HEARING AND THEN YOU
CAN REGISTER YOUR SUPPORT. MR
TEAM AB. TWENTY SEVENTY SEVEN
ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION- THAT'S THAT A
MOTION BY MS CARILLO IN A
SECOND BY MISTER CALDERON THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR THE AB TWENTY
SEVEN SEVEN IS A BILL THAT
EXTENDS THE SUNSET DATE OF
CURRENT LAW THAT ALLOW THE
RETAIL SALE OF FURNISHING OF A
HYPODERMIC NEEDLES OR SERVICE
TO A PERSON EIGHTEEN YEARS OR
OLDER. BUT OUR PRESCRIPTION- IT
CAN THE THROUGH JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY SIX- THIS
PRODUCES THE SHARING OF
SYRINGES AS WELL AS DISEASE
TRANSMISSION SCOTT WIDE SUPPORT
IN THE STATE OFFICE OF EIGHT C.
PH IN CDC I WILL JUST VERY
QUICKLY POINT OUT THE
OPPOSITION LETTER BLOGS-
INACCURATE COMES JUST THINKING
THAT THERE IS OUR SALES ABOUT
PURGING SUPPORTING STOPS. SEC
VIEWS REMAIN A PART ARE
REQUIRED PROVIDE FOR. ABOUT TAX
DRUG TREATMENT TESTING FREE OF.
HAVE C. IN STATE DISPOSAL OF
SHARP WASTE WITHOUT RESPECT ASK
FOR. THANK YOU MISTER KING THAT
IS A- TWO SEVENTY ARE ANY.
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE IN SUPPORT.
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO THREE
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU TAMMY MARTIN ON BEHALF OF
THE QUALITY CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. I'M GOING TO NINE
THREE SEVEN SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING CONTACTED WITH A
CO SPONSOR DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE.
CALIFORNIA HELICOPTERS OF
CALIFORNIA THE CENSUS GRAY
FOUNDATION. AND WE HAVE LINE
TWO FOUR FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
A GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
NUMBER SUCH YOUNG FROM ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVE ASSOCIATION AND
TRANSPORT. AND MANAGER WE HAVE
NO ONE FURTHER IN Q. THANK YOU
WITH DID YOU SAY THAT WAS.
WE'RE DONE WITH THE SUPPORTERS.
BACK ALL RIGHT WE WILL MOVE TO
OPPOSITION ON AB TWENTY SEVENTY
SEVEN. PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION. AND MADAM CHAIR WE
HAVE KNOWN QUEUING UP THANK YOU
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NO FILE
MANAGER. THANK YOU SEE NOBODY-
MISTER TEEN AB TWENTY SEVENTY
SEVEN GETS OUT OF THE ROLL CALL
WITH MISS PETRIE-NORRIS NOT
BETTING RADIO I'M GONNA GO BACK
FOR JUST A MOMENT ON A
CORRECTION OF A VOTE FOR MR
STONE- AFTER HIS STUNT THE
REPUBLICANS HAVE DECIDED TO
PULL THEIR SUPPORT FROM HE I'M
JUST I'M JOKING I'M JOKING BUT
THERE WE MUST READ OUT AB
THIRTY THREE SIXTY SIX IT IT IS
STILL IT DID PASS BUT IT PASSED
WITH REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
AND WE AND WE WILL CORRECT THAT
NAY OFFICIAL THING SO AB
THIRTY. THREE THREE SIX SIX. AB
TWENTY SEVENTY SEVEN PASSED-
AND NOW. WE MOVE ON TO MISS
WEBER SHE'S NOT HERE I WILL
PRESENT FOR HER AT THE END-
MISS WICKS. BAUER-KAHAN YOU'RE
PRESENTING FROM THIS WICKS. AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY ONE. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MISS CARILLO AS
SECOND BY MISTER CALDERON THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WICKS AND
PRESENTING AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY
ONE THE BILL REDUCES PARKING
LOT REQUIREMENTS ON FAITH BASED
PROPERTY TO BILL HOUSING THE
COMEDIAN ALICE'S INDICATES NO
STATE COSTS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE. THANK YOU ARE THERE
SPEAKERS ON THE LINE IN SUPPORT
OF AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY ONE BY
MISS WICKS. PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME WE WILL GO TO
LINE TWO ONE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE TWO ONE SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MOVING ON WITH A
LINE NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MATT INSURING
COMMITTEE MEMBER THAT INCLUDES
MARKET WITH CALIFORNIA BE INTO
COURT AND THAT'S WITH THE HAPPY
TO GET JUST RECAP MONEY ABOUT
THE BILL WITH ON THIRD OF IT.
I'M AT THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS A
CORRECTLY NOTE THAT WHILE THE
BILL MAY CREATE A LOCAL MANDATE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO LEVY EITHER ON
HOUSING THE BILL WOULD NOT
CREATE A REIMBURSABLE FIT ME
THEY MANDATE FOR ADDITIONAL
THEY CAUGHT WE ARE YOU FOR IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
AND WE DO HAVE FIVE LINE TWO
ONE SEVEN QUEUING UP PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINETY
ONE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE MATTER NOT LIKE HAVE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS CALLING ON
BEHALF AND HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS A THREE
PIECE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANA MADAM
CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE Q. THANK
YOU ARE THERE SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION TO AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY
ONE ANY SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
ON THE TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO IF YOUR IN
OPPOSITION. AND I'M SURE AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NO ONE
QUEUING UP. THANK YOU-
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAVE A
FILE. FILE THANK YOU AS I'M
SURE MISS WICKS WOULD LIKE AS I
VOTE THAT GETS OUT WITH THE
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING MR DF
VOTING NO AND MISTER FONG YOU
MISTER VOEPEL VOTING HI MOVING
ON TO MISS WORK SECOND BILL AB
TWENTY THIRTY SEVEN BEING
PRESENTED BY MISS ABOUT K. HAND
THEY LISTEN JOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE A MOTION
BY MISS KOREA IN A SECOND BY
MISTER CALDERON THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR PRESENTING AB TWENTY
THIRTY SEVEN ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WAX THE BILL
INCREASES THE REQUIRED TIME
HOSPITAL MUST GIVE TO
COMMUNITY. THE PLANS TO REDUCE
OR ELIMINATE LEVEL OF A MAGIC
MEDIC EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES TO ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY
DAYS OR SIX MONTHS THE BILL
ALSO INCREASES THERE WERE
REQUIRED AMOUNT OF TIME A
CLOSING HOSPITAL FILLING YOU
MUST NOTIFY THE COMMUNITY TO
ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY DAYS OR
SIX MONTHS AND REQUIRES THE
HOSPITAL FACILITY THAT IS
ILLUMINATING RELOCATING A
SUPPLEMENTAL SERVICE TO AT
LEAST NINETY DAYS PRIOR THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS STATES THAT
THE COST IS MINOR AND ABSORB
ALL. OBSERVABLE THE RIGHT.
THANK YOU DO WE ON THE PHONES
ANY SUPPORTERS OF AB. TWENTY
THIRTY SEVEN. PRESS ONE AND
ZERO IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT WE
DON'T ALIGN EIGHTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS CAN WORK ACT OF THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
WHERE THE SPONSORS OF THE BILL.
SIMPLY RECEIVED QUESTIONS I DID
ONE NOTE THAT THE LOCAL ANGELI
SIMILAR TO A BILL THAT MANY
PASSED LAST YEAR WHICH RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND WITH UNFORTUNATELY
VETOED. HOWEVER THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE HAVE COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH A FROM A LANGUAGE
THIS YEAR AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION THANK
YOU TO THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
PRESENTING- AND I ASK FOR YOUR
ABOUT. IN MANAGER WITH NO ONE
FOR THEIR IN Q. THANK YOU IS
THERE ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION OF
AB TWENTY THIRTY SEVEN. PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO NOW IF YOU'RE
IN OPPOSITION. I DO HAVE AT
LEAST ONE LINE QUEUING UP ONE
MOMENT. WE WILL GO TO LINE
THREE TO FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU THE MORNING CHAIR
MEMBERSTHIS IS ALICE HAWTHORNE
AT THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION- AS HOSPITALS
CONTINUE TO EXPERIENCE PHYSICAL
STRAIN UNDER THE CURRENT
PANDEMIC WE DO REMAIN OPPOSED
UNLESS THE MINUTES OF THIS
BILL. TO MAKE A NOTIFICATION
REQUIREMENT SIXTY DAYS INSTEAD
OF THE ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY
PROPOSED THE BILL. AS NOTED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S VETO MESSAGE ON
A SIMILAR BILL LAST YEAR GIVING
NOTICE THIS FAR IN ADVANCE IN
HIS IN THE CLOSURE OF A
HOSPITAL BY CREATING FINANCIAL
AND PATIENT SAFETY ISSUES. SO
THIS TIME WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
ASKING CORY KNOW ABOUT UNTIL.
THANK YOU CHAIR WE HAVE KNOWN
FOR IN Q. THANK YOU. DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. WELL MEDICARE.
THANK YOU. THE STAFF CAN WOULD
LIKE AND I ON BEHALF OF MISS
WICKS THAT GETS OUT ON A. B.
ROLL CALL THANK YOU MISTER
SANTIAGO. WITH ME I'M SORRY LET
ME GO BACK TO THE AB TWENTY
THIRTY SEVEN BY MISS WICKS THAT
GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL WITH
MISS BETWEEN OR SOMETHING. MR
SANTIAGO YOU ARE HERE. ON AB
TWENTY SIX NINETY NINE IT
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISS
CARILLO SECOND BY MISTER
CALDERON. A RESERVE LASSEN IDLE
MANAGER. THANK YOU. AT NICK AB
TWENTY SIX NINETY NINE-
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT. YOUR AND
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. MADAM
CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE SHOWING UP
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY SIX NINETY NINE. YOUR IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I'M
SURE THERE'S NO ONE QUEUING UP.
THANK YOU. MISTER SANTIAGO THAT
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL THANK
YOU THANK YOU. I'M GONNA GO
BACK IN THE FILE- TO MISTER
RIVAS I AM SORRY I SKIPPED OVER
YEAR- WHEN OTHER PEOPLE STARTED
COMING IN. MR RIVAS YOU HAVE AB
TWENTY NINE FIFTY FOUR ENJOYS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION I HAVE A
MOTION BY MISS CARILLO SECOND
BY MISTER CALDERON. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- SO THIS BILL IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE INTENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA RESOURCES BOARD
TO ESTABLISH AN OVERALL CLIMATE
GOAL FOR THE STATE'S NATURAL
AND WORKING LANDS IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AB. THREE TWO
SCOPING PLAN UPDATE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS BILL ARE
MINOR AND ABSORB. THANK YOU
BRING THE PHONES FOR IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY NINE FIFTY FOUR.
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME IF YOUR IN SUPPORT. YOU
NOW HAVE A DELAYED QUEUING UP
ONE MOMENT. WE APOLOGIZE FOR
THE DELAY WE DO GO TO LINE OF
THREE SIX FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THEY ON THE APPLE THE FOLLOWING
ORGANIZATIONS IN SUPPORT OF THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY AUDUBON
VINYL DEPEND ON THE MILLION
CHAU CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT
SOCIETY CALIFORNIA. AND WE WILL
NOT A LINE THREE NINE EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THREE NINETY
EIGHT RIGHT. THAT'S CORRECT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OKAY MY NAME
IS JUGGLING ALL FROM CHINO
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY OFFICE OF.
EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE. THANK YOU WE
ARE ON AB AND WE HAVE NO
INTEREST IN Q. THANK YOU I JUST
WANT TO REMIND- FOR THOSE ON
THE PHONE OR AT HOME WE ARE ON
AB TWENTY NINE FIFTY FOUR
PLEASE ONLY- COME ON IF YOU ARE
TRYING TO REGISTER SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION FOR THAT BILL. THOSE
OPPOSED TO AB TWENTY NINE FIFTY
FOR THE PHONES PLEASE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME IF YOU WERE IN OPPOSITION.
WE DO HAVE LINE THREE NINE. WE
HAVE NO IN HERE AT THIS TIME
MANAGER PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO HAVE A
FILE. YEP MANAGER WE DON'T HAVE
THE AND THE COMMISSION ON THE
BILL BUT WE KNOW THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
AND STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD ESTIMATED
REQUIREMENTS IN THE BILL ARE
OBSERVABLE- WE WOULD NOTE
THOUGH THAT THE EXPEDITED
TIMELINE PROPOSED BY THE BILL
COULD RESULT IN ADDITIONAL
STATE COST. NOT CONTEMPLATED BY
CURRENT FEE SCHEDULE SAYS THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU-
MYSTERY VEST YOU'RE ASKING FOR
AN AYE VOTE AS A PRIVATE THANK
YOU THAT ACCOUNT ON A BI ROLL
CALL WITH MISS EGGMAN NOT
VOTING. NEXT HAVE AB THREE ZERO
ZERO FIVE IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO PROVIDE
FLEXIBILITY WITH TIME FRAMES TO
MAKE OTHER TECHNICAL CLARIFYING
CHANGES. IT IS I MISS CARILLO
THERE'S A SECOND BY MISTER
CALDERON AND DO- EXCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS- AND THIS
BILLS ON THE BILL THREE ZERO
ZERO FIVE EXPECT THE EXPEDITED
DAM SAFETY FOR SILICON VALLEY
ACT. ASA SO HE WITH HIS BILL-
TO BOTH DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE AND STATE WATER BOARD
ARE MINOR AND I'M SO LITTLE
RESPECT WE ASK WHEN I. ALL
RIGHT WE'RE ON AB THREE ZERO
ZERO FIVE SPEAKERS. IN SUPPORT
NICK. SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. THE
TRUCK WITH A ONE NINE KILLING
UP ONE MOMENT. SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION. I APOLOGIZE WITH A
DEADLINE COMING UP I'M SORRY.
OUR FIRST LINE WILL BE LINE ONE
FOUR SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS FOR BLOOM
REPLICATING THE SANTA CLARA
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT ALSO
KNOWN AS VALLEY WATER WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT EIGHTY THREE
THOUSAND FIVE TO EXPEDITE THIS
CRITICAL PUBLIC SAFETY WATER
SECURITY AND ENVIRONMENTAL
PROJECT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITH A LINE
THREE SEVEN ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BUT IT IS JACK FROM YOUR
A CALIFORNIA AND I STRONG
SUPPORT. EIGHTY THREE ZERO ZERO
FIVE. AND WE HAVE NINE THREE
EIGHT ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. EACH. MY THREE OF
YOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WELL
HELLO. YES YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO. YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD AB THREE ZERO ZERO
FIVE. MOVING ON WE HAVE KNOWN
FOR THEIR IN Q. ALL RIGHT-
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. MADAM
CHAIR SPOKE ON THE BILL FOR THE
PREVIOUS- ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS
STILL- WE DON'T HAVE A POSITION
ON EIGHTY THREE THERE THERE ARE
FIVE BUT WE KNOW THE DEPARTMENT
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE AND THE
WATER BOARD ESTIMATE MINOR
DOUBLE. I WE DO NOT HOWEVER
THAT THE EXPEDITED TIMELINE
PROPOSED BY THE BILL- COULD
RESULT IN ADDITIONAL THEY
CAUGHT NOT CONTEMPLATED BUT
CURRENT VEHICLE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MYSTERY GUEST THE
REQUESTED I WROTE YES MA'AM
THANK IT'S OUT ON A ROLL CALL
THANK YOU I'M I'M SORRY I WE
SKIPPED AROUND ON THESE THERE
ARE TWO MORE- BILLS AB TWENTY
NINE FIFTY SEVEN ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MISS CARILLO AND A
SECOND BY MISTER ALDERON
TWENTY NINE FIFTY SEVEN MADAM
CHAIR THE BILL THAT ALLOWS
LICENSE WINERIES TO FILL
CONSUMER PROVIDE OF BOTTLES
OTHER GROWLER. AT ONE AND SO
THIS BILL SIMPLY LIST A
RESTRICTION ON WINERIES WHO
WILL NOT ADD EXTRA COSTS NO
RESPONSIBILITIES TO THE ABC
RESPECT BATTERY OUT THANK YOU
AB TWENTY NINE FIFTY SEVEN WILL
GO TO THE PHONES THIS IS A BILL
ABOUT GROWLERS FOR WINE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME IF YOUR IN SUPPORT. I'M
SURE WE HAVE KNOWN KILLING A-
DO WE HAVE ANY TO AB TWENTY
NINE FIFTY SEVEN PEOPLE WHO
DON'T LIKE WINE. NOW OPEN IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. MADAM
CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE QUEUING UP.
ALL RIGHT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
NO FILE MANAGER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU A MYSTERY BEST
EVERYBODY HERE LIKES WINE THAT
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL AB
THIRTY FIFTY THREE IT ENJOYS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION THIRTY
ONE FIFTY THREE I SHOULD HAVE
BACK ON MY GLASSES- AB THIRTY
ONE FIFTY THREE I HAVE MISSED
CARILLO IS- MAKING THE MOTION
MISTER CALDERON SECONDING IT.
YOU MAY PROCEED THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR OF THIS BILL INCENTIVIZE
BIKING CARSHARE PARKING IN NEW
HOUSING THAT DEVELOPMENT
PROJECTS CAUSES SO HE WITH HIS
BILL ARE MINOR AND AFFORDABLE
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF. HOUSING
COMMITTEE DEVELOPMENT- RESPECT
AS WE HAVE A- THIS IS AB THIRTY
ONE FIFTY THREE- IT ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION DO WE HAVE
SUPPORTERS ON THE LINE. AB.
THIRTY ONE FIFTY THREE. THE ART
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME WE WILL
GO TO LINE TWO ONE SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ONE SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE MATTER NOT LIKE
HOW PUBLIC AFFAIRS CALLING ON
BEHALF OF HABIT AT HER KNEES
CALLING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIAN BE INFORMED ABOUT
THANK YOU. AND WE GO TO LINE
THREE SEVEN ZERO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO THIS IS JACK FROM
YOUR CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AND- AT THIRTY ONE
FIFTY THREE THANK YOU. THAT
CHAIR AT THIS TIME THERE IS NO
ONE FURTHER IN Q. IS THERE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO AB
THIRTY ONE FIFTY THREE. PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME IF
YOU WERE IN OPPOSITION. I'M
SURE THERE IS NO ONE QUEUING
UP. THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THE FILE. NO FILE ALL
RIGHT MYSTERY VESTS YOU'D LIKE
A AYE VOTE YES MA'AM THANK YOU
THAT GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL
WITH MR FONG NOT VOTING. OKAY
MINUTE. ALL RIGHT I THINK I'M
PRESENTING DO WE PRESENT FOR MR
BLOOM FOR MR HOLDEN. YES WE DID.
ALL RIGHT. I'M I'M PRESENTING
FOR RODRIGUEZ I'M PRESENTING
FOR. WEBER PORTANTINO IN RAMOS
IF I CAN PRESENT FROM HERE AND
AMANDA MISTER VICE CHAIR
ALRIGHT HAD JUST LET ME KNOW
WHICH ONE. YOUR AB. TWENTY ONE
NINETY SIX. OUR PRESENT ON AB
TWENTY NINE ONE NINETY SIX I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE IT'S THE PILOT X.
DEPENDING IT EXTENDING THE
SUNSET ON THE PILOT PROGRAM
SMALL DOLLAR LOANS. FOR THE
MOTION BY MS CARILLO- SECOND BY
MISTER CALDERON. THIS IS THE
TWENTY ONE NINETY SIX. AB
TWENTY ONE GONZALEZ. IT'S YOUR
BILL WOULD YOU LIKE TO- PRESENT
FORTY JORDY PRESENT THAT
PRESENTED YOU DID PRESENT NOT A
LENGTHY PRESENTATIONS I'M A
LITTLE CONCERNED ABOUT THAT TO
SEND SAID EXTENSION WAS PULLED
OFF CONSENT. LET'S GO TO THE
PHONES WERE HAVING TOO MUCH FUN.
ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
TWENTY ONE NINETY PART PLEASE
PRESS. THANK YOU PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT. WE DO
HAVE A FEW LINES KILLING UP ONE
MOMENT. WE WILL GO TO LINE.
LINE FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS I TELL US MORE ON
MONDAY MEDICAL STUDENT AT UC
SAN DIEGO SCHOOL OF MEDICINE
AND I'M CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE.
IT'S A STORY THIS IS NOT THE
TIME FOR RESPONDING TO A SCENE
FIVE ON WERE ONA BILL AB
TWENTY ONE NINETY SIX YOU WILL
BE ABLE TO COMMENT OUR REGISTER
YOUR POSITION AT THE END OF THE
HEARING- WHEN WE CALL FOR IT
THANK YOU FOR CALLING AND- NICK
COULD YOU FIND SOMEONE THAT
WANTS TO RESPOND TO TWENTY ONE
NINETY SIX. IN SUPPORT OUR WE
HAVE NO ONE IN QUEUE FOR
SUPPORT OKAY HOW ABOUT
OPPOSITION. THIS TIME IF YOU'RE
IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY ONE
NINETY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AS WE HAVE KNOWN IN
Q. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS
BILL GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
WILL MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT BILL
WHICH IS AB. TWENTY THREE
FOURTEEN RAMOS. THIS GONZALEZ I
BELIEVE YOU HAVE THE FLOOR
YOU'RE GOING TO PRESENT FOR AND
ON BEHALF OF- MR ALMOST THIS IS
ABOUT A BILL ABOUT NATIVE
AMERICAN VOTING ACCESSIBILITY I
RESPECT ADVISORY COMMITTEE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE WE
HAVE A MOTION AND SUPPORT FROM
HIS CARILLO AND WE HAVE A
SECOND BY MISS PETRIE-NORRIS.
WE'LL GO TO SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT
ON THE PHONE SEEING NONE IN THE
GALLERY. NICK DO YOU HAVE
ANYONE QUEUING UP FOR THIS BILL
23-14. AT THIS TIME PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. I'M
SORRY I DIDN'T HEAR YOUR WAY OF
KNOWING QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME
NO ONE SHOWING UP. CORRECT SIR.
OKAY ANYONE IN OPPOSITION. THIS
TIME IF YOU WERE IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. SIR WE HAVE KNOWN
QUEUING UP DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING.
NO FILE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THIS BILL GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL. WILL BE MOVING ON TO OUR
NEXT BILL. THAT'LL BE AB TWENTY
FIFTY THREE MISTER RODRIGUEZ.
NOW NINETY TWO. ONLINE OKAY
THERE IS NO TWENTY THREE FIFTY.
MY AIR TWENTY NINETY TWO MISTER
RODRIGUEZ EMERGENCY AMBULANCE-
EMPLOYEES. THANK YOU ON BEHALF
OF MISTER RODRIGUEZ THIS WOULD-
ALLOW EMS EMPLOYEES TO REQUEST
PP. RESPECT IS CARILLO MOVES A
BILL MISS PETRIE-NORRIS SECONDS.
GOING TO THE GALLERY IS OR
ANYONE IN STE WISHING TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. SEEING
NONE TO THE PHONES. DOES ANYONE
WISH TO ADDRESS US IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL IS THIS TWENTY
NINETY TWO. PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT. YOUR CARE THERE IS NO
ONE SHOWING UP IS THERE ANYONE
WISHING TO ADDRESS US IN
OPPOSITION. HOW FOR OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO IN GIVING UP SIR THANK
YOU. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
FILE THANK YOU KNOW FILE THIS
BILL GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL.
AND MOVING ON TO MISS WEBER.
I'LL BE HAVE A DOCTOR WEBER-
THIS IS A BILL TO PREVENT-
PROHIBIT A PARTY FROM USING A
PEREMPTORY CHALLENGE TO REMOVE
A PERSPECTIVE JUROR FOR-
IMPLICIT BIAS REASONS RELATED
TO RACE ETHNICITY GENDER GENDER
IDENTITY SEXUAL ORIENTATION
NATURAL ORIGIN OR RELIGIOUS
AFFILIATION WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY BELL A SECOND BY
MISTER CALDERON. ON ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTY SEVENTY DOES ANYONE
WISH TO SERVE SPEAK IN SUPPORT
HERE IN THE GALLERY. SEEING NO
ONE MOVING TO THE PHONES NICK
DO YOU HAVE FOLKS IN THE QUEUE
FOR ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
SEVENTY. AND SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE FIVE ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MARCO GEORGE
AND I HAVE TO THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. EXCEPT LINE
FOR TWO SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
POOR TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. IT'S NOT HERE HERNANDEZ
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
WE ARE THE SPONSORS OF. AB
THIRTY SEVENTY WHICH UPDATES
CULT LAW TO BETTER IDENTIFY AND
REMEDY RACIAL BIAS JERRY
STILLER WE ARE FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THE MINISTER. THIS IS NATASHA
MINSKER IN STRONG SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF ALL THE FOLLOWING
ORGANIZATIONS THE ALLIANCE FOR
BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR THE ANTI
DEFAMATION LEAGUE ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE-
BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
EQUAL JUSTICE USA THE EIGHTH
AMENDMENT PROJECT INITIATE
CHAPTER WE'RE GOING OFFICE FOR
PUBLIC POLICY NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE AND CALIFORNIANS FOR
SAFETY INJECTORS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK. I
WILL SERVE LINE THREE SIX SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MIKE A
DOCTOR OFF ON BEHALF OF THE
ACLU OF CALIFORNIA AND STRONG
SUPPORT. AND WE HAVE LINE
TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
KEVIN TIBBLES A CURATED
CALIFORNIA ACT AMERICAN. GRILL
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
AND NEXT WE HAVE LINE FOR THREE
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. FOUR
THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HEY MAN I GOT A LOOK WE'RE
GOING. I'M WANTING TO SPEAK ON
ADDED ON AB OR AC EIGHT SORRY
SORRY THIS IS A LONG TIME. FOUR
THREE ZERO. OR THIRTY MINUTES.
HI THIS IS YOUR THE TO CLOVER
CALLING FROM OAKLAND CALIFORNIA
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
EIGHT FIVE. SORRY ONCE AGAIN
JUST FOR EVERYONE'S KNOWLEDGE
WE'RE NOT ADDRESSING A CA FIVE
AT THIS TIME WE ARE WORKING ON
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY SEVENTY IF
YOU WISH TO REGISTER YOUR
OPPOSITION NOW IS YOUR TIME.
NICK DO YOU HAVE ANY DO FOR.
THAT BILL. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
KNOWN FOR THEIR AND KILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WOULD YOU LIKE TO A-
ADDRESSES WITH A FILE. I KNOW
FILE THANK YOU WE HAVE NO FILE.
OKAY MOVING ALONG THAT GETS OUT
ON A B. ROLL CALL AND WISH YOU
HAD SOMETHING ELSE YOU WANT TO
ADD FOR YOUR CLOTHES NOT AT ALL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE GONNA
GO OUT TO MISTER PORTANTINO'S-
A BILL THAT'S SB. FOUR ONE
SEVEN. THANK YOU. ANNA THIS
BILL IS OF COURSE THE VICTIMS
COMPENSATION BOARD CLAIMS BILL
THAT WERE REQUIRED- AND
APPROPRIATIONS TO PASS I
NORMALLY JUST ASK AND I'M
WILLING TO TAKE A MORE. THAN ON
THIS BUT I WOULD COMMANDED. THE
TIME GIVE IT HAPPENING IN OUR
COUNTRY THIS IS THE
COMPENSATION THAT WE PAY
INDIVIDUALS FOR BEING A RONI
SLEE CONVICTED OR IMPRISONED IN
CALIFORNIA IT IS SEVEN- LIVES
WHOSE. LIVES WERE CHANGED
BECAUSE OF A RUN ITS
CONVICTIONS WE ARE PAYING OUT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN IT
NEEDS SOME LIGHT READING- IT'S
ALWAYS A- GOOD ONE SO WITH THAT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK. ABOUT SO WE
HAD IN MOTION BY MISTER
CALDERON AND A SECOND BY MISS
KOREA. ON THIS DOES ANYONE WISH
TO ADDRESS- THE COMMITTEE ON
THIS BILL HERE IN THE GALLERY
SB FOUR SEVENTY THIS WOULD BE
SB FOUR ONE SEVEN HOW ABOUT
FROM THE PHONES. YOUR AND
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE NO IN QUEUING UP
ANY OPPOSITION. WE'RE ON SB.
FOUR ONE SEVEN. IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. MR
KERRY OF KNOWING QUEUING UP
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
IT WOULD YOU LIKE TO COMMENT ON
IS THE CHAIR I DIDN'T THINK SO
YES REPORTER THE PLEASURE. WE
DO HAVE A FILE AND ACTUALLY IN
SUPPORT OF THE MATTER THANK YOU.
OKAY THIS BILL I GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL WITH MISTER ALI NOT
VOTING. MANAGER THAT SCORE ON
THAT ONE. IT'S BACK TO YOU. WE
HAVE THANK YOU OUT WHAT WE'RE
GONNA DO NOW THAT THAT
CONCLUDES OUR REGULAR ORDER OF
BUSINESS EVERY SINGLE BILL HAS
BEEN DEALT WITH EITHER. MR
GABRIEL DID I'M SKIP YOU OWE NO
I'M SORRY YOU JUST STAND UP WE
DID COMEY SCARE THERE I THROUGH
EVERY BILL EVERY BILL HAS BEEN
VOTED ON. WAS THAT WERE ON IN
CENTER VOTE ON TODAY WILL GO TO
THE FLOOR THE BILLS THAT WERE
MADE TO THE SUSPENSE CALENDAR
WILL BE VOTED ON TOMORROW. NOW
WHAT WE HAVE LEFT IS PUBLIC
COMMENT THE WAY PUBLIC COMMENT
WILL WORK IS YOU CAN SAY YOUR
NAME. YOUR ORGANIZATION IN YOUR
POSITION AND WHAT BILL YOUR THE
POSITION IS ON BEFORE WE GO TO
THAT OF AN ASK HOW MANY PEOPLE
IN THE QUEUE BECAUSE OF ITS TOO
MANY PEPLE WERE YOU TO TAKE A
SMALL BREAK BEFORE- I'M SO.
SORRY MISTER NECK HOW MANY
PEOPLE WE HAVE ONE IN FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT HOW MAY PEOPLE
LEFT IN THE QUEUE. ARE WE
CURRENTLY HAVE- A DOZEN FOLKS
IN Q. AND CLIMBING SO VERY
SLOWLY. LOOKS LIKE FOURTEEN NOW.
FOURTEEN AND CLIMBING WE'RE
GOING TO STOP TAKING ADDITIONAL
COLORS THE TWENTY FOUR GONNA
START TAKING ADDITIONAL CALLERS
NOW WILL GO HEAD TO THE QUEUE-
PEOPLE CAN IT YOU'RE NOT
SPEAKING ON THE BILL YOU'RE
SIMPLY SAYING THE BILL NUMBER
YOUR NAME AND THE POSITION AND
WE'RE NOT ACCEPTING ANYMORE
PUBLIC COMMENT AFTER THE THESE
FOURTEEN. THANK YOU. GIVE WILL
FIRST GO TO LINE ONE ONE FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS GREGORY KRAMER ON
BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHT
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF- THE
FOLLOWING. SUSPEND MEASURES.
BEAR WITH ME HERE WE HAVE
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN FORTY
SEVEN KALRA AB TWENTY SIXTY
FOUR PATTERSON AB TWENTY ONE
TWELVE RAMOS AB TWENTY TWO
THIRTEEN LIMON B TWENTY TWO
SEVEN ONE GABRIEL. AB. TWENTY
THREE TWENTY NINE TWO. AB
TWENTY FOUR SIXTEEN GABRIEL AB
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY ONE QUIRK AB
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY THREE POWER
QUE ON AB TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY
CERVANTES AB THIRTY TWO TWENTY
EIGHT BONTA SB THIRTY TWO TWO
NINE TWO AB THIRTY THREE
HUNDRED SANTIAGO. AND EIGHTY
EIGHT FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FIND FOUR THREE THREE A LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS JOHN THE
CLEARLY ON THE NINETEEN NINETY
SEVEN I WAS BORN IN NINETEEN
NINETY SEVEN I'M A COLLEGE
GRADUATE AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ORDER
ONLINE FOUR ONE SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CAN YOU MARTIN ON BEHALF
OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF BOTH AB TWO TO THREE
SIX AND EIGHTEEN TWENTY TO
EIGHTEEN THANK YOU. THE LINE
ONE FOUR ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHEN MEMBERS
NICKEL IN ECONOMIC GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS FOR SAN DIEGO GAS AND
ELECTRIC IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
ZERO SEVEN SIX BY MISTER
BIGELOW AB TWO TWO ONE THREE BY
MCMAHONS A. B. THREE ZERO SEVEN
FOUR BYE MISTREATMENT A. B.
THREE ONE SIX. FOR BY MID
FRIEDMAN AND AN OPPOSITION TO
A. B. THREE GIVE ME A BE TWO
ONE SEVEN EIGHT BY MAJORITY IN
THANK YOU. NOW LINE THIRTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS LEARN WHAT
MAC OR IN LOS ANGELES NOT
AFFILIATED WITH ANY
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE THE ACLU
UNDER THE CONCERNED MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC I'M REGISTERING MY
OPPOSITION SPENT BELL AB TWO
TWO SIX ONE THANK YOU. A LINE
FOUR ZERO EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ZERO EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MOVING ON WHAT I HAVE A
SEVEN. SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. RIGHT YES- MY NAME IS
MADELINE GRIERSON SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE LATINO ROUNDTABLE
REGARDING EIGHT BE EIGHTEEN
FIFTY AN AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY
SEVEN WE GIVE IT. LIMITED
SUPPORT IS THAT APPROVED WITH
OVER EIGHTY FIVE BUT IT STILL
HURTS UNDOCUMENTED EIGHTEEN
HOLDERS. AND INDEPENDENT.
CONTRACTOR PROFESSIONALS
ESPECIALLY INTERPRETERS. IN A
LINE ONE ONE SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE ONE SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
ALEX TOWARDS WITH STRATEGIES
THREE SIXTY ON BEHALF OF UP FOR
GROWTH ACTION CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF THE FOLLOWING
MEASURES AB TWENTY THREE FORTY
FIVE DOLLARS WE ARE HAPPY CO
SPONSOR AB THIRTY ONE FIFTY
FIVE RIVER. AND AB THIRTY ONE
OH SEVEN ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
VETERANS SERVICE AGENCY IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY THREE
HUNDRED THANK IAGO THANK YOU SO
MUCH. GOING OUT THE LINE FOR
ONE THREE THE LINE IS OPEN. ALL
APATHY PROTEST AND OUT OF THE
SOUTHEAST MOMENT THAT FACT MY
COUNT THE BY. AND WE ARE NOW TO
LINE THREE EIGHT NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS ABBY
TRAINING ON THE HALF OF THE BAY
AREA COUNCIL AND I'M CALLING IT
TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT. FOR
EIGHTY THREE ONE SEVEN BLOOM.
AB THIRTY TO THIRTY NINE
FRIEDMAN AB TWENTY THREE FORTY
FIVE GONZALEZ. AB THIRTY ONE
FIFTY FIVE. AND EIGHTY EIGHTEEN
FIFTY ONE WAY. THANK YOU YOU
KNOW NOT TO LINE ONE FOR ONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON SURE GETS ALL
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS MAYBE
RODRIGUEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
EDUCATION TRUST WATCHED IN
STRONG SUPPORT THE FALTERING
SUSPENSE FILE PHOTO. AB TWENTY
NINETEEN HOLDEN AB THAT. MEDINA
EIGHTEEN THIRTY WHAT WE'RE AND
AC EIGHT FIVE WATER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU GOING OUT TO LINE TWO
ONE SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR NUMBER SO CAN
MATTER NOT LIKE HAVE PUBLICAFFAIRS CALLING ON BEHALF OF
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA AGAIN BE IN A THREE
PIECE COALITION ON THE
FOLLOWING BILLS. AB THIRTY
FORTY TWO EIGHTEEN THIRTY ONE
AND SEVEN AND BLOOM AB THIRTY
ONE FIFTY FIVE THREE THAT AB
TWENTY FIFTY EIGHT. GABRIEL AB
TWENTY THREE FORTY FIVE DOLLARS
AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY THREE
PAYING. EIGHTEEN THIRTY THREE
HUNDRED SANTIAGO AND AB TWENTY
FIVE EIGHTY EGGMAN THANK YOU.
NEXT WITH A LINE THREE EIGHT
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ZACHARY
SMITH THE SOLE PROPRIETOR WITH
THE MISINTERPRETING I'M CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY
F. AMENDED TO EXPLICITLY
INCLUDE SIGN LANGUAGE
INTERPRETERS AND REAL TIME
CAPTIONING UNDER THE
PROFESSIONAL. SERVICE EXEMPTION
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. AN
EXTRA LINE FOR TWO EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ANDY HUANG FROM SAN FRANCISCO
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHT EIGHT FIVE THANK YOU SO
MUCH STE. THANK YOU AND FINALLY
WE WILL GO TO LINE FOUR ZERO
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN COULD
UPLOAD FRIDAY MAY EXTRA LONG
AND STRUGGLING AS- BECAUSE A
KID. EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR THAT IS OUR FORTY NINE.
ALL FORTY ARE ALL OF OUR LINES
ARE DONE WITH THAT HIGH I
APOLOGIZE TO THE PEOPLE IN THE
GALLERY THAT I DIDN'T SEE- THEY
CAN NOW REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION TO A BILL JUST
COME UP TO THE MICROPHONE AND-
STATE YOUR NAME- THE BUSINESS.
SESSION AND THE BILL. SURE GOOD
MORNING- MY NAME IS FRANK SHE
I'M A CO FOUNDER OF SAN DIEGO
ASIAN AMERICANS FOR QUALITY I
SPEAK FOR TENS OF THOUSANDS IN
ADITION TO A SEE FIVE I DROVE
UP FROM SAN DIEGO LAST NIGHT
AND SHOW OUR SHOW YOU OUR
PASSION AND THE PETITION
LETTERS WE HAVE COLLECTED MORE
THAN SIXTEEN HUNDRED OFF FROM-OUR PEOPLE. AND THE ACA FIVE
YEARS FIRST RACES SIR IT WILL
COST THE STATE SIR SIR SO YOU
BECAUSE IT WASN'T HEARD TODAY
THIS IS TO PUBLIC COMMENT WHICH
MEANS YOU CAN ONLY- SHARE YOUR
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION WHAT YOU
JUST DID SO I THINK HERE YOU
CAN LEAVE US IF YOU WANT TO
LEAVE AT SOMETHING YOU CAN
LEAVE IT WITH THAT SERGEANTS
AND LOOK AT. THANK YOU USER WAS
THERE MORE PERSON UP THERE.
THANK YOU TIMES AND ALSO THEN I
REPRESENT A SILICON VALLEY
CHINESE ASSOCIATION I TO SPEAK
FOR SAW THAN TO OPPOSE ACA
FIVE. A HASN'T BEEN DONE ANY
FINANCIAL ANALYSIS YET AND WILL
COST THANK YOU THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. ALL RIGHT THAT CONCLUDES
PEOPLE HERE TO SPEAK. AND
PUBLIC COMMENT. NECK ARE YOU
STILL THERE. THURMOND ENTER
THERE'S NOBODY LEFT ON THE
PHONES CORRECT WERE DONE NOW.
WE DO HAVE- MULTIPLE LINES- IF
YOU WANTED TO CONTINUE I JUST
AT THE FIRST FOURTEEN WE ARE UP
TO- FORTY NINE TO GET UP. FORTY
MORE LINES. CORRECT IS THERE A
WAY OKAY THAT'S FINE WE'RE
GOING TO ALLOW THAT- WILL GO
AHEAD AND TAKE THOSE FORTY
LINES BUT- THEN WE'RE CLOSING
OUT PUBLIC COMMENT BECAUSE WE
HAVE GIVEN PEOPLE QUITE AN
OPPORTUNE GET ON THE PHONES AT
THIS POINT SO TAKEN AWAY NECK
THANK YOU. THE STATE WILL GO TO
LINE TWO SIX SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS LACI
EASTERN FULL PROPRIETOR AT
EASTON INTERPRETING AND I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF. AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY IT AMENDED TO
EXPLICITLY INCLUDE SIGN
LANGUAGE INTERPRETERS IN REAL
TIME CATIONING UNDER THE
PROFESSIONAL SERVICE EXEMPTION
THANK YOU. YOUR NEXT WILL GO TO
LINE FOR TWO TO ONE MOMENT.
MEMBERS ARE MANY PARTS ON THE
STRUGGLING WITH THE UC STUDENT
ASSOCIATION ARE SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF THE FOLLOWING
MEASURES AB NINETEEN THIRTY
MEDINA AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY TWO
MCCARTY AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTEEN
GABRIEL AB TWENTY NINE
SEVENTEEN THE MALL. SB THIRTY
NINETY WE'VE AND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF A C. THANK YOU.
JOINT WILL GO TO LINE THREE
SEVEN THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH. THREE SEVEN THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MOVING ALONG WITH
A LINE TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THE MOVE ALONG- WE HAVE
LINE THREE ONE NINE. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON- THIS IS
TONY PAN FROM THE ALREADY CLOUT
STRONGLY OPPOSE IS HE A FIVE.
Q. AND- WE'LL GO NEXT TO LINE.
FOUR ZERO FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS NICOLE THIRSTY
FROM LAFAYETTE CALIFORNIA
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY FIVE AS WELL AS WITH
THIS THIRTY NINETY YOU. THANK
YOU AND- NEXT WE WILL GO TO
LINE. APOLOGIZE FOR THE DELAY
WERE GOING TO LINE FIFTY FIVE
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON JUDY HYMAN ON BEHALF
OF THE ANTI DEFAMATION LEAGUE
OR A. B. L. AND THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY RELATIONS COUNCIL OF
THE SACRAMENTO REGION. IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ACA FIVE
THANK YOU. YOU WILL MOVE
FORWARD TO NINE THREE FOUR ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FOR ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MOVING FORWARD WE
WILL GO TO MINE TWO FIVE THREE.
TWO FIVE THREE AIRLINES OPEN.
HELLO GEN NUMBER I'M QUICKLY
FROM PATENTS AND RATHER THAN
THESE HIGH VALUE AGING
ASSOCIATION WE HAD TO SIT DOWN
IN THE PUBLIC TO INTO A FIVE
THANK YOU. GIVE IT WILL GO NEXT
TO LINE ONE THREE THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SO THAT THE ISSUE
FROM PAPA THIRTY I'M CALLING TO
OPPOSE THE CA FIVE THANK YOU.
KILL WILL MOVE FORWARD TO LINE
FOR THREE FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I THIS IS- JOHN CANDY'S
AMERICAN UC BERKELEY GRADUATE I
CALLED IN TO EXPRESS MY
STRONGLY SUPPORT FOR A CA FIVE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE GOING
OUT TO LINE FOR FOUR ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS SYLVIA SO THE SHOCK
ON BEHALF OF THE FOLLOWING
ORGANIZATIONS THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES THE CITY OF SANTA
MNICA AND THE SAN FRANCISCO
MUNICIPAL TRANSPORTATION
ASSOCIATION ALL IN OPPOSITION
TO A. B. THREE ONE ONE SIX ALSO
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY AT THE- NATION I'M-
BUYING IN SUPPORT OF ACA FIVE.
WEBER ERICA SPONSORED THING YOU.
DO WE GO NOW TO LINE TWO EIGHT
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS SEVEN MIL I AM FROM.
CALIFORNIA HAS STRONGLY OPPOSED
THE STATE. THANK. THANK YOU AND
GOING TO LINE FOUR ZERO EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ME YES GO
AHEAD OKAY SORRY- THIS IS NOT
THE BANK CALLING IN ON THE HAVE
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
TRYING TO THE LAN LINE
ASSOCIATION- AT THE UC BERKELEY
PHD DEGREE HOLDER I AND
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY EIGHT
FIVE. THANK YOU. Q. AND WE'LL
GO NOW TO LINE ONE FIVE FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES ON HOW ARE
AND I READ IT THANK. IN FRONT
OF THE COMPUTER THANK WE MAKE
ALL RIGHT THE AND I DON'T KNOW
WHOLE OF THE EIGHT ARE YOU SO
I'M- CAN KNOWN AS ROUTINE ARE
NOW ALREADY. THERE YOU OF THIS
IS JUST JUST YOUR NAME THE BILL
IN YOUR POSITION PLAY. MOVING
FOR TO LINE FOR THREE YEARS IS
OPEN. YEAH MY IS JIM JACK'S
FROM EQUAL JUSTICE. CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT AND EIGHTY EIGHT
I THANK YOU. AND NEXT DOOR TO
LINE THREE NINE ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE DOW I REQUEST I
REPEAT SANT'AGATA MAKING YOU
COLLISION ASSOCIATION P. HOP
ALL MY OUTGOING IRISH AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE FEET EIGHTY
FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE GO
NOW TO LINE THREE NINE ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OUR DATA
CARREON FROM STUDENTS FALL FOR
A MISSION I'M IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO A SEE A FIVE
THANK YOU. AND NEXT WE WILL GO
TO LINE THREE NINE SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. KEEP THE CITY FROM
THE EQUAL JUSTICE SOCIETY IN
OAKLAND. CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FIVE. AND
NEXT IS LINE ONE ONE SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MA'AM
SHERMAN MEMBERS THIS IS ROYCE
SPEAKING BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION GOVERNOR'S A
CALIFORNIA AND THE NRA WE ARE
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY SEVEN. AND
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY TWO THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY. AND
NEXT WE GOT A LINE. THREE SIX
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS PAMELA
GIVE REPRESENTING THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
FOLLOWING BILL EIGHTY EIGHTEEN
THIRTY FIVE WEBER AB TWO ZERO
ONE NINE HOLDEN AB EIGHTEEN
FORTY FIVE THREE OF US THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND TAKE CARE.
NEXT WE GO TO LINE TWO SEVEN
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS CHRIS STONE THOUGH I'M
THE PRESIDENT OF SILICON VALLEY
CHINESE THE CREATION AND I
REPRESENT THOUSAND WE ARE IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY
EIGHT FIVE THANK YOU. IN OUR
NEXT LINE IS FOUR TWO FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ANGELES AREA AND I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF A CA FIVE
THANK YOU. NEXT WILL BE LINE
THREE TWO ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS THE
LEADING BRAND NOW I PRESENT
HE'LL BE FOUNDATION IN ON YOU
COUNTY I STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHT
EIGHT FIVE IS THE HOME FACING
COMMUNITY RIGHT BACK THANK YOU.
NEXT WILL THAT ALIGN TWO SIX
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
MORNING SO ON MY NAME IS GONE
HE AND I'M CALLING FROM SILICON
VALLEY IS HERE FIVE IS A
JOURNEY OF THE BILL BEFORE ME
MAJORITY AGAINST THE HIVE BUT
WE BY THE MINORITY. WE WILL
LEAVE RIGHT I WANT TO REMIND
PEOPLE. YOU KNOW. IF I WHERE I
TAKE OR ON TAKING YOUR- THE
BILL. IN YOUR POSITION I'M
SORRY. HERE WE GO TO LINE THREE
NINE SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TRACKING AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THIS IS A RAINY IN MEAN GIRLS
GOC FOUNDATION I'M STRONGLY
OPPOSED DALE. EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU. THANK NEXT WITH A LINE FOR
THREE SEVEN. HI MY NAME IS
NATALIE RECALL LAW I'M A
RESIDENT OF SOUTH SAN FRANCISCO
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT ACA FIVE.
THANK YOU WE GO NOW TO LINE FOR
THREE ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THAT
IS AFTERNOON OUR MEMBERS THAT
MADAM CHAIR MY NAME IS HOW YOU
SHOULD BROWN I AM THE CHAIR OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY
AFRICAN AMERICAN CAUCUS. IN ALL
HOLD STATEWIDE NUMBER OF THE
WAFFLE IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
EIGHT FIVE. THANK YOU GOING OUT
TO LINE THREE ZERO TWO. YOUR
LINES OPEN YEAH SO IT HI HOW
YOU CAN. OF EQUAL EDUCATION
ASSOCIATION FOR MORE. SB NATION
EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CAN ACTUALLY GO TO
LINE FOR FIVE ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS TRACY QUAN
FROM SECAM FROM AN ORDER FROM
THE SENATE BILL I STRONGLY
OPPOSED RIDGE'S EIGHTY EIGHT
FIVE THANK YOU. NEXT WE ALIGN
TWO TWO FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS CHARLES FROM A CHEAP
AND PROTECT CAP WE ALL I
STRONGLY ATKINS HILL. EIGHT
FIVE. THANK YOU AND AS WE LOST
A LINE WILL AND THAT LINE FOR
FIVE THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FIVE THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
UP IN THE NEW YES GO AHEAD OF
THE COLLECTOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MY NAME IS NICOLE FROM ONE OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICT WHAT'S COMING
OPPOSE AC A FIVE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR THAT WILL COMPLETE
OUR FORTY LINES. ARE. YES WE-
WE ARE AT THIRTY SEVEN LINES
AND KILL. I'LL TAKE THOSE THAT
HE SEVEN OF AT SOME POINT WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO BREAK FOR
LUNCH AND SO THIS IS AB. I HATE
TO CUT ANYONE OFF LET'S JUST
TAKE THOSE THIRTY SEVEN I IT.
IN THE NEXT FEW MINUTES IF YOU
DON'T GET ON AND WE CAN'T WE
CAN'T DO THIS ALL DAY AND
FORTUNATELY- PEOPLE COMING ON
LATE SO LET'S TAKE THOSE THIRTY
SEVEN AND THEN. SEE WHERE WE
ARE THANK YOU. ALRIGHT WE WILL
START WITH MINE FIFTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALL RIGHT WITH
YOU FEEL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
GROCERS ASSOCIATION. I THINK
YOU END UP IN OPPOSITION TO THE
FOLLOWING BILL- EIGHTY NINETEEN
FORTY SEVEN KALRA TV THIRTY TWO
SIXTEEN KALRA. AB TWO NINE NINE
NINE- LOW AB THIRTY FIFTY SIX
DOLLARS AND EIGHTY THIRTY
THIRTY FIVE DOLLARS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU YOU GO TO LINE THREE
SEVEN NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SEVEN NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
LIVING ON WILL GO TO LINE FOR
THREE FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH I MEAN CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FIVE THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR DODD. AND NEXT
WE'LL GO TO ONE FOUR FOUR SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FOR FOUR SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IT IS FENCED
YARD FROM THE ORANGE CLAP AND
DAY STRONGLY- PUT OPPOSE EIGHTY
FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE
GOT TO LINE TO ELEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD TWO ONE ONE. ONE ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS SALLY
I'M CALLING TO STRONGLY OPPOSED.
POLITICS FOR THE DELAY OF THEIR
SYSTEMS CATCH UP HERE ARE WE
DEADLINE FOR SIX SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. REMEMBER STILL DEAL FOR
OUR IN BEHALF FACEBOOK IN
SUPPORT OF THE FOLLOWING BILLS
AB. TWENTY THREE FORTY FIVE
GONZALEZ AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
EIGHT. AB THIRTY FORTY CHU AT
THIRTY ONE OH SEVEN BLOOM AND
EIGHTEEN THIRTY ONE FIFTY FIVE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WE
HAVE LINE THREE THREE TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
BRENDA GOAL FROM BAY AREA I'M
CALLING TO STRONGLY OPPOSE
EIGHTY EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU.
AND OUR NEXT LINE IS FOUR FIVE
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS THE NET ONE I'M CALLING
FROM- READY FOR AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT WILL GO TO LINE FOR
SIX FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS ON ABOUT THE ARE HERE
I'M CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT
ACA FIVE AND WITH EQUAL TO.
EIGHTY IN OAKLAND. NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE FOR FIVE SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS SLOWLY BEING FROM SILICON
VALLEY CHINESE ASSOCIATION
FOUNDATION I'M CALLING IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO A CA FIVE
THANK YOU. AND NEXT WE GO TO
LINE TWO THREE TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS KING NOW
COME FROM STATE AREA. I'M
STRONGLY OPPOSE. EIGHT EIGHT
FIVE. AND ACTUALLY GO TO LINE
FOR FOUR EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THAT THE TONY ONE ALMOST
ON A BILL I REPRESENT THE- FIVE
SEVEN. SIX PEOPLE- HUNDRED
SEVEN SEVENTY SIX THE PEOPLE
YES I KNOW WE ARE ONLY OPPOSED
TO ANYTHING A FIVE BILL. IS
RECEIVED AND TO EAT IT TO BEAT
IT ACROSS THE CONTINENT THE
CALIFORNIA BACK OR- THANK YOU
NEXT WILL GO TO LINE FOR SEVEN
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
CHIRLA MY NAME IS MICHAEL
FAMILY I AM REPRESENTING THE
NATIONAL SHOOTING SPORTS
FOUNDATION WE ARE IN OPPOSITION
AB TWO EIGHT FOUR SEVEN AM A-
TWO THREE SIX. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WERE GOING OUT TO LINE ONE
TWO NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON COREY MET ON BEHALF
OF THE BAY AREA HOUSING AT THE
COULD BE COALITION IN THE COURT
OF THE FOLLOWING BILL. AB TWO
THREE FOUR FIVE DOLLARS AB
THREE ONE FIVE FIVE RIVAS. AB
THREE TWO SEVEN NINE FRIEDMAN
THANK YOU. AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE TWO SIX ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. TWO SIX CAROLINA GOV YEP
BUT YEAH. YES MY NAME IS THIS
YOUR LAN REPRESENTING THOUSAND
TO HEAR IN PARALLEL STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WILL
GO TO LINE FOR EIGHT TO PLEASE
GO AHEAD WONDERFUL MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF ACA FIVE FROM TARZANA
CALIFORNIA MY NAME IS AMY
REPRESENTATION MATTERS WE WILL
CáC THANK YOU. AND NEXT WE GO
TO LINE FOUR EIGHT FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. RIGHT FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THE REMOTE YES UTILITY
LINES OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
SALINAS YOU ARE REPRESENTED
FACT THAT THE ON THE NIGHT
VISION AND THOUSAND OF OUR
MEMBERS A FEW OF EIGHT EIGHT
FIVE VIEW WE ALL AMERICAN ONE
I'M GOD THREE DO NOT SUPPORT
THE- THANK YOU JUST JUST YOUR
NAME N. ORGANIZATION IF YOU
HAVE ONE AND POSITION ON THE
BILL PLEASE. YES MY NAME IS
TINA SHOOT I WOULD BE SENT BACK
CAN MAKE YOU GET ALL THE LIES
ATION. THANK YOU. WE GOT OUT TO
LINE FOR SEVEN SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HEY THIS IS. FEDERAL
LINE IS OPEN. POLITICIAN
ADELINE STUCK HERE. WHAT IS FOR
THE DELAY WE WILL GO NEXT TO
LINE FOR SEVEN ONE. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS DENNIS
FROM ORANGE COUNTY I'M CALLING
IN OPPOSITION OF ACA FIVE IN
OPPOSITION. AB. TWO EIGHT FOUR
SEVEN. THANK YOUR NEXT DEADLINE
FOUR EIGHT SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BOB THE GO OUT YOU I'M A
BOARD MEMBER ALL BOX SEVENTY
EIGHT OF THE VISION I'M
STRONGLY OPPOSED. TO EIGHTY
EIGHT FIVE. THANK YOU NEXT WE
GO TO LINE FOUR EIGHT THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
EDDIE CONFIGURE I'M CALLING
FROM SAN LEANDRO CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE CA FIVE.
AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE FOR
FIVE EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS BOB MAIL REPRESENTING
FEELS TED IN COMPANY AN ORANGE
COUNTY BUSINESS STRONGLY
SUPPORTIVE OF CALIFORNIA U. M.
B. AND STRONG SUPPORT OF A. B.
TWO THREE FOUR FIVE THE CHAIRS
BILL. AB THREE ZERO FOUR ZERO
AB THREE ONE ZERO SEVEN AND AB
THREE ONE FIVE FIVE THANK YOU.
IN OUR NEXT LINE WILL BE LINE
FOR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
RICK WYSOCKI WITH WESTERN
MANUFACTURED HOUSING
COMMUNITIES ASSOCIATION IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO A. B. TWO
SEVEN EIGHT TWO STONE THANK YOU.
OUR NEXT LINE IS LINE FOR THREE
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. FOUR
THREE ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MOVING ON ON THE LINE FOR EIGHT
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. FOR EIGHT
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS RUNNING
PROJECT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION- CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF THE FOLLOWING MEASURES AB.
TWENTY NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO ONE
SIX FOUR EIGHTY TWO ONE SEVEN
EIGHT. AB TWO FOUR TO ONE AND
EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE THANK YOU.
OUR NEXT LINE OF LINE FOUR NINE
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELL
MAYBE RECORDED ON THE RECORD OF
FROM THE CALIFORNIA I'M NOT TO
FIND TO THE OFFER THIS. IF THE
FIVE. THANK YOU YOU NEXT LINE
THREE TO THE- PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO AND BECKY YEN
REPRESENTING ASIAN AMERICAN
FROM RIVERSIDE. WE ARE STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO DC EIGHT FIVE THANK
YOU. JOHN I FINALLY NINE FOUR
NINE ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. PARTY
TO FRANK WILL CONFRONT THE
HOTEL CALIFORNIA- ACCORDING TO
EXPRESS THE STRONGER YOU A
QUOTE WITH EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE IN
YOUR. OUR NEXT LINE WILL BE
LINE THREE SEVEN SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WHAT'S ONE TALKING
ONE PHONING OUT LIMóN STRONG
OR CLOTHING. THE EIGHTY FIVE
THANK YOU. Q. AND THEN OUR NEXT
LINE IS GOING TO BE LINE FOR
THREE SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MOPPING MORE THREE SIGNATURE
LINE IS OPEN. FORMER BACK HERE
NO ONE ON WILL GO TO FOUR SEVEN
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS NOT A
SCINTILLA POLITICAL SOLUTIONS
ON BEHALF OF THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT
OF AB THREE ONE ONE EIGHT BONTA
THANK YOU. OUR NEXT LINE OF THE
LINE THREE NINE THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS JOSH
TERM FROM SLOPPY AT I'D LIKE TO
VOICE MY STRONG OPPOSITION. TO
EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE. NEXT LINE IS
LINE FOUR EIGHT ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. EIGHT ZERO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THING ON WE GOT A LINE
FOUR NINE NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH MY NAME IS KONG CAN I AM A
CANDIDATE FOR A LOT. I'M THE
ONLY A POLL EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE.
THANK YOU. WERE GOING OUT TO
LINE TWO FIVE SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OUT IT MIGHT YES YOUR
LINE IS OPEN OKAY YEAH THIS IS
MICHELLE CAME CALLING FROM ARE
AND WEAKER THAN NINETY COUNTY
CHINESE LADY QUIRK AND WE ARE
STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHTY EIGHT
FIVE THANK YOU. WE HAVE LINE
FIVE ZERO EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS JESSICA GOVERNOR
THE IDEA I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE ORGANIZATION PROTECTION
OF EDUCATIONAL RIGHT TO KIDS
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSED
CRISTINA GARCIA IS BILL AB TWO
NINE NINE ZERO THANK YOU SO
MUCH. ONE FOUR SIX FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. A THIS IS A
MEDICAL THAT REPRESENTING EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY FALL DOWN MONSTER
MAY GOWHERE DO YOU STRONG
OPPOSITION TO RESIST EIGHTY
FIVE EIGHT EIGHT FIVE BI<c.cyan></c>
BECAUSE IT'S ABOUT PEOPLE USED
AS YOUR PEOPLE THANK YOU. WE
GOT OUT NINE FIVE ZERO NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
THAT IT'S AND FOR OUR LINE
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY OPPOSE. A
FIVE THANK YOU. NOW LINE FIVE
ONE FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MOVING
ON WE ALIGN THREE NINE SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THREE NINE SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MOVING ON
WITH A LINE FIVE ONE THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS IS A
JUDGE ON HIM FOR MONTHS ON A
BILL- HERE I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
EIGHT EIGHT FIVE THANKS. THANK
YOU OUR NEXT LINE IS LINE ONE
EIGHT NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS BABY AND WE TRY WALL
FROM SOLVE THE MONTH THAT
CALIFORNIA AND MINING IS AND I
AM IN STRONG OPPOSITION OUT AB
ONE- ONE EIGHT FIVE ZERO- ALL
THAT SAYS ARE REQUIRED FOR ON
THE ON EXTENSION PORTS ARE
BUYING PROFESSIONAL
INTERPRETERS. AND NOW IT CUTS
OUR ABILITY TO PRACTICE BY. WE
GOT A LINE FIVE ZERO THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
THE CALLING FROM FROM SAN
FRANCISCO AND I'M A PART OF A
COALITION OF OVER TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY ORGANIZATIONS AND
COMMUNITY LEADERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ACA FIVE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU WE HAVE
LINE FIVE ONE SEVEN. HI MY NAME
IS THINKING I'M A PARENT FROM
MONTANA WITH DISTRICT I'M
CALLING TO STRONGLY OPPOSE IT'S
A FACT THANK YOU. THANK YOU. Q.
AND THEN THE OUR FINAL LINE
WILL BE LINE FIVE ZERO SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
YEAH YEAH I'M CALLING FROM
CAPISTRANO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT I STRONGLY OPPOSE
EIGHTY FIVE. Q. THANK YOU
MANAGER PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK
YOU I'M. NICK ARE THERE STILL
PEOPLE TRYING TO GET ON. BUT WE
DID GET SOME- ADDITIONAL IT
LOOKS LIKE ABOUT FIFTEEN MIND
SET OF- CONTINUE TO SHOW UP ARE
YOU OKAY DO YOU NEED TO TAKE A
BREAK. ARE YOU ASKING ME- NO NO
WE'RE FINE. OKAY THEN LET'S GO
AHEAD AND TAKE THE FINAL
FIFTEEN. PLEASE LET ME KNOW IF
YOU NEED A BREAK. DO WE GO TO
LINE TWO ONE ONE- PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
UNDERSTAND ME I'M COMING I
REGARD AND IN SEEING. IT
WRITTEN IN AN IDEA OF THE NO
EIGHT EIGHT FIVE PETITION WE'VE
GOT MORE THAN FORTY THOUSAND
SIGNATURES WE ARE. STRONG OUR
NATION TOOK A SAY A FIVE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY. ARE NOT LINE OF
LINE THREE NINE SIX- EXCUSE ME
THREE SIX SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SIX SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE FIVE ONE
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS FINGER
CEELO ON BEHALF OF FOR NEW
FINANCIAL. IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWO FIVE ZERO ONE THE MOMENT
ALONG WITH A COALITION OF OTHER
STATES PROVIDERS. THANK YOU
NEXT WE WILL GO TO LINE FOUR
ONE FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. FOUR
ONE FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MOVING ON WE GO TO LINE FIVE
TWO ONE FIVE TWO ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS CHAU AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSED RAISE A FIVE.
THANK YOU OUR NEXT LINE WILL BE
LINE FIVE ZERO SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ZERO SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN LOOKING HEAR ME. YES GO
AHEAD THE HIGH DID THE TIME AT
ALL AND I'VE ONLY OPPOSE EIGHTY
FIVE. NEXT WE GO TO LINE FIVE
TO EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NEIGHBOR KAREN OF AMERICA I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORTER OF
ACA FIVE. THANK YOU. THE NEXT
TO GO TO LINE FOUR ONE NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IS IT ME HELLO
YES OKAY I'M MY NAME IS
STEPHANIE I'M FROM ONE HIGH I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. EIGHTY EIGHT
BY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WE HAVE LINE FIVE THREE ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
TO HANG YOUNG I'M FROM SANTA
CLARA CALIFORNIA AND ON THE
STRONGLY- COMPENSATION TO A
THREE EIGHTY FIVE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THE CLIP LINE FIVE
THREE FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS PENG MADE
HANG OUT REPRESENT. TWENTY FOUR
FROM THE FACTIONS ALRIGHT
ORGANIZES IN THAT FRANCISCO I'M
CALLING. WITH ANNIKA SUPPORT
FOR AC. FIVE AND NEXT WE GO TO
LINE FOUR EIGHT FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI UNANIMOUS THIRTEEN
FROM CHINO CALIFORNIA I'M
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO EIGHT
EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE THANK YOU. AN
X. RAY OF LIGHT FOUR THREE ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THREE WANT TO
CHECK WITH US THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DONNA
CHUCKLED I'M CALLING FROM
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA. GRADUATE OF
BERKLEY LAW I CAN STRONG OF.
EIGHTY FIVE. NEXT HEADLINE FIVE
FOUR TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
MY NAME THAT ONLY I REPRESENT
THEIR POGO COMMUNITY WHICH HAS
MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED
SIGNATURES TO STRONGLY OF
EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT REDLINE FIVE
FOUR SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS JOHN I'M REPRESENTING-
A FEW PEOPLE IN MY NEIGHBORHOOD
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THE RACES
ACE A FIGHT THANK YOU. AND NEXT
WE HAVE LINES FOUR FIVE TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I YES THE
FUTURE ALSO C<c.cyan>G A LA COUNTY</c>
I'M A STARTED- UP CLOSE THE
BILL IS THERE FIVE YEAH THANK
YOU. AND NEXT WE HAVE LINE TWO
SIX ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. IF
SIX ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MOVING ON WILL GO TO LINE FIVE
FIVE FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
OUR THIS IS TOM WE OVERNIGHTED
SO SOFTWARE CANCELLATIONS WAS
OVER FIVE HUNDRED MEMBERS WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHTY EIGHT
FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU AN
XRAY OF NINE FIVE FIVE FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BE A LAW FIRM
TRY VARIATION ASSOCIATION. TO
OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE.
NEXT HEADLINE FIVE THREE EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALL HELLO.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE CONTINUE. HELLO YEAH
IT'S ME. YES GO AHEAD I'M SORRY
I THINK THE HIGHER FROM ONE
THAT I DON'T OF COURSE IT'S A
FINE. START BY GETTING. THANK
YOU AND NEXT WE GO TO LINE FIVE
FIVE TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS CINDY SAID THE BILL
FROM SANTA CLARA COUNTY I
REPRESENT OF ALL FOUR FEET
NOBODY PEOPLE ARE INVOLVED IN.
AND SO WE HAVE OVER FOUR
HUNDRED TO THIRTEEN PEOPLE AND
WE ARE STRONGLY AGAINST HER-
OKAY THE EIGHT THE EIGHT FIVE
THREE SIX. THE CLIMATE. THANK
YOU WE GOT A LINE THREE FOUR
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI IT'S
ME RIGHT. YES GO AHEAD YEAH HI
I'M VACATION AND LOCAL STATE I
AM REGRETTING NINETEEN
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD MAYES JOHN LATE A
POLICY THAT THE WILL EIGHT
EIGHT EIGHT FIVE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT HAVE LINE FIVE
SIX THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
MY NAME IS ALEX ON THE FROM ARE
YOU COUNTY I STRONGLY OPPOSE
EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT HAVE LINE FIVE
SIX EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS KINDA HEARING
REPRESENTING THE FRESNO METRO
PLAQUE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN
THE CITY OF FRESNO WE ARE
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF ACA
FIVE. THANK YOU. AND WE'RE
GOING OUT TO LINE THREE THREE
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS THERESA FROM ON SEVEN
BARNETT AND A MEMBER OF. THE
FOUNDATION AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE H. P. EIGHTY FIVE THANK
HAVE NO ONE FURTHER IN Q. THANK
YOU I'M GLAD I THINK WE GOT
EVERYBODY WHO WANTED TO AYE AYE
WAS TEXTED THAT PEOPLE CAN GET
THROUGH BUT I THINK THEY DID SO
I'M GLAD I THINK WE HEARD
EVERYBODY'S VOICE. I WANT TO
THANK OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO STUCK WITH
US THROUGH ALL THE PUBLIC
COMMENT A COUPLE OF US HERE-
AND NICK I WANT TO THANK YOU
WHAT A GREAT OPERATOR YOU WERE
IN- APPRECIATE YOUR SERVICE
HERE TODAY. MUCH HAVE A
WONDERFUL EVENING WITH THAT WE
CAN CLEAR THE APPROPRIATIONS
HEARING.